[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
anything can happen on friday the 13th
and it did at the super bet chess
classic in bucharest romania with the
potential for a shake-up at the top most
leaders avoided any freaky play and
steered towards safe draws but levon
aronian is proving to be a grandmaster
escape artist as well as chess player
after saving another wild position and
his chances of winning the tournament
the stage is set for an epic final day
of classical games day nine of heart
racing chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 9 of the
2022 superbad chess classic held here in
bucharest romania this is it the
championship day the day where victor
will be crowned and we're going to know
who the champion of the super bad chess
classic is the first stop of the grand
chester will it be wesley saw will it be
leveraging or somebody else let's go to
the studio and find out with yasser
peter and alejand
fabulous footage of springtime in in the
romanian capital as we welcome you to
our coverage of the last round of the
superb chess classic in bucharest our
first stop of the 2022 grand chess tour
morning i'm peter swindler and with me
is the inimitable yasser serevan peter
good morning to you hello everyone
bucharest has featured some great
fighting chess but it's also featured
some noteworthy howlers
what will happen in this all-important
decisive final round game peter
set the stage for our current standings
yeah we have a very exciting round in
front of us with three players uh
realistically uh in with the chance of
winning the tournament uh wesley and one
are ahead of the field and five out of
eight plus two
uh their their path there has been
somewhat different in spirit but uh
technically they're they're completely
tied on two wins and no losses and mvl
they're in clear third on plus one the
tournament has been very very tightly
bunched together and uh mbl is
the only one with a realistic chance of
dying and dying with with our leaders
with the rest of the field you know
fighting for pride and
perhaps
uh it's
as a chess player you know how important
it is to the last impression of the
tournament is the one that stays with
you
so winning in the last round makes you a
lot more optimistic about uh the
tournament i just finished there will be
plenty i'm sure plenty of fights for
today and our format as we close this
event
uh the formula is a template around
robin with uh
90 minutes for the first 40 moves and 30
minutes for the rest of the game with a
30 second increment from one uh the time
control that is
sort of universally accepted in uh
official tournaments these days uh no
draw offers and uh the standard scoring
system is in place with a point for a
win and powerpoint
playoffs are a realistic possibility how
do how would they work peter uh
absolutely uh no mathematical tie breaks
are employed here
which i think is a very uh
very good approach exactly so
we get we get this this situation where
if only two players are tied they play a
couple of games of
classical rapid 15 plus 10 these days is
a the rapid time control the the one
that is used almost everywhere uh if
it's a tie of
three or more players in this case i'm
guessing three yeah more than three
would require some some miracles right
uh then they will play uh around robin
uh ten plus five not fifteen plus five
because of uh the amount of games they
would have to play and time constraints
and if there is still a tie after all
that an armageddon game is uh ahead of
us with five minutes for wide four
minutes for black and black gets uh
drawers
alejandro good to see you my friend good
morning good morning definitely early
today championship saturday one hour
earlier but i'm excited for it it's
gonna be a great round let's see what's
happening in the tournament so far
starting with the amount of decisive
games to me it feels a little unfair to
the tournament we had so many
opportunities in which tournament
tournament games could go one way or
another but still we have 13 decisive
games out of 40 32
not too bad not too bad in the
tournament
white has done slightly worse than black
and this is not a usual statistic for
our events six wins for white seven wins
for the black piece is pretty good there
led by levon aronian of course nine out
of the ten players have won at least one
game except for a rich rapport he has
been unable to win so far in the event
and the tournament leaders they haven't
lost a single game but as you mentioned
peter completely different tournaments
that they've had at least spiritually
because lewanda rojan he's been very
very lucky in some rounds definitely his
game yesterday against jane pomnyacci
was lucky and lucky escaped in the
endgame but he was also incredibly lucky
to escape against alireza furusha he did
take advantage of his opponent's
mistakes in round four against lanier
dominguez and in round six just mauling
maxima shayla graf in that vienna game
both of his wins coming with the black
pieces meanwhile wesley won early in
round number one against chakra medyarov
and in number round number four with
jane pognachi a long end game that his
opponent fell under pressure and now
he's on plus two he has a tough pairing
ahead of course the tournament is not
over we do think playoffs are very
likely but everything to be played for
still in bucharest let's see our key
pairings with our friends there
christian and anastasia
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to the final day of the 2022
super bad chess classic this is it the
championship round the round where a
king will be crowned from location here
in bucharest romania to give you all the
live updates i'm your host grand master
christian carrillo joined by my co-host
grant woman grandmaster anastasia
carlovich anastasia welcome back to the
show tell us a bit as we are getting
ready for the players to arrive what
have you been doing this morning hello
christian hello everyone it's nice to be
here for the last decisive round my day
started quite early i gave already a few
lessons to refugee camp to girls in the
refugee camp in kakuma kenya and of
course i've been talking about the
granches tour and i told them who are on
the on the top right now so looking
forward to the last round what about you
christian how was your day that was
quite a morning uh you had for me it was
more about the calm before the storm i
was relaxing i took a walk in the park
just waiting for the fights to begin and
speaking of fights what games do you
have in mind for today
of course i mean we're looking um i mean
we will check of course the games of the
leaders and levon are young players
today um of course against shakirian
mamidjarov what a crazy life i mean
shakira media was fighting for the first
place last year and today he has to
fight not to be in on the last place uh
so
leonardo has a better score against
chakriar and looking forward definitely
to maybe improve even his points
today and probably win the tournament if
he wins this game who knows um it's
going to be a very interesting fight
what about you christian that is
definitely a titanic clash i have to say
the one between lev and mama the arrow
we know there are good bodies but one
game that i have my eyes on and i bet
you guys have your eyes on as well is of
course the clash between the two
americans lanier dominguez and wesley so
lanier is trailing the leader wesley by
one point so right now he has a clear
shot at potentially catching the leader
we see the head up between these two
players two wins for a lanyard two
losses and seven draws one thing about
lanier and his tournament that he's had
in general we see lanier making a lot of
draws winning one or two games and then
just cruising throughout the event in
this one in this event here in bucharest
he had the topsy turvy event he lost two
games he won two games and right now
definitely he will pile on the pressure
on the leader and potentially try to win
this event we have a lot of fights ahead
of us here in the championship round
guys back to you in st louis thank you
christian and peter let's take a look at
all the pairings for this all decisive
all-important final round yeah one final
one final set of pairings uh the two
games that our friends in bucharest
spoke about are of course the the ones
that attract attention uh live on with
white uh with the white pieces against
shaq and uh
the game between uh lanier and wesley
but there is plenty to look uh to look
for otherwise
as well uh richard perhaps
still still in with a shout to to to
improve his impressions of the
tournament with the white pieces against
yanipamnish even though he he has been
and he is a very very you know sincere
interviewee
he seems very downcast and clearly you
know
wouldn't mind already be being in warsaw
and starting the next one uh but that is
a very interesting pairing and of course
the one that we are very much looking
forward to is the game between reza
ferruga
and uh and mbl there uh
mvl i think was quite instrumental in in
the idea of erosion moving moving to
france and playing under the french flag
i think they're under they're on very
very good terms
uh but uh alireza is a very very
ambitious young man and that potentially
maybe makes him want to win this game
even more and there is also the
tournament considerations too
to think about because if he wins he is
uh i'm guessing guaranteed at least to
tie for third i would say
whereas for for mvl if he somehow
manages to
get the better of this matchup he could
get into taipei first if none of our
leaders win today well you're talking
about all what what winning and jocking
for position might mean and what are
they fighting for peter because those
extra half points could be very
meaningful extremely crucial with with
how tightly uh the the standings are
bunched together right now uh as you can
see
plentiful price fund as
is the case and
with gct in general it's increased by 25
000
over yeah
last year's price fund and 100 grand up
top
and
12 or 13 gct points depending on whether
you win with tie breaks or without a
hundred thousand prefer 65 000 per
second that's a big diff
350 000 in total as we see these two
players
linear and wesley getting uh ready for a
kind yeah and this is uh this is someone
i know quite well this is a a good
friend of mine natalie who is a
grandmaster from from ukraine she won
the european women's twice and is now
very involved in
city governance in her hometown of
odessa
uh yeah very nice very nice seeing her
make the correct first move there
i'm glad sure
where's the english when you need it uh
nice to see natalie as well
and uh speaking of uh chess yeah and
i think there's going to be a one more
one more first movement yeah we can we
can i can pass this one over to you yeah
uh
uh romania's first grandmaster
giorgio florian
played all over the world uh
broke into the top ten uh played nine
world championship work nine in games
against world champions actually more
played nine different world champions
and uh
florian georgie at the board once more
one d2d4 and you can see with his little
elegance how he yeah he knows how to
make a definite flourish there yes you
but actually the way he put it back i
think gives gives the way that he's just
play even more than the way the way he
put it forward like that nice
as he said in his book uh chess
there you have it i succeed for one uh
as well
predictions
playoffs
or yet i think playoffs are huge
favorites today yeah and of the
scenarios we have in front of us i think
the one scenario that is
although the likeliest to to avoid
playoffs is is left winning with the
white piece i don't think i mean
i don't want to you know
jinxle
doesn't lose very many with the white
pieces and wesley also uh specifically
against wesley wesley is a tremendously
strong player but in a situation that
he's in uh right now in in
the tournament's endings being what they
are
i don't think wesley will
you know attempt to just balance it very
much i think he is okay making a draw
today feeling that you know winning
chess games is hard levon starts you
know with white it's a favorable matchup
for him because he as we've seen on our
screen he has a lifetime
lifetime positive score against shakhtar
but still
uh no one is ever guaranteed to be
charged with the white pieces
and
knowing knowing how well booked up
linear is in the openings i'm expecting
wesley to play it safe
to i mean obviously if he gets a chance
he will we have seen in this tournament
how well he does when people give him
uh you know i'll buttress further your
point it is remarkable that lavonne with
the white pieces finds himself with like
you say the best opportunity of winning
the event clear and alejandra when you
think about the positions that lavon has
had
stating that he's about to win clear
first is rather shocking it's like his
opponents could have chomped half a
point here half a point there but they
didn't he proved resilient he found
resources all the way to the end that
rook c1 that he played against nepo
yesterday
ah that game was a cold shower for his
opponent but he's hung in there and
that's part of the fight of in this
tournament right yeah very frustr one
very very frustrated nepa while you were
talking peter about the
uh
pairings today uh we broke away for a
shot of the two players uh rich richie
and nepo at the board and you saw two
very
disgusted gladiators
yeah in that particular shot yeah you
have it alejandro used used the word
lucky uh quite a bit when introducing
left tournament and
it feels both sort of correct and
incorrect because in order not to lose
positions that levon hasn't lost against
players of alireza and jan's caliber
you're fighting hard yes you did
probably do something wrong to get in
those positions but then you need to you
know scrape and and and fight tooth and
nail to to stay alive and right he found
study-like ideas in both games to to
stay afloat and uh
yeah you still you still call it lucky
right because that's the easy way to
describe it but it's not really luck in
the universal understanding of the word
it's
players make their own too absolutely
yeah
levon
is definitely one of the great great
fighters uh no question about it i'm
surprised they're already on move number
three here between levon and ernie and
shakhman but therefore knight c3
inviting the four knights it's kind of a
rare
guest nowadays right level of chess that
is interesting i wonder if he's going to
say i want i won two games with black in
this tournament i'm just gonna go knight
f6 a3 and play one more he'd like that
he did that in a magnus store once i'm
honestly not joking because i think that
like the classical four nights these
days is
very very empty right uh and he has
played he has played the four knights as
well he has been has been known to just
play 4g4 here i don't think he is very
much a bishop b5 player and bishop b5
does these days against somebody who is
booked up lead to a number of
seemingly completely forced draws after
94 specifically after bishop before you
get the game but after 94 there are some
lines which continue until move 25 and
then end in repetitions it gets very
very sharp but it means sharp stands for
you know it doesn't really mean much
when everything has been properly
analyzed with good engines
uh so yeah i'm i'm expecting either
4d4 and then some kind of a bite uh you
know try try some kind of a small new
idea in in those lines but you're not
really fighting for very much or you
could play a3 uh or perhaps g3 but i
think a3 of the two move of those two
moves i think a3 is more likely knowing
knowing you know what kind of a player
levon is
i think this is more likely than g3 and
and just saying uh yeah let's play a
game of chess i don't particularly want
to contest theory
and what's happening in our uh linear
wesley so uh game uh
alejandro uh it's just gonna be an
italian we have only a few moves on the
board still yeah yeah we're just waiting
to see the definition of the variations
this is the italian opening we've seen
it plenty in this tournament uh the idea
of going d5 quickly has been something
that we've been seeing very often but of
course there's so many ways to handle
this position wesley employs pretty much
all of them that's what makes him so
hard to prepare against especially in
this e45 lines so in italian here
enviou playing what looks like a king's
indian slash grunfeld you see that he
still has the option of going d6 or d5
no queen's guide would accept that he
could have gone d4 d5 but none of that
against alireza will be a little bit
more of a fun game alireza plays the
move g3 the fiance variation and now
it's up to nbl whether he wants to play
king's indian or the more traditional c6
and d5 grunfeld which he's chosen a
little bit more of a solid approach but
yeah emile has been has been a
symmetrical greenfield player for quite
some time yeah i actually uh the the
repertoire i gave in my in my greenfield
course was in part inspired uh by by
what mvl had been doing yeah he did
dabble sometimes with castling knight c6
before playing the move d5 absolutely
yeah but uh but for them for the most
part he's been playing 65 systems and
doing quite well with them so yeah i was
i was
expecting that more more than anything
else
um
just turn our attention for a moment to
the game
between daniel and fabi because i think
fabby is a very hard player to nail down
in terms of his defenses
he plays a lot he plays everything and
he plays
well the slav today after 95 97 knight
takes e4 earlier in the tournament we
have seen uh knight b6 yeah richie
played this against levon the 96 line
but there was also this really really
crazy game between
11 and alireza which which did feature
them of queen c7 which used to be the
main line and then people started
shifting away from it exactly and i
wonder you know how much of it was
inspired by the fact that alireza
seemingly you know indicated that he
thinks it's fine right because i think
the reputation of the line uh
i i don't follow the theory of this of
these particular slavs very closely or
not at all to be honest right but it it
definitely at the very least became
unfashionable it was very very
fashionable the turn of the millennium
yeah uh uh
due to mainly the efforts of alexander
marzevic and and the introduction of the
move g5 here
and then it sort of disappeared which to
me indicates that people have started
getting the grips properly with how to
how to meet it and
uh it's it wasn't working as well as it
was
prior to that moment
but if i be playing this i haven't
really seen him play this very much or
maybe not at all yeah
but
it's a very fighting it's a very sharp
fighting position and perhaps also an
indication that he wants
you know a full-blown struggle today and
not just to equalize and
go home and go to warsaw
gtg3 an obviously very combative move
black just posted his queen on c7 and
what do we love about development
developing with gain of time so bishop
f4 on white's agenda as we see lavonne
as always uh sporting a new fashion new
look yeah
um
yeah if i for d5 95 before all of this
already on the board knight fg7 is
pretty much forced uh the big questions
the one you you've got on your screen
it's progressing very quickly towards
potentially the morris average variation
uh after bishop g2 of course you are not
obliged to uh sorry i'm just having a
there it is we'll get about it yeah yeah
okay they have progressed too yeah
you're not obliged to play g5 after
bishop g2 but you're
you know considering that i haven't seen
uh fabi play this very much i don't
expect him to play f6 and play the old
lines which really do only seem to aim
to equalize whereas g5
does lead to very double-edged and uh
yeah you go back to the 1935's uh world
championship between max irva
and alexander alakine with the move f7
f6 g7 g5 definitely the most topical
move and
it looks to me like yeah g5 played
already
has already played chief if i've played
already i will uh you know my my first
slice of humble pie today i said i said
levon will play either g4 or a3 he has
of course played bishop b5
uh
in the four nights
one of the very very very lengthy uh
draw uh long-winded uh theoretical draws
uh over to you alejandra what do you
have for us
we have a very typical nimzo indian in
the game between richard rapport and
jane pomnyacci
but a little bit of a twist here this
position
after the move a3 this is the kappa
blanco or classical nimzo indian bishop
takes c3 queen takes c3 d5 bishop g5
takes takes b6 this has been seen many
times at top level of chess
rook d1 and bishop a6 so you hit the
queen and here queasy two has been tried
a few times for an advantage queen a4 is
certainly the main line trying to force
black into playing queen d7 at some
point so when you take on f6 you might
be forced to take with the pawn or also
to avoid the move knight bd7 coming up
but richie played the move queen c1
i've never seen this move it's a novelty
at least according to my lead chess
database i don't know what the advantage
is of having the queen on c1 over the
queen on c2 but we're gonna have to find
out because nepa is playing what seems
to be the most logical way of playing
knight bd7 followed with either rook c8
or queen c prepares c5 and i
get it it's a novelty i assume there's
some kind of new idea behind it but what
could possibly be the advantage of
having the queen on c1 over the queen on
c2 when you're trying to fight for the
advantage we're going to find out i
don't think that white really has the
time to transfer this queen to the king
side or anything like that you still
have to develop your king side so we'll
we'll tune in knight f3 are already on
the board i expect one of these two
moves rook c8 or queen c8 and just
prepare c5 for the next turn and
without the move e4 coming because this
is usually why you play them with queen
c2 right you have e4 coming uh i don't
really know what's going to happen i
guess you could play e4 anyway because
you could still play g5 you don't really
want to play
i was going to play
is a little more precise perhaps yeah
quincy it also i mean rook ca doesn't
look illogical as well just trying to
prepare for
uh
uh prepare for the c5 break but
yeah richie already played knight of
three
um yeah that's interesting and an e4 and
yeah if you go for h65 i'm assuming the
queen and civilian is i assume so right
if after rook c8 e4 you take you take h6
and we're not going to sacrifice this
somehow either with bishop h4 would have
to yeah you have to there's no choice
but at this point it might also win the
computer says it is winning
to do this king h7 e5 you attack the
knight and you can't move the knight
because check would pick up the queen so
perhaps this is the reason the queen is
on c1 in some ways it depends upon e4
indirectly and it's just a little
different twist uh we'll see what nepal
plays after knight f3
thank you alejandro and in the meantime
we have a somewhat uh dispiriting set of
developments in our four nights game
because levon
uh
hard to imagine this being very very
ambitious for why the full symmetry
white of course has the tempo because
white is the one
starting
the game but the position is very
symmetrical black has no semblance no
semblance of weaknesses anywhere
um
and uh yeah it does look like levon uh
for today uh did not feel like taking
shut down taking too many risks you know
this is not a draw yet if black plays
imprecisely and white i know gets some
pressure against the c7 pawn for
instance
uh you do see these positions uh you
know evolve into
situations where black has to defend for
the rest of the game and
it might become a bit unpleasant but
you get the feeling that it really is a
matter of i don't know a couple of
precise moves here and it all dissipates
just due to you know complete symmetry
uh i remember when i was a kid there was
a book
uh that i had studied in it and it was
uh the
the white player was weiss
versus schwartz
and it was like an identical mirror game
throughout
and uh a draw agreed so this game
unfortunately uh well i mean lavon was
probably saying look i've had some
fantastic
luck
in this event it'd be nice if i finished
in the type of first with wesley so i'm
going to shut this down for
shaq
what a disaster i mean not the way of
putting it i mean he came into the
event as the defending champion people i
mean this mission is not a disaster i
don't think shaq will mind well not
having a short shorter day today but
yeah the tournament in general yeah he
he did end up winning winning a game
against uh against nepo uh in round
seven but even that was somewhat spoiled
i think for him by the way the
realization by the realization that he
he made he made at least one sort of
glaring mistake uh
on on the way uh which which always does
kind of put a dampener on
your feelings about your victories yeah
um yeah not not really a particularly
fun fun event he will not remember it
too fondly i would think no
queen f6 on the board and let me just go
around the horn okay we're still uh
waiting for ian's still thinking uh
plenty of choices you could no i won't
say you could maybe even make an
argument for c5 gt takes c5 rook ca but
that looks like allowing bishop to xf6
with the pin
is probably ill-advised yeah i would
think so yeah i don't think because yeah
this is not uh what you attack no gfgf
i'm not even going to discuss exactly
you know my idea would be to maybe take
with the queen and rook d7 rook c5 and
claim i have compensation for the piece
but
i mean yeah it's it's it's fine it's
okay not not five anymore it's 6 a.m and
uh
i'm a bit a bit dizzy here you know
obviously you don't want to be giving up
uh
and uh
in the grundfeld you know the one game i
feel reasonably confident talking about
i think this is what i give and sort of
reasonably confident not very confident
but reasonably confident 95 is a move
that
sort of didn't exist
as a serious option like people took on
d5 there as a matter of course or you
could play b3 you could play queen b3
protecting c4 in those ways knight bg-2
is a move all of those moves are of
course like major major theoretical
uh
starting points but 95 specifically
without the trade on d5
was always a very very fringe move until
kramnik started making it as usual and
then and then you start paying attention
yeah yeah let the parade yeah you start
paying attention to uh to it and i
personally lost the game to him in this
position
uh
help sells
hope sales of the chesapeake of course
and i i think i originated yeah i think
i ended up recommending uh specifically
this d5 takes everything
in my game against vladimir i played
bishop six immediately which is also a
very logical idea
uh but i think yeah knight e3 here i'm
not sure is can that
yeah not the three is a playable move
but i don't think it's a central move i
think they do recapture on c4
immediately immediately yeah we play
bishop b6
uh
white probably plays against knight a3
or knight takes e4 i guess against like
the xc4 yeah okay i mean after knight e3
i can also play b6 probably with
transpositions but yeah this position is
what i was discussing mainly and after
b3
uh i think i started with a6 but the
point here is we we have pretty much
always have the option of playing bishop
d5 and trading the g2 bishop
off the board but we don't have to do it
immediately because a very typical
grunfeld idea of just playing knight a6
and trying to push for c65 as early as
possible is also something that could be
entertained here
white does retain some hopes because
it's not that easy to push c5 in every
single position here but i felt that
uh these lines do offer black
uh
relative equality while also keeping the
game of low to a degree 93 we get i
guess we go knight g5 we can probably
start with bishop d5 previous move as
well
and uh
[Music]
this is this is playable this is uh i
think it's a very good choice by lereza
because
of the things you can do against the
symmetrical c65 grinfield
this argument arguably gives you the
least explored
positions while retaining a short
advantage because you can do something
completely random and it will not be
heavily theoretically uh you know
studied but it will also completely
you know lose any hope of getting
anywhere with white out of the opening
whereas this
as is often the case with you know
kramnik endorsed ideas
um this definitely does require uh
precision and uh is a nice nice little
uh try which okay can i invite you down
the r rabbit hole just a little bit
after knight eight three if you did one
yeah bishop e6 knight takes e4 i'm not
sure you actually won the one the other
knights in in this uh configuration well
bishop h3 is definitely something they
do in these types of positions right
because i was trying to head down the
light square bishop yeah but i don't
think like when the when the knights are
on e5 and c4 i don't think i have to
play knight g5 necessarily i can start
with knight
yeah sorry bishop d5 yeah i can start
with knight dudes with bd7 or perhaps
even knight g4 is a movie you could
think about knight g4
yeah i don't know i can see why people
need to get your course
yeah g4 is because first move that would
uh jump to my mind i i think the point
about the structure is that if all four
knights somehow come off the board black
is more or less instantly fine because
your structure is way way way too solid
for white to you know exert any pressure
exactly so if i get if i get the trade
if i get to trade the f6 knight for the
e5 knight and then go knight bg7 next
move it will white will potentially
struggle to actually keep the knights on
the board i see and then i mean i'm
slightly
ever so slightly more passive in terms
of the pawn structure but it's just not
very much
um so just to mattress the point here i
will take on c4 i think even though oh
even in
c4 okay and the the the pawn on d4 is
kind of under pressure right yes it's
hanging it's not quite clear how to
protect it if you play knight e5 i think
i will quite happily take on if i've
taken d1 take it
as
player you don't like being pawns ahead
you like being pawns behind yeah well
you do have to make exceptions so that
people kind of start second second
guessing you're second-guessing your
decision good point yeah and if you play
something like this p3 i play 97 i
really don't see why black is in in any
way in trouble
all right well keep an eye on this one
and alejandro what do you have for us in
the fappy game we have a theoretical
discussion in this kind of mirozovich
sloth that we're seeing between dak and
fabiano caruana
but a little bit of a twist and i don't
know if fabi's familiar with the twist
because he's not moving we know that
favi loves playing his uh
preparation pretty quickly he's not the
type of player that likes to hide his
hand or pretend that he doesn't remember
a variation if he remembers it he just
plays it and in this case he's stuck
after the move castle in this position
after g5 which you guys mentioned of
course the move 93 is the main line it's
been the main line since that's time
game between morozovic and kasparov in
the year 2000
but bishop takes e5 is a variation that
exists this is not a variation that is
particularly new
we have seen it several times throughout
the years and after knight takes e5 the
main line is queen d4 you have to play
f6 at this point you have to defend this
knight and there's this ugly pin on the
d4h8 diagonal so there's no choice but
to move f6
and the main move by the fire in this
position is castles 93 also exists but
castles is the most logical you can see
already the differences between this
kind of positions and the ones that we
saw in for example the game between
levon aronian and firuja which we had
the same
uh
opening
and you see in this position black
cannot castle long uh
difficult to attack here because you
castle long as white but this is a
little bit more insecure you're not
gonna be throwing the pawns forward
definitely a different variation a
different type of sharpness to it as
white might be looking to blast open the
center with the move f4 take advantage
of the king of being in the center for
the time being so certainly a very sharp
position
plenty of games have been played from
here we see mvl has played this against
levon adronian morozevich himself played
it with black bujong ji championed this
variation with the black side in the
late 2000s so certainly it's something
that we've seen at the top level of
chess many times however favi is
currently stuck he's not playing at the
moment uh most people play bishop e7
rook d8 has been seen my engine is
throwing bishop e6 is an interesting
idea tons of things to consider here but
again curious to me that he hasn't made
a move yet
wow
yeah this is uh yeah there's definitely
going to be a nice theoretical battle i
just like to turn our attention because
we haven't mentioned it yet uh lanier
versus wesley so we spoke about it a
little bit but yeah it was move five and
they have progressed far far possible
five by this point it was a joke of
uh bishop c4 bishop c5 joker piano as
opposed to the two knights
i think apart from the lines with the
immediate d75 from move six what uh what
wesley has done here is maybe the most
fashionable
of all the options black has this early
a7a5 which
has become very very topical because of
white understood at some point that
gaining space
gaining space on on the queen side with
b4 and a4 is very beneficial to white so
a5 aims to prevent that
uh rookie one castles linear actually is
one of the sort of most devoted
champions of the idea of playing bishop
h5 bishop sir bishop g5 bishop h4
when black castles without h6 so i'm
curious as to why
uh he didn't do it here but all of these
move orders are ever so slightly
different
and i do know that this is arguably the
absolute central position of the joco
piano uh like the one of the bishop b6
yeah uh
together with uh
a couple of others i would say that this
is maybe the most heavily discussed
position in the theory of the entire
line including knight d7 97 is a bit of
a
less less uh well
well-studied move queen b8 is by far the
most important
that that was the move that i
knew best i i
i didn't even know that knight d7 was a
event
move
actually
and you see and you see that very strong
players have played this uh there's a
very recent game played uh by sergey
azarov on the black side of this and uh
the the the uric revolution played 97
earlier against arientari the idea i
guess is to uh yeah push this pushy 65
as early as possible and to try to
equalize this this way queen v8 leads to
unbelievable messes yeah and uh once
again we see wesley uh you know making a
conscious choice to sort of play solid
positional chess instead of getting
involved with
yeah this these are the standings uh
prior to this round and yeah the three
players are singled well not singled
it's three of them
uh chosen there on your screen uh are
the ones in contention for
uh for the first prize most likely with
the opening in the books levon ironian
seems
geared towards a drop it does appear
that this one
is giving it seems very very equal to me
there could still be some things
happening but it's less likely than
prior to the start of the round
should wesley draw that would give mvo
um an opening if you will a chance to
type even though uh you know the uh the
g3 grindfeld is
not something that fills your heart with
joy in terms of winning prospects but
the position is still very much alive
there in the ferruja mvl game
and to finish with uh with wesley's
position they're still blitzing away i
mean all of these moves queen f6
queenie ii
rook
f8 to d8 rookie jiban which is also an
awkward move to try to explain to our
audience well a2 is hanging i think you
your training's working
okay no i mean if we're comparing rook
81
i think we are gg and we are of course
yeah a2 might might hang at some point
so you play rookie g1 rookie one by the
way created a kind of a cute tactical
thread of rook takes d7 which is why
bishop fate was played in response
there's also this kind of a dance where
black clearly is happy with bishop takes
c5
because
wesley has been allowing it for a bit
but
not happy enough to take on e3
themselves developing the the knight on
this one four wide right and here this
kind of a
stalemate was broken by the bishop going
away to a fade
i must say i like this move a lot
because i i i'm not afraid afraid it's a
strong word
the knight on g3 doesn't bother me as
much as the knight on e3 the knight on
e3 going to d5 will be disturbing
absolutely and knight h3 creates a kind
of a semi idea of knight h5 uh but the
queen i think quite happily just goes
back to e7 exactly yeah h4 i would force
it to h7 which is maybe sub-optimal but
a5 a4 maybe stopping a2a4 and just
generally gaining some space on the
queen side this is very much why they
play uh a5 in all these lines the idea
of gaining space on the queen side
getting gaining a foothold
for you know potential counterplay
in this particular setup i'm not
entirely sure what it does
but it doesn't have to do anything
immediately it's just a very useful pawn
to have which restricts white's options
on that side of the board kind of
locking the a2 pawn into
say a target i kind of like that a5 a4
and
from the speed of play
i'm guessing that we still uh deep into
theory and theory recognizes everything
it's a very rare line and i don't think
it's it's official theory so to speak
but it's something they have clearly
looked at before in both players yeah
this is seemingly the first pause in the
game within year on a very very
comfortable 125
looking yeah yeah yeah which by move 16
is
you know not a given
where linear is concerned uh jump right
in alejandro your perspective of this uh
position well we're out of theory and
clearly linear doesn't know what the
engine thinks so let's go back and forth
between us let's see what we can try to
find out with the position i hate
analyzing this kind of variations with
the engines because i've looked at a lot
of italian throughout the last few years
it surged in popularity you had to look
at it especially when i was working with
2600s on my university team it feels
like everybody's playing italian with
both black and white so you inevitably
have to look at it so what would you
consider
white's plan following moves kind of
maneuvers that you want to play in this
position because
this pawn on a2 it is getting hit you
don't really want to put it on a3
because we should be three super
annoying
you could play bishops
before i think this is why we played a4
i think bishop c4 gets met by knight a5
yes and if bishop c4 knight a5 is pretty
annoying because if you take on e6 queen
takes e6 the queen has the same pressure
that the bishop had exerting on the a2
square and i never want to play a3 this
pawn on a4 is awesome with clamping down
the structure we've seen it in recent
games for example this one in lavon
ironian with the black pieces against
fabiano carona where the bishop on b3
just held the entire structure here on
item b3 would be very annoying so what
is white's plan in this position for
uh to continue because
harder to get rid of the bishop you've
kind of maximized the knights i guess
you could consider knight h2 g4 that's
what the engine wants to do but it
doesn't apparent to me what the knight
is doing on g4 exactly now of course you
always have the option of taking on c6
but this structure is going to favor
black you might be wondering why don't
you play this as white just destroy the
structure so many weaknesses but it's
not enough it's not enough that the
pawns are potentially weak you don't
have any pieces to attack them with and
this rooks or this rook is coming to b8
and actually hitting the beat on v2 and
i think white's queen side is actually
weaker than blacks in this position so
that's why you don't see people rushing
to take on c6 and
that's just going to leave lanier with
the question what do i do with my light
square bishop i think bishop c4 is a
very logical move and the more i see the
points behind a4 i agree the more i like
it yeah and it's it's it's good that you
put the position after bishop 6bc6 on
the board because
i think for people who have looked at
these structures even a little bit it is
such a poor move that you don't consider
it but for the viewers it's really not
obvious at all so it's important to
actually demonstrate blood gets
immediate pressure on the queen side the
bishops on f8 and e6 are very very nice
pair of pieces to sort of secure the
queen side against white's incursions
and also vitsu is
a pretty serious weakness i wouldn't say
white is immediately much worse but i
would instantly prefer black after
bishop takes 6 bc6 and like long term
it's just
i'm definitely picking black hair over
over over white and uh
uh
it's just nice to show these little bits
of uh bits of uh evaluations because
uh
it's it maybe it's not immediately as as
clear as it should be here uh
the bishop bear is extremely extremely
powerful in this type of structure i
guess asked and answered
there by alejandro um i i find myself
drawn to uh knight h2 i've seen enough
rui lopez positions where the knight
comes to g4 chases out the queen the
knight drops in on f5 the queen comes to
f3
and somehow this pressure isn't so easy
to shake off it gets it gets annoying in
some positions and another thing i want
to attract attention to is i think for
me uh
i can trace it back to precisely one
specific game
the concept uh and here it's not as
striking but there was i think it was a
game uh in the candidates i played
myself in london in 2013 there was a
game that livon iranian won on the black
side of a very quiet gioco piano against
uh taymor rajabov
and in those years people like people
didn't play five yet i think uh joko
piano was just coming into its own but
the theory of the variation wasn't
developed
nowhere nearly enough like today like
today and people were still very much
playing sort of the old main line where
you play a6 and you put the bishop on a7
that was done you know as a matter of
course like you you just
did that with your hand and then you
started thinking okay and
uh in response to that uh tamer played
something very slow like you put a
bishop on b3 played the fun knight g3
and at some point levon spent two tempe
playing bishop a7 c5 and bishop c5 f8
and
at first i was kind of
surprised and i mean shocked maybe
strong but i was definitely surprised
that he spent two tempi bringing the
bishop yeah bringing the bishop from
seemingly you know a very long diagonal
where it does something you know it
controls some squares you know uh
challenges the bishop e3 if it comes
there and so on
uh but the more you think about this the
more you realize that very often as
you're mentioning you know spiritually
this is not very far from real opposites
and white often wants to do something on
the king's side exactly and having this
additional protection of having the
bishop on the fate controlling the g7
square supporting your pawn on h6 so if
you can play g7 g6 easy if you need to
just makes your king side
gel together so much more right then you
are much freer to do things on the other
sides of the board and
this by this point i think became a sort
of universal understanding that
it's often better on the fate than it is
on a7 and we see it here as well
solid i wanted to say uh a5 a4 to my
mind
i would really like you to push that
pawn one step further i would love you
to play the move a4 a3 whether i play b3
or whether i play b4 i'm not sure
and for me a desirable move would be the
move queen c2 until i see my h-pawn
being lopped off
in such a fashion yeah there could be
there could be tactical issues with this
yeah and otherwise i agree with you
quincy would be a very serious candidate
here and that was why also a second
reason why i was drawn to knight has
been played by the way uh knight h2 yeah
and uh wesley
more or less more or less instantly
replies with twin g6 he knows the knight
is coming to g4 i mean
knight h2 is about as telegraphed an
idea
as you can get
without without playing a bugle and
playing all right pretty much yes so he
he very much knows that queen g6
probably will need to be uh will need to
be done
yeah so he does it he does it first he
sidesteps knight g4
perhaps i'm not entirely sure but maybe
if you go knight g4 here black can
consider playing h5 h4 i thought about
it but i think h5 knight takes h5 i
think he's trying
to seven works yeah yeah sorry
i was going to go to h6 check also i
mean
i actually considered knight h5 and
thought it wasn't working because knight
f6 knight takes f6 exactly
you're not winning the queen this way
yeah but any other way any pretty much
takes d7
rook takes d7 actually no bishop takes
g4 i take it sorry it doesn't work good
morning st louis we are uh an hour
earlier here today very noticeably an
hour earlier
well now that okay two things come
immediately to my end now that i've
already you i've pushed you i've bullied
you away
two moves yes queen c2 first and queen
f3 with the idea of cementing the knight
to f5 peter so queen c2 first gift me
the pop yeah i i had a kind of a stupid
idea here but it is stupid so i'm going
to i i i was wondering
sort of in the spirit of solving our
queen side problems tactically on the
king side
as we were doing as we were doing in the
previous position with knight yes
i wanted to suggest knight c5 knight to
c5 yeah using the fact that if you take
on c5 to win the pawn on a4 you will
lose
g3 oh that is nice let me just show that
to everybody oops
and also knight c5 is not a horrible
move positionally but i think the issue
with it is that you can take on d8
i don't really even want to discuss
knight takes g8 it's a bit too ugly for
uh
for this early in the morning and if i
take with the rook you can take on a4
without taking on c5
right i always hate partying with my
bishops but if it's a full if it's a
full healthy board on a4 i think i will
i will you know i think that's what it
is
the the question of healthy and you know
like good and healthy uh queen c2 a dual
purpose move of um absolutely attacking
the pawn and maybe uh i think black does
play a43 though because you do yeah okay
because i think in general you would
prefer before
as a reply to b3 because it takes away
some squares it's kind of you you feel
you feel like you're playing more
proactively by playing before correct
but with the bishop on a6 exerting a
decent amount of pressure against the a2
pawn i don't think black is that unhappy
about those developments
um anybody just put it on the board b4
b2b3 is a as you say alternate choice
but i do like the idea that this knight
on d7 is temporarily stuck yeah and i'm
wondering if i can start solving that
issue immediately i
i'm sort of
i'm very undecided about the idea of
playing knight b6
knight b sounds
because
on the one hand bishop takes b6 i i very
much like the idea of having more
bishops than my opponent yes but
after that trade happens i am left with
this knight on c6 which is a bit silly
the pawns control does not really have
very many squares yeah even if it was to
get give it a turn or two exactly not
exactly my issue is i i understand it's
a poor piece but i don't understand how
to improve it right and it's the second
part that's annoying me here because you
often have pieces you would very much
like on different squares but you can
immediately say what those different
squares are right and here i am very
very unsure what i'm doing with this
piece on the other hand i i want to get
rid of your two bishops if i were white
shoes at this moment something
along the lines this actually allows me
a very cute tactic oh please worship a4
i think knight takes before works oh man
that's shiby rook gc8 rook dc8 that is
that is uh purdy and the bishop on a4
appears to
be gone gone and with it probably the
entire game yeah this is not great yeah
so it's a very unclear position but once
again we probably should limit ourselves
to
to the discussion of it it's kind of far
away from well knight h2 queen g6 let's
look at let's look at queen of three
okay i thought that was also very
sensible i just you know plonk a knight
on the five right go from there i
remember
help me on this wasn't there a game
wesley so versus godakamski it was a it
was one of these beautiful rui lopez's
where there was
uh
and wesley
or got it one with the white pieces and
very very nice style by putting a knight
on f5 you don't remember okay he's easy
good morning saint louis
we'll warm up as the broadcast gets
going but yeah there was a u.s
championship so
you're shaming alejandra for not
remembering uh a very vague description
do you remember that one time where
wesley played god and put a knight on f5
yeah
that wasn't good
it was good um i mean that three
yeah of three i'll interrupt you guys
for a second that is a fascinating
position but i wanted to take a look at
this one as it's just exploding oh and
it's still theory so i'm wondering what
favi is thinking about this remembering
what's going on
f6 castles bishop e6 i did say the
engine did like this move and it's been
played before
golfing tried this position with the
white pieces a couple of times including
a game against mirosevic so certainly
two experts of this position have played
it up f4 played in this position it is
apparently uh the main line everybody's
played f4 so far that's caught into this
position the point is that if you take
on c4 here i'm gonna take on f6 and you
have this double attack against the
bishop on e6 and the rook on eight shade
apparently this is deadly but it's not
deadly if you throw in the move
g takes f4 because after g takes f4
knight takes f4 queen takes f6 there's
two ways to do this um my engine likes
queen f7 but everybody's done it through
bishop f7 the idea is that when you take
on h8 i have this counter attack queen
takes f4 check now the queen could have
gone through f7 so there's also bishop
f5 ideas and after king b1 bishop g6
check which is what everybody's played
king a1 you see that this position
starts getting into a mess the king's in
the middle
white is currently up on exchange and
not just any exchange because rook hf1
is coming attacking the queen attacking
the rook so white is
also attacking black but blacks to move
so they have the initiative for the
moment uh the move knight e3 has been
played in some games including an old
game of yobaba against carlson yobaba
won that game in 2005 and so knight e3
has been essayed rook hf1 has been seen
rook t2 the engines are saying is very
strong because your allow knight takes
g2 but it doesn't quite work it's a huge
mess the engines have looked at this
before though there is precedent to this
position but
judging by the time they actually would
have thought usually 30 minutes to get
to this position he is very well aware
of the theory and fabi fabi's the one
that's not favi which is supposed to be
the better prepared player 2800 going to
the candidates
he's
doesn't seem aware of the variations in
this position because he's just going
into the tank
well let's jump to
bucharest and get their impressions of
you from romania
christian
thank you yasser yes i do want to talk a
little bit about the approach these
players and in general professional
players uh take to the final round how
do you stifle the emotions how do you
shut down the nerves but also i want to
talk about how do you approach it from a
technical point of view what variations
you're going to choose and so on so
let's start with the technical part and
try to understand what these players and
what their thought process was going
into this round and we're going to start
with the leaders of course levon aronian
has the white pieces against a
struggling chakrillar mamedyaro normally
if you make a draw you likely expect
wesley also to have quite a good chance
quite a good shot at making a drawing
potentially going into the tie breaks
now you're playing against a struggling
opponent chakra yarmouth mediaro but are
you willing to take the unnecessary
risks and it does seem like levon went
into this game thinking i'm not going to
take any unnecessary risks what i want
to play is a position in which i have a
very slight advantage
imbalances in the pawn structures no i
don't want to see any of that
on the board we have facing each other
pawn structures equal position the same
material balance i really like the way
levon approached this game so i'll give
him this one and of course linear versus
wesley linear trailing by one point
wesley so with the victory of course uh
he's going to catch him but will he win
the tournament
likely not because levon aronian is
playing with the white pieces and if he
doesn't lose it then lanier is unable to
catch him so will he take any
unnecessary risks no i don't think he
will once again he's looking for a long
game and i like his approach he's
playing this joko piano i remember in uh
the american cup when he played against
fabiano caruana and we were wondering
will lanier in the joko piano be able to
find something and he did find an
advantage so let's see if he's going to
be able to get an advantage against
wesley as well but let's talk a bit
about the psychology psychological part
as well anastasia what can you tell us
about that yeah first of all i wanted to
say that i went to the plane venue just
like a couple of minutes ago and i saw
wesley so you stayed quite a lot of time
next to the board between um next to the
board of lebanon watching the game and
the position and
really spend lots of time there
wondering probably what he should do now
with his position
knowing actually that level choose the
position with a small advantage i think
it's not that easy to understand what to
do and actually you are playing in the
last round you kind of play two games at
the same time right you play your game
and at the same time you go and check
what your opponent is doing so i think
everybody would be happy probably with a
draw in the last round and then we will
have a probably interesting tie break
but at the same time he understands that
dominguez also doesn't want to make a
quick draw probably he also tries his
chances in the last game in any case i
believe that the decisive rounds are
really interesting to follow and i
always think what the players
thoughts can be at the same time how do
you play these decisive games like do
you sleep before how do you sleep before
the games and of course we know this
famous quote from mikhail tal who said
that he was nervous until he understood
actually that in decisive games not only
him
who is nervous but also his opponent so
you should think about this too but we
don't know how nervous is shock i mean
and how nervous is level right now um i
i don't know christian what do you do
when you play the decisive game what
approach do you have well that's a very
good question and the question that is
so difficult in general to answer i
think it's individual based like how are
you as an individual going to deal with
this type of emotions of course i put
myself i tell to myself that i'm
grateful to be in the position i put
myself in the position to potentially
win the tournament and that's enough for
me and i'm going to give the same advice
to my students as well i think this is
the easiest way to deal with the nerves
everybody will have nerves of course
it's going to be impossible to just
forget about your nerves but if you put
yourself in the position going into the
final round to succeed i think that is
enough yeah and i also remember many
decisive rounds maybe many last rounds
in different events of course one of the
most exciting
games to follow where from london
candidates tournament 2013 and we know
that peter swiddler who is in the studio
right now was one of the heroes of that
round when he beat magnus carlson and
this was black pieces and i think he has
a lot of things to tell us about that
game and his approach when he when you
play the decisive game or when you know
that your opponent has a decisive game
so i wonder what he thinks about it
guys back to you in st luis thank you
anastasia thank you christian i'll put
it to the man himself what is your
psychology going into these
all-important decisive last rounds i
agree with much of what was said there
in the studio in in bucharest
i think sort of trying to tune out the
the tournament situation because there's
still a chess game in in front of you
yeah you still have to play it as well
as possible and uh you know whatever
happens happens
it's very difficult to completely ignore
the
uh you know the importance of that round
but
in as much as you're capable of doing it
i think it's better not to think about
the tournament situation very much but
the specific example anastasia mentioned
uh
of the 2013 london candidates when i had
the black pieces against magnus and
vladimir kramnik who was
also very much in the running there uh
to to get to a match against vichy you
know playing black against swazila
vanciuk uh
i did beat magnus there but uh i felt
that you know i had a decent candidate i
ended up on plus two i shared third but
for me the tournament was sort of
effectively over i was by that point
nobody wasn't running apart from those
two exactly uh so
i'm still very proud of that game it was
a very difficult it was a very difficult
game there was a lot of calculation
involved and yeah it's it's one of the
better games i played in my life
but
you know compared to the amount of
pressure magnus was under right i had a
free roll yeah you know i had i mean
there was some money at stake and pride
sure but for magnus it was a you know
potentially a culmination of the you
know life lifetime of of trying to get
to the match
you know the very summit of chess
achievement
and he he very much played two games
that day i played one he played two
because as did vladimir putin
vladimir also ended up losing to vasily
and i mean for vladimir
you know you kind of have to feel for
vladimir in particular there because
vasily had a horrible tournament losing
five games
yeah he lost i think five games on time
and he lost i think six and six in total
uh
but
as as is often the case with vasily he
updated brilliant games you absolutely
have no idea which was getting on the
day right
it might be the one that is going to be
like down to three minutes and you have
to remember london was no increment yeah
okay so he might be down to three
minutes by move 22 right or he might
just
play the kind of rancho game that we've
seen throughout throughout the last
don't know for 30 years where like
everything goes to precisely the right
squares and you're under pressure from
move one and the clock is under control
right and you're just not enjoying a
moment
and
and you know throughout the tournament
we saw a lot more of the you know the
the the the bad eventually so to speak
right and kramnik got to play against a
good evan chick in the last round
on top of having to figure out whether
he needed to play for a win exactly and
i guess
i also i lost kind of badly with white
to magnus in the first round of double
round robin yeah and i think uh
vladimir's opening choice
of the perk defense of the beards yeah
of the periods against vasily very much
kind of uh indicated that he did not
think very much about my chances against
madness
i think i think he probably thought this
is going to not be very pretty no
fortnite
because you know if he if he thought
draw is enough right you probably don't
play the beards in the last round
against uh against evan shook there
right uh but i ended up being kind of on
point on on the day right and uh yeah it
uh it perhaps backfired a little bit
yeah but overall uh my approach in these
last round decisive
uh games is i
avoid thinking about
the meaningfulness of the game and why
it's so important that i win
this
game in the title whatever it's more my
approach has been
i want to get the kind of game
that i need whether it's a chaotic game
or a soft slow strategic game or a
technical game so i'm really focused on
that aspect of what it is that i want to
achieve yeah but that's once again you
need to think about things on the board
yeah and uh then what you're saying
makes it makes a lot of sense just you
know getting a position you're
comfortable with and potentially a
position your opponent is you know the
least comfortable with that that suits
you
but that is that is specific chess
questions that you need to be asking uh
you know asking yourself and uh choosing
uh
but yeah in as much as you can you
should really tune out the tournament
situation
let me uh jump over to alejandro and get
him
get him involved in this question of
last round uh psych
your psychology going into these last
round crucial games uh alejandro i think
you guys said most of it last rounds are
really tough not only because of the
tournament pressure but also the
accumulation of how tired you are i mean
normally by the time that you get to the
championship rounds there's such a
tournament on top of you i mean you're
mentioning peter this candidates
tournament canada is a marathon fourteen
rounds 14 rounds against some of the top
best players in the world and you got
all this pressure of the months of
preparation leading up to the event so
you got to manage so many different
things in this one game of chess it's a
tough thing to do it's a tough thing to
do no matter what the level is i feel
that even at the collegiate level of
chess you get this last round and you
know that you need half appointment of
your opponent and you end up looking at
so many different boards right trying to
figure out what's going on exactly and
the other ones even though you have to
focus on your own and sometimes it's
difficult to do so
so certainly a little bit of nerves here
for the players but levon he's a
professional i mean he's been in this
situation how many times right how many
times has levon seen this particular
story unfold in front of him so he knows
what he's doing i like his approach it's
just extremely solid and he's going to
think well linear with the white pieces
yeah he's a solid player as well but he
nibbles once in a while right i mean
he's particularly good at this italian
openings right it's easy for me to be a
little bit more critical i mean i'm
sitting here in studio i don't have
anything at stake
but uh
myself in lavon shoes i think my
approach would've been different from
the four nights i mean i am after all
white i am playing the player is
actually having a really bad tournament
i would love to get a game where um
i'm putting more pressure on on my
opponent
and i think this approach basically is
very very soft if he if he were to win
the game then i'd take it all back it
was a genius yeah she seems unlikely now
the position that we have on the board
genius decision of playing this but no i
think it's just a little bit too tepid
for me yeah i don't i don't disagree uh
uh something that uh anastasia mentioned
uh in the pre-show
uh i sort of hesitate to to bring it up
as a very serious uh part of the
equation there but they are friends
these two players yeah uh levon and
levon and shahar are in very very good
terms and uh i don't know how much that
play once again levon is a professional
of i know 25 years probably not 25 but
definitely 20 years of playing at the
very top level
this
shouldn't inform his decision very much
but perhaps it informs it a little bit
right and uh
yeah it does it does seem like you just
thought
i don't really need to you know over
complicate matters today too much
because yeah this
this is about uh about as non-critical
as lymon gets with the white pieces
exactly let's just jump into that game
because when we left that we had just
seen this move by levon queen f3 and the
discussion is that white has a slight
advantage and so forth and so on bishop
e4 queen g3 trade trade trade and guess
what we're now in a
semi-open position four versus
four on the queen side three versus
three on the queen's king side
i think
i think it's
it's it's nothing really because the
pollen c7 is a little bit weak
but the knight on d6 blocks it uh very
very very comfortably and also i think
all four rooks just disappear along the
e file and then look at the chopping
block as we know yeah and then i put the
king on e6 or d7 or wherever and and
start shuffling exactly and i just don't
see how white even asks a pertinent
question there to be honest agreed i
think this one this one is just going to
be
truly uh dead dead dead uh let's just
just take it on d6 that is even even
more i mean
the pretense yeah
yo if you're gonna take on d6 which he
has done by the by the way remember when
i was saying um
uh weiss versus schwartz yeah take a
look at this mirrored position it is it
is very very nicely very nicely
symmetrical
exactly very very and what they often do
in this structure when they get it in in
the rookie 190 berlins is they actually
play b4 with white and b5 with black
and then everything
just to make sure that nobody goes
anywhere yeah exactly
right here yeah b4 and b5 would mean
that no entries for either king are
possible so that game we can definitely
i think we will return to it when we
watch the handshake yeah there's no
particular need to watch it until then i
want to get
right back into the game that alejandro
found very very exciting that was the
fabiano game with daniel daniel playing
that move f4 which by the way i think is
a hilarious move
for me personally when i see this move
bishop
f5 to e6
i'm attacking your knight
and i'm attacking it twice
and white says you are
i don't think so go go execute your
threat you know f2 f4 and you had taken
us down a rabbit hole there which was i
thought pretty fun
knight takes c4 you never came to a
definitive conclusion
on uh any of this because
it was
it seemed so far-fetched
but rook d8
was also not a novelty but supposedly
not the best move even though i have
seen
a negative plate and whatever negative
plays generally cannot be all that bad
is actually the best move according to
my engine better than the move knight
takes e4 remember that a lot of this
theory is dated uh some of these games
were from the early 2000s or mid 2000
2005. engines have evolved significantly
since then and rook d8 is the choice by
you favi it is the best engine move now
there's not a lot of choices for white
to continue in this position if you're
looking for an advantage and i don't
think that that knows this movie stuck
right now after the move rook d8 if you
move the queen to e4 there's bishop d5
the the line kind of continues but
because knight takes is not possible
because pawn takes e5 and then queen
takes c4 you need to find a good idea
you could still continue the line with
bishop e3
sorry queen e3 still a mess
uh after the move rook did you could
start with the move queen e3 and then
forced me to take on c4 in this
variation there's also a move like
bishop c5 absolute madness but let's say
bishop takes c4 pawn takes e5 queen
takes e5 it looks a little dodgy for
black to play with the king on e8 but
you're currently up upon you have the
pair of bishops you are covering a lot
of good squares and i don't think that
queen takes a7 which is the main move of
the engine uh
is really something that's going to
refute the variation you could according
to the engine take on d8 queen takes
rook takes
go to an end game
you have to take on c4 to get your piece
back and the question is how do you
evaluate this one there's two connected
pass pawns in the center of the board
marshall
yes
marshall type of compensation
if these ones get connected and somehow
you break the light square blockade then
white's just winning but you're far away
from that you're still a little
underdeveloped this pawn in particular
is very advanced so you could try to
create a play
and it's very vulnerable yeah because of
its advanced nature so right now the
engine is saying almost full
compensation for black it doesn't fully
see how to get the pawns back exactly
but it kind of gives away h7 for f6 and
then fights on with a pair of bishops
saying that well at the end of the day
material is very reduced the position is
very open this bishop is not
particularly great yeah you'll enjoy an
extra pawn as white but your winning
chances are rather low that being said
winning chances for black here well zero
right wow not very many uh
one game that has just kind of zoomed uh
went past the opening and zoomed past
the middle game and we're deep into the
ending i'm going to bring up the game
between uh richie and ayan here uh this
queen c1 didn't seem to perplex
not very much but also much i mean
once again after yesterday uh jan has
had a kind of a traumatic event honestly
because he started really well by
beating alireza in that like
monster of a game right
which featured some swings but it was i
think very very uh well played by both
of them
and then he just had a series of
unfortunate events yeah it's like lemony
snicket uh
like very very deflating you know losing
to losing to shock from a position which
at one point was just completely and
utterly winning with one precise
calculation and then not winning
yesterday after playing a very nice game
against levon exactly so i i don't know
how much credence we can give to his 125
on the clock by move 20 honestly
but yeah it does seem like he has not
been shocked by quincy one and his is
uh being sort of blitzed out
somewhat convincingly and the end game
they have on on the board right now uh
she's she's 7c5 is by far the main the
main idea here for black so
yeah rickard understandably goes rook c1
here and it happens anyway uh jan went
c5 dc and he went knight d7 uh knight b8
which is one of the ways to avoid uh
spoiling your queen side structure with
beta xc5
this is a definite no no that one i mean
in some positions it's playable because
you do have counterplay against the
beats upon it's not as if you create a
weakness but it's you get absolutely
nothing nothing
right i don't think it's unplayable but
i think keeping the structure as is if
possible is sort of the saner the saner
choice now for me uh
having the knight appear on c5 is less
tolerable than having it appear for
example either on the c6 square or even
the c7 yeah we can take your pieces
put your pieces backwards uh and i would
i would assume that he doesn't want the
pawn to be captured on the c5 square but
rob the season absolutely you never
allow 97 take c5 exactly yeah so white
clearly has a
pleasant pleasant free roll here but
it's not very much it's uh
i think these missions generally get
held but i guess it depends what you ask
because the engine hates it for black
really really hates it like plus one
plus 1.5 depending which one you ask
right
because there are i saw the evaluation
on the screen a bit earlier and i didn't
reach actions and so it really hates 97
specifically right because i really hate
97 but the entire idea of playing c5
without preparation it it really
disliked it i thought you should go 97
first and i'm going to rook c6 just take
the draw with knight b8 knight d7 no i
assume richard would have put the rook
on c3 played but you still prepare the
move c5 yeah absolutely so 97 let's take
king e2 c5 rook hc1 and we go i don't
know rook cg8 or something something
like that yeah yeah you can break
through yeah i can very much still
retains a bit of a plus a bit of a plus
but it's not as much as in the game in
the game after c7
i mean if you just put some moves on the
board
you start seeing how black gets on in
trouble oops uh yep
yeah
knight b8 c7 yeah knight a6 you kind of
have to play
and then either ke2 or knight d4 doesn't
matter that much 94 even 94 even this i
just i like knight d4 just
uh yeah and uh the one i'm not surprised
at all is the if you take on c7 here
white will just take take play king 2
follow it up with rook c1 yeah this is
exactly the kind of position you just
kind of lose
yeah because particularly here this
knight on c7 is so dominated yeah and
you can't play e5 you just can't make
yourself play that you you
know giving up giving up the f5 square
is very very painful yeah and this is
why i said that you know normally in a
tournament like this when you see
somebody who has just played a world
championship match you know sit there
with 125 on the clock you although
maybe it's not 125 by this point but
not not much more than that
uh
you would assume he is just quoting
something from memory but
uh jan does it you know in particular
when it's going as poorly as this one is
going
uh he does get into these kinds of moods
where he just makes moves
and hopes they're good on the day like
you know not much
not much thought really goes into them
he i mean he is definitely gifted enough
to trust the autopilot on a good day
it's just that when it's not a good day
the autopilot could good malfunction
exactly uh just because richie is taking
a quick second before playing the move
c6 c7
it did cross my mind that knight d4 is
actually g8 is annoying i think yeah
that's the
that that that's the problem was that uh
the desirable rook c4 i've got a back
rank issue c5 i think it's very strong
five not the five maybe is actually
playable for white but b5 is very strong
i think oh because of 97 yeah it's like
okay but b5 would be funny yeah that's
true it's is a nice way of taking
advantage of my fact that i'm actually
not castle my king is on f1
all right well we'll keep an eye on that
um alejandro uh
well
they didn't get in b5b4 yet uh the two
players that is to say i mean we don't
have to return to this exactly but
what's going on with the west oh wesley
so
and lanier more or less
g6 half an hour
for linear we're we're back on form here
we're back
yeah one decisive game today four draws
for 20 minutes 30 40. yeah this one is
going very slowly linear trying to
figure out what to do okay
it's not easy i mean it's really not
easy to try to understand these
positions
every move
looks similar
and they're met in such different ways
for example i was trying to understand
what does happen after queen c2 it
looked like such an our normal move to
me right and
it's the most forcing yeah the top
engine move i would have never thought
of in my life quincy to knight a5
knight a5 yeah no that was not on my
agenda either oh yeah it's it's very
clever though i've i've looked at
sacrifices like this but not here
because here it looks like you're really
pushing it so [ __ ] play four knight c4
kind of forcing bishop c1 potentially
yeah bishop c1 and then you still have
nine c5 okay and you just chased down
that bishop traded for one of the
knights and you have to play
so marshall issues
rip takes rook takes bishop uh it should
be five c6 simply should be three i
guess we can now we can think about uh
you can go rook a8
yeah rook a8 i i pulled you off the a
file so you wouldn't do that to me but
now you're playing rook a8 anyway oh my
it's a very clever move because it stops
you from going bishop takes c4 bishop
takes c4 b3 liberating your position
precisely it's very deep it's hard to
even con conceive this idea they're on
the board but if you know it if you just
know it and you come prepared from home
and the engine tells you well you
sacrifice a pawn go rook d8 arcade and
you equalize well that's all you need to
do right 95 is a very very nice movie i
i really like that is something special
uh
one other look because maybe bishop c1
okay for knight b2 is a threat i.e ah
rookie four nights i wasn't doing it out
of you know the
goodness of your goodness
there's not much goodness yeah
precisely
stuff is hanging stuff is hanging uh
just uh for the audience i i was
thinking well i'll recapture on e3 peter
says no no no no i have got a fork in
mind rook takes a4 knight takes b2
hits
these two guys and black
advantageously wins back his pawn
in this case so
knight a5 quite the resource we've seen
it show up actually
earlier too that knight a5 was yeah but
not in a position like this where
seemingly the a4 pawn is completely free
yeah right we were giving it up in
slightly more understandable
circumstances but here you know white
spends the full tempo attacking the pawn
a4 and you sort of give it up more you
even remove the k8 from the protection
it's it's a difficult idea uh to to
conceive of as alejandro was saying but
perhaps
perhaps uh linear realized it exists
because uh
he's definitely paused and we were
basically in linear shoes we were saying
okay two
two uh choices queen c2 and or queen f3
queen f3 was the game that i was trying
to remember which actually i was told
was from the u.s championship 2016 and
it was a great game uh queen f3 with the
idea knight f5 and i think this was the
one that attracted you most peter yeah
we were looking at this and um
honestly having having uh you know
listened to alejandro i'm wondering if
you can hear maybe the knight a5 is
playable but i'm
i think it's probably less uh less
interesting here
because i can i can go on
bishop c bishop a4 knight c4
bishop and i can take on d7 the
difference being that knight takes e3 is
much less of a sort of a winning threat
here with the queen
there's still going to be compensation
because the bishop player here is
definitely not nothing no but white but
white doesn't spoil uh their pawn
structure at all you do have to give up
both of your bishops for that pawn which
is but it's it's a solid enough pawn i
will play night knight f3 back i will i
will hopefully play rugby tour kg1
here i'm picking white okay okay fair
fair
so queen f3 knight a
knight a5 would be quite the
the move knight
but if you don't do something yeah it
feels like another five needs addressing
because it will be awkward right more
than a one way to do so knight f6
another six i was going to say yeah
as it starts both knights yeah exactly
it stops both knight five and nine g4
yeah because now knight takes e4 and
because the knight on f5 is hanging and
i don't have knight g4 my issue with
that move was specifically rook takes d8
because i kind of hate the idea of
taking with the knight but maybe i
shouldn't maybe it's fine it's okay yeah
but while taking with the rook i will
definitely clip the pawn on a4 taking
with the knight maybe your knight
isn't any great shakes but for the
moment black white's pieces are kind of
there's also a bunch of pieces on the
king side which do nothing maybe we'll
go c6b5 to follow and knight b7 knight
c5 later on ib7 bishop c5 or something
yeah and i will return to the game at
some point i'm guessing that it's not
fast i'm guessing the desirable queen d1
just will also hang the e4 player bishop
d3 but yeah i can i think i'm gonna play
it five if all of those fails
all right uh it's that time peter where
we inform everybody of our specials and
cuba today i have glad tidings today uh
as as a parting note for the viewers of
this tournament
uh the grand chester a kind of a one day
of everything must go 20 off on the
entire the entire catalogue wow with the
uh promo code uh rom 20 that's read only
memory 20.
[Laughter]
nice association here
i'm not sure
what video games you've been up to but
okay
i couldn't resist
i thought yeah so
20 off of all regular price merchandise
today only with the code uh uh rom 20
that obviously stands for romania and
not not what i said
uh at checkout and uh the offer is only
valid with uh at cubitique
stl.com but yeah plenty of very
interesting stuff there and as we go
check it out yeah and as we go on break
anastasia has been interviewing playing
catch-up with zhukova and onishuk see on
the other side of the brick
[Music]
and here we are with another guest of
the tournament alexander onishuk
ukrainian american grandmaster you were
in different times ukrainian champion
american champion played for both
countries for the national teams
alexander welcome to the grand chess
tour how is it to be here
thank you thank you anastasia um now
it's great to be here thank you for
inviting me it's great to see this event
like in person it's been a while i've
been to such big tournaments on this one
and uh especially um
like uh
not in the us because in the u.s
obviously i
i attend some tournaments in saint louis
but this one is uh
you know just an amazing tournament uh
with lots of uh great players uh it's
nice to
follow the tournament and many
interesting games many decisive games
and uh yeah i'm glad to be here
who was the most impressive players so
far i mean for you which games did you
follow with with interest
well i mean you know i should say all of
them obviously but um
of course i'm rooting for american
players and i'm glad to see that wesley
saw is leading
the tournament with the leofaronian
yeah i hope one of the us players will
win
this event
you you were the one who took part also
in this fundraising event for ukraine
what were your impressions what what do
you think about such events
well i think it was a great event and
the main thanks to
uh the main sponsor superbad and
obviously everyone who attended the
event uh it was great
to meet all these people
i have talked to some of them next day
and
they were telling us stories like their
personal stories
how they support ukraine ukrainian
people and quite frankly you know being
here in romania and meeting uh
so many people that
you know do their best
helping refugees
um helping ukraine ukrainians uh it's
it's very important for me to kind of
meet these people and thank them
uh alexander how did your life changed
in the way after the war started
because of course we know that you keep
ukrainian uh you reality you have
ukrainian relatives in ukraine and
france yeah
well it has changed a lot i should say
um
as you know i'm originally from crimea
and
i still
have some friends there i used to have
more friends in crimea and
overall i should say but uh
yeah my life has also changed a little
bit um
of course
i started being more involved
once the award started and
helping helping helping ukraine
also taking part a part in some events
in my hometown
we have a small ukrainian community and
i mean americans they they support
ukraine so much and uh
you know we ukrainians living in the u.s
we are
very grateful to everyone who
who puts a flag outside of their house
or just donates the money and
it has happened from day one and uh i
think it's very important and very
important for the us and we're important
of course for ukraine to have such a
support in
in america
thank you very much alexander and
welcome once again to granchester and we
hope to see you once again here as i
know that you are going to poland as
well
[Music]
here we are next to the plane when you
together with natalia zhukov a two-time
european champion ukrainian grandmaster
who came directly from odessa from
ukraine natalia how was your trip tell
us welcome thank you very much nice to
be here yeah uh yes i i came here a
couple of days ago
uh yes of course it was a difficult trip
i came by
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the final round the championship
round of the bucharest
chess classic
and uh as you see on your screens there
are two leaders uh playing today an mvl
potentially
catching up to them if he wins with
black against alireza which is a very
tall order but it has been done it has
been done even in this tournament
exactly and he got himself a fighting
position even though white is
under no pressure there but it's it's a
fighting uh just balanced position which
is something you don't often get in the
g3 c6 uh
but during our break the the game that
got our attention is nepo
well he's in real trouble uh peter yeah
when we left it we he had just played
uh the desirable move c5 but he didn't
prepare it with the move knight d7 as
recommended by alejandro first you play
knight d7
then you play c5 and eventually you
fight your way to a equal equal position
said he jumped with c5 right away and
what's this said richie
i'll take it and
i'll place it
i'll push it all the way to c7 and now
when you recap can you click one more
just
i just want to see
so never spent eight minutes on knight
h65 here that's what i wanted to take a
look at 95 straight up loses to best
play
right
the result the result would no longer
even be in doubt if if richard found
the most precise way to to put this to
bed
which isn't what he played for and i
think i figured out why i think i know
exactly what
uh what richard missed there
uh
the move to win here is the move b2b4
forcing the knight away from the c5
first
if you go and i take c4 we can play we
can play knight b5 here right a rookie
seven is obligatory otherwise you allow
knight takes a seven and if it causes
like a full exchange and now we go king
into very simply king two followed by
rook hd1
and stop being an e9d yeah rook d1 d8
the idea is very simple but also
completely unstoppable you can't really
deal with this in any in any kind of
reasonable fashion and yeah the black
position just collapses here
just to con no no
king king is yeah currently is the only
one i don't quite understand i guess you
go rook hd one
e8 of three a6 knight a7 knight c6 i
guess yeah
yeah a6 this is the one final touch you
need to find knight a7 rooks ec7 and
knight c6 attacking not only the
exchange but also rook g8 check
checkmate is a bit of a very powerful
threat uh rta checkmate wow uh and
instead of that uh richard played in 95
immediately which we thought honestly
before which was also winning actually
we thought it was completely winning as
well but i think the point is after
knight b5 and rookie seven already
blitzed out by
uh by reheard uh and nepo yeah king e2
uh a6
uh yeah actually it's it's simpler than
i thought after okay g1
black can actually take on b5 right yes
rook g8 or k8 and this doesn't win
because there's knight b7 in the end we
go rogue d a check rook a8 i don't know
if it doesn't win right
uh we take on e8 all rook cd1 is also
possible we go rgd1 here and black goes
knight b7
how do we evaluate the endgame after b4
here
though uh better rook c8 yeah you have
to xb6 there yeah yeah that's kind of
the point you have you have set xb6 it's
probably yeah this looks very promising
as well but for some reason the engine
doesn't
really it's not disturbing yeah and this
looks dead lost yeah this looks
deadlocks but the engine goes with hd1
king h7 and this is what i thought was
was being missed
and then i realized this exists in the
current like rook hd1 with 25
instead of 8xb5
the machine suggests you can play king
h7 which looks like it just resigns to
rook d8 but black does have rook takes
c7 there i think this is what i think
this is what he missed
that's easy to miss i think this is what
he missed i think he thought the game is
over
and then by this point he realized that
king h7 followed by rook takes c7
actually
uh solves the biggest the biggest issue
uh black has here uh the engine still
suggests white is massively better after
king h796 followed by
uh beautiful
before years up there yeah and we get
back to you know the kinds of end games
like the the most famous one is
i'm guessing uh
right
yeah this just looks really really nasty
yeah in better days one win
for a richie uh against seven draws so
he's definitely uh
done very well against nepal yeah he
said he said the better of this of this
matchup but not not by a large margin
but yeah it's a it's a huge big miss
obviously because yeah had he started
with b4 instead of 95 the game would
have been over by now i see but now he
must have completely missed king h7 yeah
do we have to and we do have in fact
king h7 on the board
yeah and he will now have to go back to
to to uh
playing a very pleasant end game and
just to show the audience you might be
thinking king h7 we're not king g7 yes
you guys can you guys can take that one
i'm assuming there's going to be some
very nice
uh
night forks in this one
there must be yeah yeah but but how is
it wherever yeah this is this is the one
yeah you got 96 and before and before
correct and uh when the knight leaves we
take on c7 and we go to 98 check and
that once again ends the game
oops
that's right getting you from behind
that's why the kings on h7 are not on g7
the subtleties of the position
yeah you know richard's such a good
calculator he's proven it this
tournament the way that he played
against shock wow what a game that was
but this one
it just feels like the both players have
kind of checked out mentally from the
tournament they're making moves they're
not double triple checking the way they
normally would because at this level
guys this is
he should see before should he shoot
this well all of this is you know
eminently findable yeah
the entire line is also just completely
streamlined there's nothing else to
calculate you cannot allow knight a7
here yeah it's k7 strictly the only move
you're playing into he knows the idea
exists he played it in the game as well
so it's not as if he doesn't realize
this is the winning idea in all of these
positions
and you follow it up like all of the
calculations here are you know take
third straight yeah
very straightforward yeah and i i liked
the final uh the most that threat of
knight of rook to a checkmate
as you stop if only temporarily the rook
from landing here until you see that i
think you you probably should include
this i'll probably actually first yeah
yeah that i i did it wrong my my
apologies f3
you your knight can't move because of
knight d6 check only move is a6
knight attacks the rope the rook has to
take the pawn and then suddenly not only
are we attacking this rook but we also
have the threat of check made in one and
then that only for continues
completely lost position
yeah that's a that's a
wow that's a straightforward piece of
calculation that shouldn't have been
difficult at all for uh richie
um
our first big miss uh alejandra what
else do you have for us first hopefully
not many but yes this game a little
dodgy but let's go back to our
tournament leader wesley saw with the
black pieces against lanier dominguez
playing what i call ugly chess ugly but
effective we have in this position after
the move knight g4 wesley blitzed out
bishop d6
and we had considered this idea of
bishop c4 earlier training the light
squared bishop hopefully getting some
squares here for the queen as well and
here wesley could play the move knight
a5 but he said you know what give me
that bishop and let me play the move
queen e6 stop move by the engine by the
way
so no surprise there queen e6 and the
engines say go back don't take on e6
i would obviously take owning six and
linear yeah you'd never go back no you
look at this truck here say that is ugly
that is two isolated pawns that are
blocking this bishop for the rest of the
game they're never gonna get better
until i break them with the move g3 f4
then i remember that in some game
carlsen beat karjakin it's a very
important game with this structure i
think i can torture my opponents the
same way
not human but the engines think
look the pawns are not really that weak
because who's going to attack them the
pawn on e5 is already very well defended
there's no real ways to get to the e6
sponsor white needs to have a second
front and that's what um linear does
with the move b4
takes takes but wesley not really
spending a lot of time getting to this
position also blitzing out the move
knight a5
he hasn't really thought at all his
clock is sitting at an hour and 25
minutes
rook db1 played and instantly well a
couple minutes think on this one b5 on
the board the edge is saying zeros not
even a slight smidge of an advantage for
white thinking black's just too active
you have these problems on the queen
side that are more real than the
problems that i have on
the center with these two pawns on the e
file black's pretty active everywhere
the knight on a5 is on the rim but it's
kind of tying all of my rooks together
here on the queen side and this knights
on g4 and g3 they look pretty but
what are they doing with the rest of the
pieces maybe you want to coordinate in
this way for the moment b4 might be an
idea knight c5 coming as an idea this
knights are far away from the queen side
and black apparently has solved their
problems
thank you for that alejandro and turning
our attention to uh fabies games sorry
peter did you and this is the scenario
that alejandra was actually describing
when we started talking about the end
game after uh ef6
uh i i i him he did mention that the
pawn on f6 often gets traded for the
pawn on h7 and i wasn't
entirely sure how that is happening but
the players have shown us basically
exactly and it started with the move
that
i think it's a in particular because
fabi did not appear to know very much
about the position king c7 is a very
cute move to make here especially i'm
prepared because it seems like you need
to start attacking the pawn of six
straight away but he says
i need to sidestep the checks i need to
secure my king i don't actually have to
address the pawn f6 just yet pass the
move to white ask white exactly what
white needs to do well king c7 is he's
basically saying k7 will be useful
every single time so i'm starting with
this and i will react to your moves and
knight b4 looks logical but it does take
away the e4 square from the knight
meaning that now black and
black can attack the pawn on f6
in full knowledge that it does get
picked up right and we see a very
logical follow-up from there uh the
problem though with the immediate knight
e4 maybe bishop d5 right you're walking
maybe even bishop to ac2 i'm not saying
it was strong here i'm just saying the
the option gets taken away by placing
the bishop on that square clear here
yeah and then a kind of a forcing
variation continues from here bishop h6
bishop g5 uh f7 square is covered so
yeah the point of six is gone but it
does get traded for the pawn on h7
and uh
the rooks will come off i'm pretty sure
white uh is you know white incentivized
yeah i mean the rook on h6 would be very
way too strong to allow exactly so i
think the rooks are coming off
and then
like my initial feeling here is that
it's not even a difficult draw it's not
a difficult role it's not even a
difficult draw because
yeah and we we we will finally get the
promised handshake in the uh
game everything just everything got
hosted on the queen
and it's three versus three
um
vice versa schwartz
absolutely yeah king g3 somehow the
rooks
should be on a more
uh mirrored square yeah if you know what
i'm saying they they haven't done it as
perfectly as perfect
but my teenage book yeah efficient
efficient enough you you you
complain here lavonna rooney is not
going to complain at all about his final
result as he goes into the clubhouse
with a half a point lead waiting for the
results of wesley and mvl
uh absolutely yeah
and again if we do get to a playoff
peter what would it look like yeah the
playoff rules are
i wanted to say straightforward but
i mean they're streamlined and
very nicely
very nicely for the spectators there is
no you know excel spreadsheets involved
this is the format of the tournament in
general as as you can see but the
tiebreak rules are uh people play it out
right if you
if i don't want to use too many words
there people people battle it out over
the board which is
way way preferable to calculating arcane
tie breaks
uh and uh we need the player yeah the
playoff rules in case of two players
they're going to be playing head up
right just just a straight up two game
two game micro match with the game game
in 15 plus 10 yeah those are those are
the the rules we were looking for uh 15
plus 10 uh and uh
if that is still tied uh there's an
arrogant and if uh
wesley draws an mvl wins which currently
doesn't look very likely but it's still
nowhere near very possible
yeah possible uh so in case of a tie of
three players we'll get a round-robin
three-round rap
three-round or
i can't speak english anymore uh
uh so they will they will they will play
a proper tournament not not uh
luckily for us
not to double round robin but a single
program yeah
yeah and uh there will be with a
slightly shorter time control due to the
amount of rounds that they will have to
play
and uh
the important beat is they will have to
wait until the entire classical round is
finished which is very understandable
because people start banging on the
clock in
rapid and you don't really want to
distract players who are still playing
their classical game but 15 minutes and
after the final game is finished uh in
in the tournament proper will we will
have our tie break start
and uh after the uh
the match between the two or the round
robin uh among all three there is
immediately an armageddon game if people
are still tied for first uh with five
minutes for white four minutes for black
and uh
black getting draughts and this is the
view of the playing hall as you can see
still plenty of spectators obviously
this is the most important
uh day of the tournament
uh and uh
the reason they're not watching the
watching the stage there as you can see
all of them intently watching something
on the left yeah clearly there's a large
screen there showing all the
all the live boards and this is what
attracts everybody's
and
let's take a look at the game between
mvl and alien uh
what
oops that's yeah and what are you
what is the chances of mvl
uh i mean
clearly only a victory gets him uh into
a tie
yeah
some somewhat surprising decisions
weren't were taken since were there last
i very much liked his approach and
actually i was just sitting there i'm
pretty sure i gave instead of knight bd7
that he played after bishop b2 uh b3
d5 should be two happened here i think i
still i still had this position in the
course i think i was recommending here
to play knight a6 knight c3 take on g2
and play queen c8 i think that was
that was my recommendation kind of
combining the ideas of rook g8 and ideas
of c7 c5 c65 and the queen is often very
well placed on the e6 square i still
feel like this is playable if i if i
remember correctly what the chorus says
which is also not a given uh i could
give you a
good discount on your own course for you
thank you very much yes uh
but uh
what mvl did is actually very very
streamlined as well and i i quite like
this idea you play an mpd7 you lure them
knight to c3 and you immediately uh
attack the knight on c4 with b7 b5 and
you obviously yeah you need the knight
on d7 to do this because knight c4 e5
would be the ideal square to retreat to
but with the knight on d7 it's not
really playable but the 75 is a bit
questionable if we go back after 92
um you can definitely make an argument
for playing something like queen b6 gear
and following it up with c65 which i
think pretty much instantly equalizes
here and i think the the the fact that
mvl also quite quickly played the 75
here
is a nod
towards the tournament situation uh
because you know completely equalizing
is all good and well but that
you know considering how wesley's and
the ones games are going is not going to
give you a type of first exactly it's
going to it's going to leave you
he's got to do something to imbalance
this but as we get to their position
let's just jump over to bucharest where
christian is with lavon aronian
christian
thank you uh yes sir yes we are indeed
with lavon aronian the leader as we are
waiting for the result between the game
of linear and wesley levon first of all
congratulations quite a solid event for
you i would say remarkable even for you
how would you assess your performance in
romania
i think i was playing rather terrible
but
so was everybody else
and definitely the defensive side played
quite well in your favor in a couple of
games yeah absolutely i think uh i was
making very obvious mistakes
i think i'm uh you know playing so much
rapid chess online kind of kills your
concentration at least that's how it
works with me
so i was struggling with my
concentration something that i need to
work on
and that's why i was making such
mistakes and putting myself in real
danger but i'm happy at least i was
fighting back co-leading at the event
going into the final round you had white
uh against a struggling chakrillar how
uh um how um
how did you approach
this particular game what was the
strategy going into today's round well
the last round has its specifics
you know it's like uh in poker yeah we
say
you don't play uh
you don't play your card do you play
your position
and my position dictates me to uh
actually play very solidly because
in case
if if i had lost
i mean the difference
would have been huge
in gct points and how the tournament is
spoiled yeah and also in uh
i mean
price month as well
so you always assess it as a risk reward
ratio yes got it and right now it does
look like wesley most likely will
probably defend this one it's probably
going to end in a draw and you guys very
likely will end up in a tie break now
you know wesley quite well and recently
you played a mini match in a rapid time
control also you played a lot of
other matches in rapid time control in
the american cup how would you assess
your chances going into that one
well uh wesley is a very very good
player
in rapid and generally chess
and
of course he's a tough opponent always i
think he won this
tour quite a few times with his
performance in the
rapid parts
so well i'm going to
try uh
to play my best and
try to repeat what i have accomplished
in the american
cup would you say that result is going
to weight heavily on the performance of
both you and wesley yeah in this
potential playoff i don't think so
it's a new tournament uh
new opportunities and wesley is playing
very well here so
uh he's going to play a different nature
of it
lavon thank you very much for joining us
we'll let you go get ready for the
potential playoff and we'll see you soon
thank you guys back to you thank you
christian and uh our congratulations to
lavon on his very solid outing
absolutely yeah and uh you know
seems like he thought he was uh
playing on the button this round i don't
know yeah i didn't quite get all the
poker analogies but you play your
position not the cards
that's that's the way it works um wesley
by the way perhaps you know he he played
so tightly maybe he thought he was like
early position or i don't know
i've been saying i'm going to be
thinking about this for the rest of the
break i'm i'm i'm so interested in uh
because i i can't remember when he used
the poker analogies to describe
i've never i've never heard him do that
before now i am now we're perplexed my
eyes are
you know um b5b4 peter by wesley
alejandro was explaining even though
these pawns look really pathetic and
shame on you
for having them in the first place the
problem is that this knight on a5 does
well and truly tie down a linear you'd
lanier did not want to
invite the knight to occupy the c4
square
rather he played the move knight d2 in
order to be pardon me knight f1 in order
to play knight d2 and then so then he
could play 3b before and wesley kind of
beat him to the punch absolutely and i
think this is a apart from controlling
the
b3 c3 pawn pair the 5 before
specifically is very much why we have
played b7 b5 i think on the previous
move because
this puts white in a kind of a weird
spot because if you play c4
you give up this really gorgeous square
on c5 for the black pieces and even if
the immediate bishop c5 i think makes it
definitely comes into uh
consideration because if the machines
come off and the knight lands on c5
white would be
maybe in big trouble or already already
in severe trouble because upon b3 is
very very weak exactly uh meaning that
you have to uh pretty much you have to
allow this trade of the pollen before
the policy iii and the big question is
uh sort of uh exactly how
how you do this maybe
to start is
definitely an argument could be made for
that or you could just take on before
and then play uh
i was looking at uh cb4 bishop before
okay four
uh trying to perhaps uh utilize the fact
that the black pieces are you know
somewhat misplaced i mean not place but
maybe it could be put on a celebration
yeah yeah and let's say 96 here which
looks logical until you spot the rook c1
i think is quite strong because you
definitely don't want to take rook a4
ba-4 improve my position and the the
pressure along the shift file is quite
significant here but instead of the
knight c6 there's a number of things
which i think are quite healthy for
black in particular you say on c5 i
think just equalizers does it with the
idea of knight b6 and then perhaps i had
a trick for you if you landed in b6
before works here yeah
but it's not the end of the story
because still you know variation sort of
continues but i think after would be one
maybe white is
better yeah right uh i'm reminded
forcefully reminded of the ending that
we had yesterday of two minor pieces
against the rook between nepo and so it
does feel to me that c takes before in
rook a4 is the one try which could
potentially give white you know a
semblance of hope because i'm not
entirely sure how you're supposed to
reply maybe rook a b8 is fine
uh rook a8 it's
then i thought maybe we can play
something like rook b1 d1 and try to
continue exerting you know asking some
questions of the pieces which are still
not entirely coordinated if you take on
b3 here
i will take on uh e5 g8 and b4 and claim
that i'm ever so slightly better in this
end game
still a draw i assume but do right maybe
i'm a little bit better due to my
slightly better structure who knows rook
d3 is quite good though i missed e3 i
thought the knight had to go to a5 and
then i would claim i'm a bit better but
53 is a good move here uh
linear played rook a4 straight away
which is very interesting whoa
similar very very interesting but uh
whoa because
he is i'm guessing
he's just
loses a piece to rook a1 right whoa i
wouldn't that i mean
that pawn is one one square away from
coronation
two i apologize thank you but obviously
taxi three is nowhere near forest you
can play knight g6 here i understand and
be completely fine
uh just a
little lanier obviously spent quite some
time calculating this but i i just
i just want to be sure that uh
yeah i mean i'm sure yeah bishop c5
specifically was what was worrying me it
takes takes uh rookie five and c2
exactly i mean but with bishop c1 i
guess
that that that ends the discussion is
the bishop c1 move so we're back to your
knight c6 plan not six seems fine and
the difference is after she takes before
here of course we're not taking with the
bishop we're thinking of the night and
that's very happily so yes much more
harmonious set up exactly compared to
the previous slide what we're discussing
we still have the two uglies if i could
play knight f1 c4 here i'd be quite
happy but i get the feeling i will not
be in time knight f1 c4 that would be a
great that would be a good move here
that would be a strong move
nice okay we'll keep this
one on our back burner uh what do you
have for us alejandro what what has
caught your attention
well richard doesn't seem to be putting
the best pressure on yanni pomnyacci he
had a lot of chances he had the chance
to win immediately as we saw missed that
one but even in this end game that they
got after the knight b5 and the precise
rookie 7 king e2 a6 rock hd 1 king h7 a
very important move knight d6 rook c
takes c7 we still had this end game in
which white is definitely better but it
does require a couple of precise moves
b4 is the start the knight cannot take
on e4 because it's currently defended
that was the problem in many of the
variations you don't really want to go
to the side so you kind of have to go to
b3 problem with going to a4 is that in
so many variations the knight kind of
gets stuck on that side of the board you
don't want to play that and knight b3
kind of forces the issue because after
takes on c7 takes off c7 i have some
ideas of rook c2 check they don't quite
work out for black though 98 would have
been strong you attacked the rope you
attacked the pawn forced the issue again
rook c2 you would think is the only move
but it doesn't quite work out because
after king d3
rook takes f2 railroad king c3 this
knight is just trapped it doesn't have
enough squares i'm going to pick up the
knight and because of the structure and
the weaknesses on b6 and a6 that can be
easily attacked black simply does not
have enough counter play despite
technically having three pawns for the
piece for the time being so this would
have been a really good end game for
white the nk the engine saying that
after knight b3 takes takes 98. you have
to find moves like rook c3 keep some
pressure alive it's not easy to untangle
us white but you are going to get that
pawn on f6 and you will get it with the
chuck as well the knight will return
eventually the engines climbing and
climbing in evaluation but they didn't
like the move that he played on in the
board
f4 played instead
trying to figure out exactly where he
did that i want he wants to cement the
knight on with e5 or something i'm not
sure knight b3 was plunked quickly down
by nepo definitely the best move in the
position the difference compared to many
of the other lines first of all the
second rack has been opened a little bit
more and more importantly the pawn is
not on b4 so this knight's never trapped
right for example if i take on c7 take
on c7 and i go 98 you could play king d3
here and still fight for the advantage
it's not like the advantage has
completely dissipated but i cannot play
98 anymore because after roof ca
checking d3 takes black gets just about
enough counter play it's still a mess
there's a lot of checks here for black
knight c5 pawn on e4 is weak but there's
also problems with the king on h7 knight
f6 check coming in some positions f5
coming in some positions so still kind
of a messy endgame not the most clear
cut white is definitely the one that's
preferred because of the piece activity
despite the fact that you're getting a
lot of pawns in many of these positions
but
definitely not the advantage and control
that he had had he played b4 instead of
f4 and certainly not
the advantage if he had just won the
piece earlier
f4 peter i'm sorry i find that to be
such a peculiar move here we have uh the
current standings with one game uh
finished yeah and this is why levon is
sitting sitting pretty there on top
alone five and a half but yeah with the
way the wesley game is going you expect
that to also probably finish in a draw i
think very likely i think it's difficult
for wesley to create winning chances
there but i don't expect him to
uh yeah and we do have a pretty sharp
you know by g3 greenfield standards we
have a pretty sharp position in the mvl
game and algereza is burning quite a bit
of time he's down to uh
less than half an hour on move 18. the
position is simplified i'm pretty sure
black is completely fine
but generating winning chances here as
black is not is not very
straightforward i find the move rook f1
e1 a little uh confusing i mean i
understand that if i do play a move like
e2 e3 uh peter i am weakening my f three
squared
let me put it another way i
i would like this diagonal to be open
contested yeah yeah where do i i would
like to take your pawn on c6 the knight
on c3 has got to go yeah e392 is a very
logical continuation here exactly so e3
will will prep the move knight e2 i'll
open up my bishop maybe on a good day
it'll land on d4 and or f4 and i'm happy
i do want to say that after something i
can say h7h5 is a very very topical move
in all of these positions i think once
the bishop on g2 gets straighted away h5
i'm actually surprised mvl hasn't played
it in the current position yet
i would assume like his hand must be
reaching for it already and the point
here being that yeah h494 is very
unattractive clear
so you play h3 and then like the
inclusion just you know you you gave
luff to your king on g8 so if h5 is
always automatically met by h3 i think
there's no downside and there is
potentially some upside because you can
imagine some scenarios in which h4 g4
and then might land and then i don't
know or f5 yeah or 26 knight takes g4
somewhere suddenly works for somebody it
normally doesn't right but you if it
doesn't you don't play h4 and you've
just included h5 h3 which should be in
your favor
uh but then yeah then white wants to go
knight two but my point is once you play
knight two i guess i just play c65 and i
ask why am i supposed to be worse here i
know rook fd8 here i'm also attracted to
the idea of playing a5 but specifically
against e392 i think a5 maybe is
somewhat
for the moment i don't want to give up
the default i like to contest it yeah
do you like
well i mean
it's a completely different ballgame but
get behind first off e2 e3
pardon me uh get behind the move rook f1
to e1 he's playing suggests he wants to
play e4 but d4 i think is kind of
it's a very risky uh
well not very risky but somewhat risky
in the structures because it does give
up some squares potentially like the
knight could start jumping
um
the knight going to g4 e5 or g7 and then
e5 and or c5 and the the
yeah i actually kind of prefer the pawn
on e3 where it presents less of a target
than on e4 okay
let's go let's let's have some fun at
their expense of course yeah yeah i mean
h5 a move i can definitely uh get behind
but uh
let me let me try to channel my
alireza maybe he actually wants to play
five against anything here like you go
97 white maybe can steal goldif
that was my
channeling i mean if you're going to put
your rook on e1 and you're going to try
to exploit the fact that there is a
queen
if white gets in a 4 in 94
this is the absolute dream scenario of
course yeah like blecco you know has
some moves to counter right
you're not you're not a sitting target
yeah and this is where my idea i don't
like it's it's not very topical again
specifically rookie one but i do want to
bring up the idea of instead of h5
playing a5 you know i seem to be only
playing with my
outside pawns here that larson would
yeah
and the idea here i'm not very sure how
i assess the position after a4 b4 and
knight somewhere but yeah this is this
is my point i want to play a4 i want to
get rid of this slightly backward pawn
on a7 i also want to ask the question
if white
uh sort of agrees with the trade of
everything along the e file but here if
i
a b can you go here
no no a3 no a3
ef here i don't know that's actually
very clever yeah you have good f6
yes sir
good morning st louis yeah very uh very
sharp uh
but uh
a5a4 it's a bit slow specifically
against rookie one it feels a bit slow
against other moves i was very much in
favor of that idea strategically but
against rookie one it might be uh on the
on the you know
well it's it's weird because one of the
things i mean i'm a queen's gambit
accepted player and i always know the
value of a c4 square i wasn't sure about
this i wasn't uh maybe i should be quite
worried on the other hand it gets very
concrete like in that position it's not
very it's not very topical but just
quick even queen before check
queen e4 check this is the end game that
i thought i was trying to embrace as
white well i i very much want to trade
the bishops and not my 96 for the for
the bishop like if if my remaining 92
here i think i'm better right yeah
this is all very concrete because
strategically i'm sort of busted
but because i left my knight alive the
opponent b3 is a legitimate target at a
legitimate target yeah and your pieces
are kind of ill-equipped to deal with
the threat of 1992 somewhat weirdly it
is it's actually a
very very annoying threat in this
particular position knight d2 and or
knight and on knight c5 right yeah um
now i can take
and then play rook b1 which looks
completely yeah but i don't believe i'm
much worse to be honest like regular g8
like i'm trying to get rid of this guy
but now i go 92 c5 c4 and once again d2
c5 oh
whoa whoa that was a little fast peter
c5 i get to play knight e3 yeah c4
c4 yeah why not
well
yeah well i don't know why not guys are
so important
i don't pretend black has much winning
chances but i think it's playable and in
general i think a5a4 is something that
is
not not ridiculous as a plan
alejandro way in here because peter is
oscillating between h5
playing on the king side
and a5 playing on the queen side and
he's coming to the conclusion that both
work is he right
uh
personally a5 i find quite good h5 i do
not understand
almost at all because h4 i mean i don't
really understand you want to take on on
g3 do you want to play h3 i'm just going
to lead you do whatever you want to do
so against h5 i'm going to go e4 and
black is in actual trouble because e5 is
coming a5 is a little more cagey
but if you want to start any of these
operations the engines think that the
best move is rook f38 a5 is fine a5 e4
goes into a little bit of a mess but
rook fd8 is probably a better way to
equip yourself against e4 if you don't
think e4 is a big deal go ahead and play
a5 you think that e4 is a big deal you
play rook fd8 why because i guess e4 i
have this move knight d7 and knight c5
or knight e5 is actually coming into the
position
so you're thinking why not e5 in this
position right that was the whole point
it has a little tactical drawback this
move queen c5
a5 is also fine by the way in this
position no problems with the black uh
position there according to the engine
but queen c5 is cool because now you're
starting to take on e5 since there is no
pin and you've counter pin the knight on
c3 to the queen on c2 so b4 is a winning
threat white can't really defend from
both of them you have to play the movie
six tactically it works out because
after pawn takes you don't take on e6
because again b4 but you're giving up
the pawn to make a weakness and you can
play rookie 2 and defend the queen now
are you playing for an advantage
not really but you are kind of
equalizing this is not fun for white at
all so i think the move rook fd8 is a
pretty cool way of meeting e4 because
knight d7 knight c3 sorry i just have a
959 d3 it's going to be a very strong
idea you guys mentioned that the moment
the pawn on e4 comes there the knight
hops become very dangerous and you were
mentioning exactly the square on d3 as a
potential hop for the knight gets there
it's very strong 97 is very good queen
e6 a5 other moves are also quite good
the engines think that they're all the
same i personally am inclined to moving
the knight because it opens up the
bishop and it allows the knight to
maneuver where he wants to go so a lot
of resources here for mvl it's one of
those positions where the engine says
every move is zero it doesn't matter
which one he chooses he's gonna be in a
fine position but i still think that
practically there will be some stronger
decisions than others meanwhile speaking
of practical linear dominguez against
wesley so yes
we are we've been talking about wesley
playing very quickly and what is this
causing linear to be linear 12 minutes
left for the white player in this
position still 13 moves to make an hour
and 12 an hour two minutes an hour two
minutes difference there between these
two players and the engines thinking
that
linear is the one that needs to start
thinking about equalizing
wow the knighto g4 a little too far away
from the rest of the pieces
yeah and if if you
could uh alejandro uh clear a few
cobwebs about the move rook f1 to e1 for
me for a moment it
it had oddly recently
had ali reza played the move e2 e3 did
the computers find that to be a superior
or as good a move as rookie one inferior
inferior in fear they think that and now
h5 makes sense now i try makes a little
more sense
but waiting for your chance there peter
you have to admit it makes a lot more
sense when you have the light squares
opened up because i agree at some point
it might be an idea it doesn't think
it's a much worse move but it's also not
really sure what your follow-up is
because it was intended for 92.
i think that was the intended follow-up
was to go knight
let's just make a random move okay well
there i would challenge the rook but
okay fine yeah and now you're just
letting me yeah as i said just the
moment you play knight two i go c5 you
go c5 i still don't believe black has
anything but black should also be
completely fine i don't know if black
has nothing i mean you go see five rooks
because this knight's not going to d4
on f4 it's okay but it's not doing that
much i'm just going to play rook c8 c4
and at that point i'm going to have a
nice choice between taking with the rook
or creating a pass pawn that i
understand could be weak in some
scenarios but i mean if i can tactically
force it to c3 that's going to be very
dangerous for you and where is white's
plan because i get it with the pawn here
on d5
you get this isolated uh hanging pump
position knight before you pressure the
center without the pawn on d5 the pawn
being on b5 this structure is fine
and it's going to start rolling at some
point you have more tactical threats
with queen b7 and uh light square
problems on the king side than black
does with this diagonal so black starts
getting a little bit of an initiative
here i think rook c8 even h5 at some
point a5a4 comes very easily as black
ideas and i don't see the white ideas
and which is why the engines are
thinking that rook f1 is a superior move
to go e4 start using your majority start
pushing your majority in this position
and after a long thing queen c5 on the
board by mvl
initial impression of the engine is not
a great move we're we're going to let it
think sometimes the initial impressions
are not that important row kc1 already
on the board because while b4 was kind
of a big threat and you're putting more
pressure on the c file initial
impression is also i'm not really a big
fan of this move because of the pressure
on the c file it feels like you're just
helping
white develop yeah but we're gonna let
them think here a little bit man they
can't think it's linear so i'm gonna i
want to pay special attention to the
next few moves here because wesley's
playing
very very quickly and putting some real
pressure in this position you can see
that even though this structure is
definitely superior for white this
rook's coming to a2 knight seven
is specifically extremely annoying
knight c2 is a very annoying move
i
this knight is one of those really
pretty nights
but it doesn't do anything it doesn't do
anything this is defended this is
forever defended it needs to be on f3
right and this is
some pressure against the e5 the thing
is you don't have that much time to
maneuver right black does have threats
in this position it's not like you can
just move the knights around forever at
some point you're gonna have to do
something concrete with the white pieces
i just don't see what it is and remember
10 minutes now
very good we'll definitely keep an eye
on this one as well uh lavone aronian
after all if wesley were to win this
game no playoff i'd like to jump back to
the game between richie and
ian for just a moment
f4 a move that we quiz let's be frank
knight b3 takes takes okay now we see
richie's idea he did want to cement the
knight yeah i wanted to support the 96
optically it looks a little bit better
for white but i would assume it's uh now
very very close to uh to nothing
because to nothing because you know so
much so much came off the board that
there needs to i think there has to be a
way to
uh to clean this up for uh for young
unfortunately and just at least the
engines don't find it they think that
rook design was just yeah well w7 really
confused me i will say that
you know considering e4e5 is coming why
are we abandoning the the one open file
that we have and the potential
counterplay that we have thank you very
much for that i was like uh you give up
the uh open file i'm not sure i thought
you would want to play playing moves
like rook c2 and
didn't like the the line starting with
knight xf7 i would assume because
otherwise you just kind of insta insta
play this right
yeah you can even you can even include
92 check but i don't know if that's if
it's i didn't know if i wanted this
night uh this early yeah yeah this
earlier but several d7 here i can see
why you would be
why you would be worried about this
because you know knight c5 even that's a
nice tempo
is clever yeah and rook let's say a7 you
can maybe
yeah but the king honestly there's no
discovery yeah
maybe yeah yeah h6h5 i think is very
simple because the knight is five covers
e6 this is very important right it
protects e6 as well as asus
everything is defended true and now
we're going to check this uh rugby three
checkers are much more serious now we
start thinking about winning yeah yeah
that's what i mean but uh the move for
me that was very confusing uh was rook c
seven
because this is what white wanted this
has been a series of confusing moves i
mean this entire game has been a series
of confusing moves i understand some of
the tactical blunders that we've seen
here but
playing c5 without preparation right to
me was just bizarre i mean play knight
d7 first then play c5 the entire game
has been very strange and i think we're
just following the series of strange
moves because rook d7 was played and
after e5 takes takes well it looks kind
of stuck there right i don't
see exactly where the plan is for white
but this point is backwards and then
maybe start pushing on the king side
it's slow yeah it's slow but what is
black doing right i can consider putting
my rook on f1 i can start considering
putting my king somewhere on the queen
side so the rook never actually
penetrates on c2 start pushing these
guys how is this king rejoining the fray
the pawn is doing a very good job of
keeping the king out of f6 keeping the
the knight keeps the king out of f5 so
you're kind of stuck on the king's side
this king has a little bit more freedom
the knight on b3 it's not easy to attack
but again it's so far away from
attacking one of white's pawns right
it's one two three from this one one two
three from that one so
it's not in an ideal position either
perhaps it's difficult to break through
but again white is the one with all the
pressure
agreed uh
i also i just wanted to say about the
game between daniel and fabi it is those
two bishops versus bishop and knight
there is this extra pawn on h2 but that
pawn on h2 is not advancing yeah it's
just very difficult to imagine how it
even reaches h4 i don't know exactly i
don't think white wins even if it does
but
i was actually thinking that fabi might
just
bank his bishop on h3 and get rid of me
i think he wants to introduce the idea
of b7 b5 simply i think i think bishop
d7 is an indication that he wants to
remind uh bogdan that there is a
majority on the queen side which is not
moving currently but you could start
because black's you know the easiest way
to make a draw here is to actually
continue trading stuff yeah and before i
follow biking b6 and by exerting some
pressure on the queen side is a way to
further further you know distract white
from making any progress on me on the
king's side makes perfect should be a
draw yeah it's a funny position because
i don't think the evaluation changes at
all if you just remove the pawn from h2
yeah i was going to say that yeah
it's kind of weird that
right yeah why could player bishop takes
h4 and still not lose but also
white is not winning any of them you
know never yeah and again uh returning
to our
wesley so game
uh wesley so of course fighting for the
first place here
with black we just saw the move bishop
uh e3 yeah
yeah it's not both of the problems we
were talking about earlier knight c2 was
annoying attacking this bishop and also
the knight on g4 needs to be brought
back into the frame into the fray and
knight c2 i guess he goes knight g3 here
in knight g4
knight c4
but yeah the pawn on b3 is definitely
the biggest weakness on the board and
your stuff starts hanging it's uh
you have to be very careful here with
white there is a double uh double attack
that could be nasty and you kind of
intimated this already
yourself alejandra that well maybe
lanier
should just
be a little careful
but first of all let's jump to bucharest
with christian and a special guest
thank you yes sir yes we are here indeed
with michael koldarkovsky the executive
director of the granchester and one of
the masterminds behind this global
project michael welcome to our studio
first of all tell us a bit about this
tournament the superbath chess classic
how do you assess it from a viewer's
perspective as well as from an
organizer's perspective i think both
very well run on one end and very well
played on another so i think uh
players uh met all expectations and
we're
basically to the wire and very possible
that we're going to have tiebreak
so therefore i think organizers are
happy spectators are happy people keep
coming
to see the action
until the end of the day and tell us a
bit about the selection process because
one thing that strikes me about this
tournament is the eclectic mix of young
talent as well as experienced players
and of course four candidates tell us
about that
that's our goal
uh first of all to have top players
and of course to bring
young guns to give opportunity for young
aspiring players who already showed
good skills and good results in
different tournaments
not necessarily they're welcome to any
other tournaments therefore we give
wildcard to to those
who may perform well and actually be
recognized and especially here in
romania we have a couple of interesting
youngsters and one of them is bogdan
diak
and
last year he played here
and he did well
as well as this one and right now he's
playing last round against fabiana and i
think that he will finish on 50
very decent result and i'm sure that
romanian
chess community will be
very happy to see that
now one thing that helps us bring all
these amazing players here in bucharest
as well as all the other uh stuffs of
the tour is the partnerships that you
guys are creating now a big one is with
the superbad foundation tell us about
that as well as all the local sponsors
that you guys have engaged for this year
yeah super bad foundation became our
major partner in europe
and they sponsoring all of all three
events
in uh in europe uh zagreb warsaw and
zagreb and of course bucharest
and
because of that
obviously they have
aspirations
to be
probably a
capital
uh of europe if saint louis chess club
is a national capital of chess in the
united states
i'm sure that bucharest may become a
capital of europe
and uh obviously
uh armenian uh players
only have more opportunities for growth
and i just met
during the course of this tournament i
met
several youngsters
i even played some games with them i
visited school where we
established the program so
little by little
uh bucharest and romania become uh
i would say right now big hop
for european chess michael you've
mentored so many young aspiring chess
players how important is it for this
young romanian players as well as polish
and croatian young players to see the
best of the best compete face to face
well you know i remember my youth
and
of course every tournament that we
attended and we
saw
uh
legends with so our heroes on stage
playing
it was aspiring we certainly wanted to
be
at least one of them if not all of them
and obviously we have
our own heroes maybe to follow
but it is very inspiring and
seeing here many youngsters from the
opening ceremony for playing
simultaneous exhibitions and visiting
day by day
uh every round
you can see that it's big interest and
it's a
factor
of future of cheers in romania
absolutely as this tournament finishes
we're getting ready to uh go to warsaw a
new stop in the grand chess tour how did
that came about and what are your
expectations for at that stop of the
tour well it would be first time and
again it's because super bad foundation
uh has its offices in
in poland
and they decided to open new stuff for
us on the tour
and uh having uh duda and voy tashak
playing especially dude is another
another candidate for uh
for the world championship cycle it
would be very excited for a polish crowd
and
i know for sure it would be packed
well i love the fact that a competition
almost feels like brewing between
romania
so and all this stuff is trying to
establish themselves as the european
capital of chess now
to finalize this interview i would like
to ask your opinion about the games
today michael we know that we do have a
draw and of course i want to ask your
opinion about this one how do you see
the position does wesley have any
chances of actually winning this one out
right
well you know it's hard to say whether
he will be able to win outright but
definitely he will be pushing for that
because this is the chance for him to
win uh first leg
and grab first price and uh
uh
bonus point towards grand chess tour so
this game will continue
you know he will be pushing and as we
were uh entering the interview you also
mentioned this game and and we are
potentially trying to do something in
his game against uh ali reza what do you
think of this well uh cue
two frenchmen
are playing uh against each other
obviously
each of them wants to win
for uh for maxime it's opportunity to
catch up with uh
and potentially so and it would be a
three-way tie
and that would be even more exciting to
see along a long saturday night
uh cheers
and uh again this
this tournament
uh showed us that
nerves are
uh not very steady
uh for for the chess players there were
some blunders here is very dynamic
balanced position and
we might see some excitement this type
of
exciting chess is exactly what we are
looking forward to seeing these type of
events thank you very much michael for
joining us and we'll see you soon in
poland of course
guys back to you
thank you christian thank you michael
and let's just jump into the game of
wesley uh what's your take
on this game uh peter
yeah i've been trying to figure out
exactly how to uh to equalize properly
with white and i came to no conclusions
it's a it's a weird position where it
looks like you have the better pawn
structure but the the knight does come
to d4 in all of these lines the other
one is aimed towards the c5 square and
the pawn on b3 in particular now that we
played bishop g2 i understood why the
move bishop d2 was played but it also
takes away the g2 square from the knight
on f1 meaning that protecting the bomb
on b3 if it comes under severe pressure
is going to become it's going to become
deep more difficult so
and you know if you couple all that with
the fact that you know wesley is an hour
ahead on the clock
uh linear has been in this spot before
and you know seven minutes for 30 moves
is nothing to him right but still with
the increment yeah but still this is not
this is not where he wanted to be i'm
pretty sure today and exactly
i think uh somewhat weirdly uh rook a4
is kind of a fancy a fancy move on the
move 26 this uh
tactic i think she takes before was
probably cleaner in terms of making sure
that you're never worse exactly
rook a4 uh
kind of
misfired a little bit boomerang a little
bit yeah
and uh
yeah he is it's also very difficult to
choose moves because all of your options
here appear to be very similar you can
play bishop c3
you can play f3 you can put a knight on
e3 i i suspect that if a knight goes to
e3 it's the g4 knight because the f1
knight is easier to
find uh job jobs for yeah later in the
game right uh but yeah all of the all of
them seem similar but all of them also
don't entirely solve your underlying
issues of yeah precisely this line for
instance
we appear to have lost a pawn
here does he does address it by trading
f3
just to make sure that at least the pawn
on e4 is never going to hang for the
rest of the game uh
but this is where i start to get very
seriously worried i see a move like f3 i
can even see you know like well i don't
know but uh the rook can come to b8 the
bishop can even land very powerfully on
this diagonal knight c5 g3 rk2 is
another way to kind of make progress for
black here just forget about the b3 pawn
for now activate all of our pieces get
get this knight to a very nice
square on d3 the other one goes to d4
and white starts kind of
experiencing problem problems you know
finding breathing space for their pieces
victor kochner had an expression that i
liked very much white starts having
unpleasant sensations
yeah pleasant sensation
okay i got that uh is white having
unpleasant sensations alejandro i think
this is pretty clear right because the
sensations are there but is it enough
that's what we have to see because
white's position is extremely solid
after f2 f3 it's very difficult to
attack anything besides perhaps the b3
pawn but even that one is difficult to
reach and white is preparing to regroup
right this knight is going to go to e3
it's going to go to c4 this bishop might
reroute to c3 at some point this knight
will either go to d2 or e3 on d2 is
going to do a good job of defending the
b3 pawn as well so not easy to make a
real progress in this position perhaps
knight d4 is a move how would you even
start in this position because
everything seems tempting but you can
only choose one move at a time i think
rookie 2 would be my choice because you
just control the second rank before
deciding what to do on the on the next
moves i can understand why on some
occasions you might want the rook b8 to
attack b3
but i think at this point it comes down
to style uh knight g3 for example knight
c5 is is playable and after knight c4
the engines are saying look you got to
play a little bit on the slow side just
go bishop e7 try to reroute the bishop
in some variations
and just allow yourself to go knight d4
with time don't rush it and black is
better but in none of the variations do
they show a very clear advantage linear
always having the possibility of
minimizing risk minimizing damage it's
very passive in many positions but very
difficult for black to actually make a
breakthrough
all right thank you for that alejandro
turning our attention for a moment peter
to the game
of mvl for a moment i i'm not a big fan
of mvl's decision to train queens i
think can you explain that to us please
well i think it was back here yeah
exactly i think quincy five is the the
real culprit here
having gotten to the position after okay
one rook 891 i can relate to quintex c2
because 25 check of 3 i didn't
particularly like either right oh that
in that case i i feel like white's
pieces are really well coiled uh to make
an expansion whether it be by e4 or 83
or i think the g3 is or even knight f2
but i i like this because
for white i mean alejandro a moment ago
was pointing out that if black gets to
go c5 c4 he's the one having the fun
yeah and this is currently very
difficult to organize so
it feels to me that quincy five really
uh
was the beginning of a wrong plan and
i'm not entirely sure what was missed
there maybe he just felt less optimistic
about his position in general uh after
cafe one than we thought he should
but yeah currently like it doesn't look
like it's much
but it's very very obvious that black is
not going to be playing for a win
anymore in this game you just have to
defend this uh carefully and hope that
everything holds with the ball on b7
black of course would have been
completely completely fine yeah yeah
totally different animals
you you do have to worry a little bit
well it's a backward pawn on the half
open file and
white's play rather speaks for itself
right
in the meantime yeah i wonder
you still don't really have any
proactive replies to knight e3 and i
would say that it's probably a little
bit too slow but the e3 is generally
speaking not the ideal square now this
piece you want it on d3 yes but i think
getting it to d3 is a bit is a bit too
too slow
king no i mean you can go with three
knight f2 in in the current position
like the way the way to get g3 would be
not to put it on e3 in the first place i
think
but f3 looks like allowing 95 in this in
this kind of a position just doesn't
feel right to me at all exactly no no no
no but i i on the other hand peter i'm
thinking
as white i'm really anxious to double
the rook side
control of the play on the queen side
and i wonder what does rookie six
signify in terms of what what uh mvl is
planning to reply to this with maybe he
actually wants to go knight e4 here okay
let's say bishop g7 king g7 rookie c1
and play maybe c6 c5
hoping that it works out tactically
because f3 currently can be met by
knight takes g3
yes this is a very very high risk
strategy because obviously on c5 this
the spawn is being supported by air
right basically so if white manages to
attack it in a way that it's sufficient
yeah i hardly believe this works yeah
knight d5 or something 95 yeah i wanted
to just start chasing like i go rook g8
well you you mentioned that bringing the
knight to d3 might be ideal but let's
continue please like rook g8 rook david
eight yeah neither four i want to go
rook a6 pause pause pause sorry i'm i'm
i'm looking at knights he said has seen
so many lines where he's winning upon he
just doesn't know
is very annoying i thought i solved it
but actually there is knight a6 there in
the end i thought i will go rugby six
rugby seven and be kind of okay but
they're actually three yeah f3 uh ruby
seven knight h6 is very very unpleasant
exactly that's the healthy pawn that you
didn't
want to fall into so there are issues
suddenly for mvl and absolutely and the
culprit
in your view was queen c5 yeah this is a
kind of a position where
you have weakened your queenside
structure by playing b5 very early on in
the game but as long as the queens stay
on the board it's not as keenly failed
because you always have some some
tactical counterplay but once you
voluntarily pretty much here take the
queens off the board
those structural issues they come into
much stark
focus and
yeah i don't like what he's done to his
position
if i'm
[Music]
honest here i just don't like it i i'm
struggling to figure out
what his intended reply to knight e3 was
maybe he wants bishop h6 bishop takes e3
but like all of this is very artificial
yeah and it also indicates just how
unpleasant it is if you play normally
yeah just thinking of these games that
i've witnessed of
both anderson wolf would capture
this knight put a knight on d3
and just you know
champion what's white's cars
it's a very serious option even here but
yeah if you take on f6 it takes you so
long to get the knight to g3 that's the
issue i'm not sure it's the best right
but it definitely is something you could
seriously consider even here right right
and alejandro what is richie
and nepo doing
they've really traded off into an end
game it's a two result end game because
you see this powerful rook on d6 it's
hamming in this rook on b7 and you can't
activate because you take on b6 of
course and the engines are suggesting
the move b5 i cannot imagine b5 will not
be placed i'm going to put it on the
board and we got this end game between
this powerful rook and this kind of lame
rook on b7 but it's not so easy to make
progress also the problem is this king
coming to f5 is really annoying it's
really annoying in any in any position
and also how do you make progress here
with the white pieces yes you have this
problem with the rook not being able to
move but the king can't penetrate on the
king on the queen side queen side uh if
you don't play the move b5 and you try
to go this way king f5 king takes e5
will always be a resource for the black
side you're never on time to do so so b5
is currently on uh on the board as
expected yep and i don't
see the breakthrough the engines are
saying pretty much equal
they give white a very slight advantage
like 0.3 but at this point it's really
nothing and they just don't think you
can make a whole ton of progress here so
optically better for richard however i
think that this is a defensible position
for black and i expect the game to
eventually fizzle out to a draw
all right thank you for that alejandro
as we're in breaktor territory uh we
want to say that uh during our break we
have an interview
uh with and natalie zhukova and
anastasia we'll see you on the other
side of the break
[Music]
here we are next to the plane when you
together with natalia zhukov a two-time
european champion ukrainian grandmaster
who came directly from odessa from
ukraine natalia how was your trip tell
us welcome
thank you very much nice to be here yeah
uh yes i i came here a couple of days
ago
yes of course it was a difficult
trip
i came by own car i was alone
and
on the road it was some tanks military
i don't know how to say mars cars yes
and so on it was very big traffic you
know and in our country now it's it's a
problem with
gas
for the known reason yeah and
my trip was about 12
hours
finally you are here and you are you
were invited as a guest of the
tournament and you came just on time to
take part in this fund rising event for
ukraine what were your impressions yes
first of all i would like to thank
organizers and sponsor super beds that
they support ukrainian people
what is very important for them
people ukrainian people feel that
they are not alone
as they're fighting for freedom
for whole world you know i mean
the prices uh unfortunately fortunately
very high
but
but people are very brave
and
we are very thankful that
[Music]
they everybody support us you know
this fundraising event
also
the money goes to them to refugees
in romania
[Music]
you are also very very brave person
natalia we all know that you stayed for
two months in ukraine before you came
here and i know that when while you were
still playing during that game that day
was fundraising event you were fighting
still for the victory how did it go
yes thank you very much actually uh
yeah
when we started the game you know i
started to think about chess before and
now it's
difficult to concentrate of course
because
every time you know
you
you scroll up news you know you just
follow everything and uh
yes it was very nice interesting game
you know against
wesley saw yes and
i don't know if he played uh with
sponsor um and we won
to zero even you have one to zero right
and it was uh very good games and i
heard you had a lot of fun yes had a lot
of fun with trash talking you know it's
nice
and nice moves you know on the board you
know
yeah it was nice
coming back to the grand chess tour did
you have a chance to follow the games
and the event did you come to the plane
when you
oh you know the tournament is great you
know the this grand cheers tour it's
just a fantastic event and everybody
missed otb
uh chess
uh because pandemic was so so you know
just it's traffic what we said that
pandemic is the worst thing we thought
it's pandemic is the word but uh this is
it not
uh and now we see these games and um i
saw some game version
maximus algorithm against quran and some
with sacrifices rook f3 or something
like this you know it was very nice
yeah
uh and natalie my last question i mean
you are a chess player yourself we
belong to the chess world do you feel
the support of chess people and how is
your life in odessa these days
yeah actually
from the very first day
[Music]
ceo of
kasparov chess foundation
texted me and
offered support
the fundraising the money for the chess
player in ukraine which
which i send them
you know
we collect this money and it's very very
important for them you know because
people now
have the problem with salary with
making this everything you know you know
some houses are destroyed some
people many many refugees
they know 5 million already
had to go out from our country
probably couple of millions
inside inside the country and of course
it's very very big problem
and
yeah once once again i want to say that
we are very thankful for everybody
they support ukrainian people
thank you so much you're a very brave
woman and i wish you all the best of
luck same as for for our country
and thank you for coming here and for
joining us today and we are going back
to the studio to peter alejandro and
yasser
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the final round of the
bucharest chess classic and we still
have a lot going on with
one of our leaders and one of the the
leaders pursuers still very much in play
absolutely peter but in the meanwhile we
do have a result in the game of richie
and richie is with christian in
bucharest
thank you
yasser yes we are indeed with richard
report after quite a tense game richard
first of all welcome back to the studio
take us uh through today's game as well
as your strategy it seemed from the
beginning that you were determined to
finish with a victory in this one oh not
really i mean i went for um this novelty
quincy one but i think he was well
prepared
um he reacted with very principle um
but then of course he was playing a
temple and here he should insert the g5
bishop history to fully equalize
and you are still aware of uh
first line of engine so it's not too
much of a mystery and then he went for
allowing me to take on f6 and c1
okay i think i'm slightly better here
and then
okay
i mean there's a reason why we are in
the last two places yes so he was
playing uh very quickly still he plays
c5
takes
just to move just to try to prove that
he's equalizing immediately takes okay
he's already works here but then he went
97 which is again trying to you know
recapture with the knight which just
doesn't seem to work so after this point
of nd4 i felt like it's completely over
and he went knight c5 which makes
things even worse for him and then i of
course
as per usual in my weight games there
was only one thing to blunder in this
position and i managed to accomplish
that after which obviously i was clearly
not
able to recover uh sort of speed because
okay i see this position of 1985 i think
i have like one hour or something like
that and one hour yeah
and then i say okay i have two winning
moves so 95 is one before is the other
right and okay i was just like 50 50.
but of course one of them is clearly
winning and the other is you know what i
did
and yeah i'm still much better i guess
in the end game after brooke takes this
seven so what exactly did you miss well
i mean this king h7 i mean it's not
that hard to spot actually right because
the rook hd one at this point and here
i'm expecting the line this might be 797
or takes and there's this very pretty
line here which i thought okay is b4
rock c8 bc5 g7 cb6
and you know like uh
yeah and then promoting so okay but k7
and he just takes the pawn after which
obviously i still have a big advantage
and it does seem like king h7 is the
only one why not king g7 explain it was
the difference rook c7 will be hanging
yes after
before
and now yeah in the 1988
yeah that's um an easy thing to miss of
course
well for me apparently yeah
and then yeah afterwards i'm still of
course much better in the same game but
i just
i couldn't okay i'm not playing for
anything honestly and i mean such a miss
on
any level really but on this level this
one around the clock is just
unexplainable so i figure i couldn't
focus on the game too much
i was very happy not to lose this one at
least you know
now richard of course for a professional
player such as yourself you have to get
used to sometimes losing or sometimes
not having optimal tournaments because
you're just going to play in a couple of
days how are you going to deal with that
what do you do to get back into it
i don't know we'll see um okay i'm not
the only one i guess who's not doing the
things too well i mean also jan of
course played a horrible
game today i mean
yesterday as well and there are some of
us who are um
on the receiving end of things sort of
i'm the only one i think holder playing
in poland but okay it's just with them
blitz so you know i might get away with
things like this
is there a specific uh psychological
trick that you like to imply in between
uh tournaments try to get back
immediately in shape
or just go and play and see where that
is not at all no i mean okay i
i just really don't see the point of
showing up to games here which i play
this way i mean it's
kind of a disrespecting of chess in my
opinion i mean it's a very nice game i
have one around the clock and then i
make a move with the rings you know
everything and also like that we have
these scenarios also against the arc
when i'm winning in 20 moves in this
right here it's very strange i mean and
then like i said to score half point out
of these two two positions so i feel
like you know i feel kind of
i don't know what to do how to put it i
i obviously don't feel good about this
but at the end of the day it is just a
game and you know this is how i've
played it uh this time so okay we will
see what happens next i guess uh
eventually it will stop happening one
way or another
richard you're still one of the best
chess players on the planet go get your
rest and we're going to see you in a few
days
guys back to you christian uh
let richie know that we all on on staff
uh on the panel love his tie
i love his time we do but honestly he
doesn't feel like he is perhaps in the
in the best
in the best frame of mind i appreciate
it richard everybody on the panel loves
your tie
oh yeah
yeah but actually i think the first uh
gift from my wife back then we were just
uh dating yeah should not be like yeah
long long years ago
so yeah this is very i'm sorry sweet
yeah very symbolic yeah
it's it's it's great if you cannot see
it it has robots on it it's brilliant
yeah your thai your wife has great taste
great taste great taste
uh yes indeed richie uh we hope to see
you back no question about
guys and robots there you go um not his
tournament that is for sure uh we'll put
this one away and say
uh next
and he has plenty coming up because he
is a very busy chess player he's
actually playing in another super
tournament even before the candidates
started playing in norway chess and i
think it's human tamer right of the of
the candidates yes i believe him and
we'll both be playing in norway that
will be their last stop before the
candidate so a lot of chess for him
coming up i believe he's playing another
tournament between here and norway
he's he is playing worse
you have the game of fobby on your
screen it's not much of a game i just
have everything on the board but here uh
king c2 bishop h4 king c3 bishop b7 is
some sort of weird repetition but
something they will find something to
draw this game there's no way white can
make progress with the knight against
trying to support i mean this is just
dead the bishops are too strong there's
too much pressure everywhere else
materials to reduce nothing to do in
this position zero zero with everything
linear and dominguez linear dominguez
and wesley saw this is the game that
keeps the intrigue bishop e1 was a great
defensive move
allowing other pieces to come to d2 it
also removes the bishop from the
tactical tricks of the rook question is
what do you attack here with black right
you have this bishop pressuring the
opponent before but it's not so easy to
get more attackers on it because white
already has defended it twice this pawn
on g2 already defended by the knight on
e3 so even if you go 92 knight f4 you're
still not hitting the pawn directly so
the question again similar to what
furuja has how do you make progress in
those positions because ferruccia does
have a slight edge in his position well
not anymore according to the engine when
we left it we left it here at the move
rookie six knight e3 and nvl played rook
d8 which i liked quite a bit
um
a knight f1 was played in this position
which to me is kind of a mystery where
the knight is going wow we'll find out i
thought he was going to play rook c1 and
perhaps what he didn't like was his
chances of winning in the following end
game 95 looks more or less forced you
have to defend this pawn somehow and
tactically this does the trick you
cannot take on g7 because this is check
and so i take on d5 bishop b2 knight f4
and then take on e6 not so clear if
that's a dead drawn end game there's
still some life there for white because
of the better structure probably better
to take with the rook bishop takes g7
king takes g7 and then e3 at the end you
don't want to take on c6 that
immediately ends the game in the draw
and how many chances do you have winning
the sand game honestly i don't think
it's very high you put the rook on d6
you transfer the king to d7 you hold on
to your only weakness yeah these rooks
are better than this ones but this
majority is not going forward anytime
soon really is white better yeah white
technically is better but perhaps lyresa
did not like the amount of chances this
he gave this gave him wanted to keep
more pieces on the board play the move
knight f1 but after 95 takes takes an a3
you have this powerful knight compared
to those knight on f1 so that causes
quite an impression and after a move
like a5 or even the immediate b4 you
could break up the structure on the
queen side just to um target the pawn on
b3 or you could play something like a5
consider the moves a4 or b4 then take
with the pawn and stop establish a
knight on c3 you're kind of playing for
the three results i still feel it's a
very equalish end game
but the move knight f1 just indicates to
me alireza is here to fight
is he gonna get there that's a different
question
no no that move knight f1
it feels a little
distasteful i will go back to the game
of wesley so for a second
because uh let me get your take here um
uh peter i
you know like whenever my oh
i sense a playoff oh yeah very very very
quickly coming uh here
i was about to say i i like the position
for black i i agree with alejandro
it's
it's
it's a long process for you to prove
some kind of an edge
but
yeah yeah
he's not around here he is not yeah he
is not even asking for
the third nightly to check he just
called for an arbiter and said king
jiwan here will repeat right and leslie
does not disagree yeah wesley clearly
would have played 92 check anyway but
you don't you don't actually ask the
question because wesley could perhaps
you know if you feel that he has a very
safe edge but the the question that we
were
asking earlier just how you make
progress i don't have an answer uh it's
very very unobvious uh king to b5
yeah
i don't even necessarily i know what
you're saying and uh
off air as we were listening to uh to to
richie give an interview with with
christian i did say i think wesley will
win this
you have do witnesses here too it wasn't
it wasn't on there but i did say that it
felt to me that he is making enough
progress here and it's it's his type of
position you know it's a riskless uh
riskless uh free role exactly
where white will never have you know an
active move to make for the rest of the
game quite clearly and you just greenly
protect your one weakness and you have
you know your pieces are fighting for
breathing space on you know in the
bottom three ranks
wesley has won positions like this uh
many a time in his career right but i
guess he just didn't feel optimistic
enough about conversion and he probably
feels reasonably optimistic about those
tie breaks uh which are now
you know assured yeah and vale is fine
but i don't think mvl wins i think it's
a it's a two-way tie break that we are
headed towards yeah i i would be shocked
if i'm even against six minutes and we
kind of glossed over the fact that
uh alireza is keeping the position as
complicated as possible i mean it's not
very complicated but still
he's clearly keeping pieces on the board
and keeping everything in play while
also having four minutes against 13.
but it's a it's a reasonably simplified
endgame you're not really running very
many risks and he is you know the the
that's true
the longer the longer you prolong the
simplifications at some point they're
not going to be there anymore yeah if
you let's say if you if you give black
time here to play knight g5 b6 and a5 a4
which obviously you're not going to no
but but if you make two passing moves
here and black goes knight b6
specifically and then a5 a4 none of your
options are particularly attractive ba
knight takes a4 is kind of horrible but
allowing the knight to come to c4 is
maybe even worse
but obviously that would require alireza
to just pass for two moves which is not
going to happen
he's played 92 and now uh
b5 before i assume is a very comfortable
move to make
black just if black wants to make a draw
here black makes uh makes the draw it
feels to me
uh because
before i mean a phone knight c3
actually maybe a4 is playable here in
knight c3 i think he has to play sorry
did you see the the there's a tactical
problem on the first rank right if i
take your knight takes oops yeah the way
to go for this position would be to play
knight c4 instead of aba b just loses
material that's what i meant yeah
so if you if you want to not play three
a four here you go knight c4 b a knight
takes a3 but you don't win this position
the b3 pawn is weak enough for black to
generate enough count to play against it
also 94 continues being annoying
actually exactly the rook has to go to
some weird but i'm thinking that b4 he
will play a4 but what is this position
let's say knight c3
and then uh that'd be one as well in
let's see for rg5 i was going to say i
will play rook g5 here and i will follow
it up by rook c5 and i will start
pretending i want to sacrifice that
exchange
i'm not sure how believable that
pretence is oh
well maybe rook c5
uh
is it uh well here i think i am very
seriously considering well there's
actually knight takes eight
i need to prepare but i wanted to take
take and play rook e4 take take the way
you put your pieces i i will take take a
player e4 here and if i pick up the pawn
on c4
i am you know that's a great night kind
of curious about whether this is
playable for black or not it looks dead
for a wide because you pick up a4 right
yeah yeah i mean i don't know about that
but it definitely is playable knight b1
is a very serious move though but i
guess we can just go back and say yeah
like how how useful is this
and rookie c1 now i don't think black is
worse and in any variation right yeah
but it doesn't it doesn't really look
like much
in all of these spots you need a lot of
tempe before you can start uh seriously
playing for a win this one i don't like
very much though because rooks
rook c5 is even maybe more of a problem
look take c6 yeah no i like white yeah
so you have to be more precise like if
you play before you need to find a way
i'm i'm drawn like it's it's very very
elaborate but i'm kind of drawn to the
idea of playing b4a for rookie three
b for rook e3 i thought about it but i
didn't see what the point was after
taking on c6 i want to go rook c3
and the question is can you take and
give me this master
i have a feeling it's probably not great
for white and then i think i make a very
comfortable draw because if all else
fails i will just go my knight e3 check
next move and everything gets traded off
i don't know rookie three very very
fancy stuff there peter uh two games
remaining with three in the three games
in the history books all draws by the
way yeah so far it's been a
the first actual quiet round of the
tournament yeah i would
think
say
exhausting the players was pretty
self-evident in that interview with
richie even though uh once again we have
a game which ended in a draw which
should have been won by white and 21s so
it's richard's game um i i shouldn't
oversell just how quiet it was up until
now wesley and levon definitely have a
playoff in front of them they're just
wondering whether or not uh mvl could
join otherwise it will be a two-horse
race for
who will be
the champion absolutely yeah we'll we'll
uh we will continue watching uh
it does seem that uh the the five uh the
game between bogdan and five is also
headed towards some kind of a repetition
and let's jump to bucharest where
christian is with wesley so
thank you yasser we are here with wesley
so one of the players that later on
today will be playing a tiebreak match
for the first position wesley welcome
back to the studio take us through the
game and how did you approach from a
technical point of view today's match
well i had the black pieces linear is uh
very strong i have huge respect for his
chest
also he's extremely well prepared
he's just opening preparation just
insanely deep for for the most part so
i really wanted to give my best today
because
the last 10 days of work all depends on
the last round so i wanna want to give
my all and fortunately i prepared well
but i wasn't sure which line exactly was
going for but as it turns out everything
went well and you guys went into uh this
joko piano were you
concerned because he did play a terrific
game against fabiano caruana in the
american cup in the joko piano why did
yeah were you worried at all or
uh
i mean i was worried but there's nothing
i could do but about it then they just
gotta go and play it others
and if you play before i'm going to play
my best opening which is e5 so i have no
choice but simply to go for it i did see
that game against fabiano the american
cup i mean i think he prefers very well
uh the opening was equal but he prepared
much deeper much deeper now take us
through this game and it's critical
moments yeah first of all the opening
was interesting because normally he
castles
knight at six
and then here c3 black gets a very solid
option of d5 right they played this
first i assume it's the castles he will
either play bishop g5 or he will play
this weird line a4a5 bishop g5 which i
faced in a blitz game recently and i had
some problems
so i'm not exactly sure all this a4
ideas like
it's not clear what the difference is
with the pawns from the a file
so anyway i just played b6 just to
clarify things
because at the very least i delayed
gassing so if you place bishop g5 then
in some cases i can play queen e7 maybe
cast along
so
that's why i play a5 here so that if he
plays bishop g5
my king is not
i mean he can play bishop g5
but linear usually plays this line ht my
team play knight beats but here always
goes h3
there are so many nuances both players
can employ in this joke of piano yeah
it's so funny like
10 years ago no one plays the italian
but now
now the theory resembles sicilian yeah
they're so completely crazy there's so
many insane lines like i think anish
gear made a chesable course on this slow
italian
but even he can cover many lines like
here i played queen b8 actually in the
american cup blitz against sam savion so
i assume linear for that game like win
bait is the main line also the most
solid
and he decided to surprise him with
knight to a d7 yeah ray robson played d7
recently
was he still in his preparation it
seemed like he was yeah he was lifting
it and perhaps
this one
was his first thing at this moment i
kind of assume i kind of thought he
would play g4 here because he played
g4 against me in a similar position in
the same louis rapids and blitz perhaps
he wasn't willing to take uh
too much risk in this game either
i mean if he wins he doesn't die for
first even if he wins then levon with
the white pieces is quite unlikely that
he will be losing so
it's interesting to see what his
perspective was and how much risk was he
willing to take but i assume not as much
yeah i mean it's uh it's interesting to
say i mean i assume linear wants to push
but the same time he's got a very solid
style yeah and he normally doesn't go
all out like other players unless he's
deeply prepared but i just thought he
would play g4 here the computer gives
all zeros but
um it's uh more complex than it does
look like the more destabilizing move uh
for the position so actually my
preparation ended on move 25 oh wow yeah
all the way here wow yeah
yeah
there's a funny line here also 92
six
which if i i just got the show
takes check
and if you block with the piece on c1
then i have knight c5 knight d3 and king
h2 h5
and then this knight is trapped and
somehow black equalizes after rook c2
incredible
yeah so
knight f1 of course but i think rook a4
was a slight mistake
because if he takes on before i was
going to play knight c6 in any case
because the bishop on this is where he
sold 0k4 was in an accuracy now let's
get back to the end of the game because
it does feel like you're getting closer
to an advantage actually then yeah
equality did you feel like that or were
you just ready given the fact that
there's limited options on the board and
limited material to just simply make a
grind i mean i was up an hour
so if chances go my way i was definitely
gonna take it but you didn't feel like
at the end you had any chances yeah i
mean linear thought he was slightly
worse i also thought i was a little bit
better but i wasn't 100 sure because i
have the double e pawns so so you never
know
and uh i thought i played like here i
could play knight literal knight c2
i mean if rook v8 he will take yeah and
then f3 and he's very solid so i thought
knight c6 was logical i didn't expect s3
but maybe s3 is very good i kind of
thought he would play bishop here nice
but actually
yeah something like this and then i have
h5 and black is slightly better
so after it's very solid also here i was
up an hour in a club i was getting
optimistic i thought with the rook on a2
i could never be worse
here i was also surprised by b4 i
thought it would play knight e3
softer b4 i guess through a2 is good the
rook's very active
knight e3 is good
yeah bishop e1 in here in knight b6
bishop and here i started thinking but i
couldn't
find a way to make progress because
esther was very solid all his pawns are
protected for now
and he's starting knight d2
i have
many other moves but
uh at the same time i couldn't see a
clear plan of breaking through i mean i
have two plans i could either bring my
king to the center to d7 if it gets
there maybe i could do something or i
could play maybe bishop sam bishop g5
but i thought with the double d pawns
and no clear way to attack i don't see
the point of risking too much so i gave
a check
i mean if he plays knight d2 then i have
knight a4 turning knight c3
knight c4
vegas even here it's just close to close
to equal
very close to equal yes yes i i mean i i
don't think i played in an inaccuracy
today so absolutely not now at this
point you know that you might be
slightly better but you know that also
the position most likely will end up in
a draw does preserving energy with a
looming tiebreak coming your way uh make
any difference at this point yeah that
actually makes a lot of sense now that
you pointed out but i didn't really
think of that uh
but yeah definitely first of all i don't
have no idea what the time control is in
the time break 15 plus 10 for two games
two games fifteen plus ten and then
armageddon immediately after if we
require oh that'll be interesting uh i
also
i think levon
had a very interesting uh
strategy today like he just played very
solid and didn't mind a quick throw at
all i actually thought he would push
very hard with the white piece yeah
because shaq is out of shape he has
three loss in tournaments struggling a
little bit in this tournament yeah so i
thought
it seems kind of weird that the one we
have with the door i thought he'd push
very hard with white and i mean a few
minutes after if he wins again he
deserves to win it but
i guess uh at this stage as you you can
see in the last game
all the players in one take too much
risk yeah like a lot of dirt has
happened last game so absolutely now
there is still one game left and we
don't want to jump to any conclusions
but it does seem like uh it's getting
closer and closer to a tie break between
you and levon you guys just played a
mini match at the american remind me
i don't want to remind you but with that
yeah
any uh have any weight into this
upcoming match or
you just forgot about it no not really i
mean i i just i just take each each game
as a new thing i mean he also beat me a
lot in the rapid chess on chess.com so
he's been beating me there every single
week
so i definitely would uh wouldn't i
definitely would want to try to get some
revenge definitely some revenge on your
mind wesley thank you very much we'll
let you go and get some rest and get
some preparation going and we'll see you
in a few thank you christian for being
so positive
guys back to you thank you christian
well done wesley as the playoff will
take place 15 minutes after the last
game of the round and things kind of
blew up there in the mvl theater game
yeah you did follow your advice
by going for oops excuse me i went a
little fast by going for the
the fancy play as you would yeah and uh
here is maybe where alireza's somewhat
you know
suboptimal time management may have cost
him a little bit even though i'm not
sure if rugby 2 is as strong as the
engine suggests but it's a very easy
move to miss when you don't have much
time and you have much time to delve
into the intricacies of the position the
point of course being that uh the rocket
is trapped yeah we tried to shoot the
with the rook away from the e3 square we
sidestepped the rook c3 move so that it
doesn't come with the tempo it's now
hanging because there is no fork to the
rook on c2 and as yassar is suggesting
roxy 394 actually wins it somewhat
shockingly to my eyes the engines were
actually suggesting that this might be
best play for black wow and now playing
c5 knight c3 taking with the knight and
following it up almost immediately with
c4 rook c8 rook takes c4
uh generating a lot of activity on the
queen side and a lot of counter play and
you you have to you have to look at the
alternatives to understand why this
would be best play potentially uh yeah
some kind of position like this and the
alternative after rook b2 is to play uh
let's say rook eea
meeting admitting the previous move
wasn't really all that great white goes
let's say knight c4
and you have to play rook a8 pretty much
right and this is not that much fun this
this is exactly the kind of position
that we reckon they're going in the
wrong direction aren't you that we
wanted to get with white yeah i wouldn't
say it's winning no but it clearly is a
very very nice position to uh to play
and you will be defending for the rest
of the game here with black which is why
i think mvl would have been faced with a
very difficult choice because
just straight up giving a full exchange
there for
yes
yes long-term compensation but
uh
yeah when the alternative is this you
you kind of have to ask yourself i mean
he knows this will be unpleasant
but also if you if you play roxy three
and you just lose that then exchange
down position you you end up feeling
somewhat silly about the whole thing
absolutely
and uh again and just in this position
that you did achieve a moment ago uh
peter it's one of those things where we
both have great nights but white's
knight actually happens to be doing a
lot more than blacks yeah it's a lot to
to do with the fact that white managed
to play to a4 and the knight on c3 is
kind of
it sounds pretty it looks something but
it does not very much because there is
nothing to do for for it to pressure
whereas the knight on c4 will constantly
exert a lot of pressure against the
weakness on a flying up a whole rook
that didn't happen much much to mvls i
suspect uh relief uh rook takes whether
or not he saw rook b2 is another point
but rook takes c six and again you were
talking about the time mismanagement
perhaps in ali reza's uh
he took
he didn't have much time to think about
this intrusion of the rook
and the movie to e4 is a bit of a he's
trying to keep everything alive
absolutely yeah and knight c4 is also a
very telling move it's a strong move uh
but
what it also does it is it very much
avoids the potential for black to play
knight e3 check leading to what probably
were drawn rook endings so yeah alireza
is keeping the position as complicated
and as alive as possible he's doing it
on three minutes against half an hour
but
i don't think that's
even remotely two minutes against 20 20
now because mvl after e4 has
taken some time to choose uh there's
yeah there's a number of choices here
for black you can play 97 you can play
rook e8 i think the engine at some point
was suggesting rook e8 might be rookie
an interesting finesse here sidestepping
uh the g-file and just
asking an additional question from uh
from why before you move the knight
anywhere if you move the knight anywhere
uh but black hasn't equalized completely
just yet you get the feeling that it
should be a draw with precise play
but the precise play might still be
required but let's assume uh
rook c7 i think the point here is not
really like eventually maybe we will
take on a5 but for the time being i
think white is aiming to kind of give
mate
knight a4 i want to go e5
i want to go e5 create a very very
strong threat of e6
i might play 96 next move i might just
play so e5 v6 and just get two rooks to
the set like against king g8 i can very
easily imagine just a very simple e5 v6
being quite strong because
if both of those rooks land on the
seventh yes coupled with the knight
joining them by let's say the e5 square
those do end in mates quite often
well the the knight on a4 being way away
not really
participating in the defense either and
this is why mvl is thinking because he's
realized that
he's not going to be asked to defend
some kind of a four against three
uh
he's going to be asked to
secure his king and this is i think
where the rookie eight move comes in it
just
prepares yeah prepares to uh fight
against those plans better i'm not
entirely sure why this is uh so much
better but
it it kind of
makes it less comfortable for white to
go for those the exact plans because
maybe it wants to place the rook on e7
and only after that go after the queen
side right
but yeah this one is a very sharp
position whereas we still have one more
game running but that that one is
sort of continues being a bit of a
uh non-event in in the game between
bogdan and fabi uh bogan continues
searching for
uh for things to do but uh it's very
very difficult to imagine how he will
ever make any progress
and rookie it was played by mvl it's the
move the engines like the most it seems
like the easiest way to solve any kind
of problems because the more i analyze
it e5 e6 what's the problem in pretty
much every variation because e6 is very
accurate right just sidestepping uh the
difficulties
that e5 e6 produces and there's
still some there's still some strange
moves here i mean you could have rook d1
rook d7 for example depending on where
the knight goes
i'm assuming the knight wants to go to
c3 yeah and after all the speeches that
we gave it actually goes rook d7 knight
takes a for here on my screen rook c7
rook no way really yeah roxy's seven
rook of eight which looks very scary to
me like 96 95 even the 5v6 continues
being an issue yeah all of those moves
but the engines are very
heartless yeah they just kind of hold
these positions and say not to worry wow
i would be terrified yeah so would i
yeah
going backwards with the rook getting
passive these pieces like you say
offsides
e5 uh lots of times you just get mated
or the pawn crashes through uh that
would be a very
dangerous line yes it's also dangerous
for white right right yeah really
dangerous when you have ten minutes on
the clock but when you have one minute
on the clock yeah yeah you know this
bottom before sometimes just yeah this
is move 30 yeah and you you do obviously
always have the bailout of taking on a5
and yeah
if you do that you never lose but you
probably minimize your winning chances
quite a bit so yeah alireza is down to
47 seconds here trying to assess whether
he should play
he should play uh sharper or if he
should actually uh accept that
safety is important and take on a5 it is
uh
the players have just reached move 30 so
this time moves to go uh yeah and here's
he's entering increment territory by
this point yeah um
we should yeah we should just watch this
from from this angle because yeah it's
going to be a very exciting very
exciting time trouble
what's your take alejandro rook d one or
knight takes a5 i think he goes wrong
with one he goes right d1 i think he
looks
he goes 96 for the third
third option
knight dsx
i don't i don't like this this looks
artificial this looks so
what is knight this looks like a move
you make on 10 seconds because you don't
like either if you have two main options
and you just decide to
you know play something uh
i think i think he wants rook c5 which
allows an immediate draw and perhaps
black could even consider playing for
more
sort of not really no i mean white
really never risks anything maybe he
wants e4 e5 and then rook c5 takes a5
but it it doesn't look like you're ever
going to be in time with any of this
like rook c3 probably stops all of this
dead in its tracks
alejandro are we going to see a
three-way play-off
three-way play what's more exciting yeah
i'm saying knight d6 feels like a step
in the wrong direction to my mind yeah
it's still under control according to
the engines really yes of course i mean
zero zero everywhere everywhere but you
got kind of get the impression that 96
it's a step on the wrong direction right
right if you're not going to couple this
up with a rook coming to the seventh
rank i wonder my knight eyeing a5
yeah it's uh
you've you've committed to the plan of
uh sort of attacking on the king side
but you've also made the attack on the
king side weaker by blocking off the
g-file
and yeah knight takes a5 no longer an
option because you moved it away from
the attacks on
those spawns as expected rookie sex
sorry to interrupt you there peter yeah
so yeah i think you
you end up starting to look for some
bailouts here maybe rook d1 is what he
wants right the one is fine e5 is fine
rook c5 also okay
e5 rook d1 rook c5 or
that's crazy
yeah i think i think maybe he wanted to
play rook d1 knight of six rook c7 i
come to think of yeah and but after
knight f6 if knight f6 is played he will
come to a very sad realization that rook
c7 is completely impossible
because he gets hit by rook takes e6 and
knight eight correct
which is still a drama no
going to go rook a3 and that's that
and take a4
e6
you're winning i think i'm playing a
fate earlier yeah a five king of faith
maybe you still make a draw but you are
going to be stretched
not on the board yet not the only move
in the position either but uh probably
the most testing because it's like
against against somebody on 30 seconds
i'm thinking i'm playing rook a5 i'm
trying to bail out after knight f6 i
think but 2694 is even smaller i'm sorry
that actually is a draw because even
even though i win the exchange a5 still
falls yeah correct a5 still falls yeah i
think at this point i'm pulling the
parachute and saying okay i'll take the
draw
and the triple zeros
what we're talking about by the way is
that in case of knight f6
we didn't like this ending yeah this
ending peter and i were like uh oh uh oh
but somewhat shockingly the one where we
blunder the evil pawn to go with it is
better for whiteness exactly this is the
one we don't want but the one that we do
want is to blunder the e pawn which was
pretty
pretty fun yeah we go rook c5 with a
very simple idea of taking a pawn maybe
playing e5 and we fall for
rook takes d6
and then we're forked continue continue
blundering the same tactic but yeah here
it actually is just a very very easy
draw for white because the point only
five falls
thankfully yeah how much he's down to
okay it's
not not his move but he did make this
move on nine seconds again
that is to say ali raza did yeah wow
so last last two moves were actually
completed with nine seconds on the clock
which is uh we've seen throughout this
tournament that ali raza has been
getting himself into time trouble is
that a part of his game i mean is he
noted for
being a time trouble addict not
particularly not to my knowledge but
so this is like a
a bad
thing that's just cree crept into his
play maybe because of the strength of
this
event well
i mean he's a bit rusty and uh this is a
very strong event those two things often
combine into you you kind of double and
triple checking things that you when
your place is flowing yeah you you make
the decisions much faster but right now
he hasn't played chess since uh since uh
early earlier this year so
well not over the board chess anyway
again the all-french match-up uh
mvl uh well i'm not going to say
desperate for a win would love to win a
win by mvl would get him into a playoff
for first yeah sleeves rolled up and
very concentrated but yeah yeah well it
still hasn't really left the margins and
once again a reminder of where we stand
with two games to play or one game with
only two sims to only have yeah yeah
we're expecting fabi's game to end in a
draw but this game uh could
could still potentially produce produce
a
third tie breaker yes
which is a very good is going to go
somewhere i'm looking at knight f6 f3
and thinking what exactly is wrong with
f3 i'm not entirely sure i think it's
playable but it's just probably not fast
enough to create any serious issues
um
let's let's look at that because uh
f6
and it does make
sense if you want to say you attacked my
client
restrict the knight on f6 exactly
reestablish perhaps some ideas but you
don't
considering the fact that roxy 7 isn't
the threat maybe we just go to k3 here
and say
do go on sir yeah what is what is the
plan after rook b2 where are you putting
the king h3 i saw i thought yeah i'm not
worried about rookie five or anything
like that i am
worried now that you mentioned it exists
yeah
but i still have g3 g4 there but yeah
i'm not he's got e4 e5 a move which we
did not consider and a move which
apparently borderline loses to knight g4
now
um
what a terrible move what the heck and
instantly
yes 30 seconds i mean that's the only
explanation i have for it but i mean
knight g4 hits the pawn and you can't go
f4 it goes knight e3 yeah
uh rugby
this has gone off the rails a little bit
yeah
he comes late he can't play roxy 795 f4
but uh there is a very clever move there
so it doesn't quite work out we need to
show that yeah rook c7
and f4 which is ugly as it is right it's
not
the first thing you want to do but it
actually doesn't work because you play
rook d3 in this position yeah there's
nothing better but yeah it also knows he
has played rook c7 by the way yeah five
seconds uh on the clock when he's done
that yeah knight takes e5 will follow
and after a four mbl we'll consider
because there are other options which
also look kind of interesting but yeah
but rook d3 uh definitely leads to
positions which are uh potentially very
bad for white because the before the
before passer is going to
become the major
the major player in this position yeah
you can take my king said i don't care
yeah
and and the entire king side is actually
likely to disappear there but it's just
probably not going to matter because the
b-pawn might just cost white the the
game guys i'm stunned because this is
just uh a suicidal uh play and f4 play
because what else what else do you do
what else do you do what else do you do
otherwise you just you were talking a
moment ago about some exchange sacrifice
and like this is like one of the best
exchange sacrifices
and you haven't even exactly exchanged
yet i mean you've got a
protected pass but yeah
and i think you do find three because i
think you want to limit the material you
want to trade away the rook on d1 which
uh later would be uh protecting white
against you know some of the problems
with the b-pawn and i i don't i cannot
afford to take and take so i have to go
for this ending where yeah now night of
seven i was yeah rook f7 king g8 rook g7
looks kind of horrible i'm just on the
on the edge of the precipice first of
all e3 but also i'm wondering if it's
useful to include knight c5 and force
your rook away from the seventh just
play knight c5 and then so
jack and maybe i could not see four
holes here i'm struggling maybe i can
make a draw this way peter yeah ah
but okay
of course very very sensible the
the once again the time the the clock
times for
mvl he's got all the time in the world
yeah he needs to assess uh assess this
correctly but i think just intuitively
you want to play you won the rook on d1
because i was wondering why knight g3 is
not stronger than rook d3 and it has to
be an attractive proposition in general
but after knight takes f7 white actually
gets a lot of counterplay against the
black king side
but there is also a vikings yeah right
yeah absolutely and this is this is why
you would be interested with white it's
because like rookie to check
yeah it looks like a very very serious
move but i suspect you can play qf3 here
which is just so annoying
stepping into stepping into the whole
thing but really
is hanging but even knight f4 is winning
though
even knight f4 has to be winning
probably yeah maybe it's actually sadly
something like king jiwan i wanted to go
forward but hang on let the [ __ ] g4
h5
yeah but just here in this moment i do
also have rook b2 checked all right king
h3
and can't i set up those wonderful and
knight xf7 and
thematic checkmates that we've all been
taught
but i think why they're sort of
beginning first here right because
rookies took g4 you don't have a
particularly good follow-up i think you
might be lost there with black which
would be really really unfortunate
because of how many threats you have and
if you have to play king of six white
has an all-important tempo to do
something
at the very least i can play knight g5
and make a draw i assume right
uh
i'm still coming to grips with
this incredible turn around
if i want to be a yeah i want to be
ambitious i can play knight g8 here and
create an idea of seven mate
yeah which might be trickier to me than
yeah and uh meets the eye that's exactly
right so
yeah i think the more you calculate
variations like this the more you
realize this rook on d1
needs to be off the board
kind of needs to be off the board you've
got to go huh just a second again i'm
just
apologies that i i just because
this king is
you know you want to play g5 rook h6 uh
my mind is screaming that there's got to
be some way of uh
uh really uh i mean if if the h7 was
already on h5 this would become
completely lost of course but the fact
that
the fact that i have the g4 square
available to me i think makes a very
very large difference here wow
i don't think you do that i think knight
g3 actually scares me rupee to check
doesn't really scare me very much 93 on
the previous move
that one i was i was really wondering
why the engine doesn't like i thought
rook d3 is strong but 93 will be
just as strong
and the move we are completely ignoring
by the way is uh the second option of
the engine right now is the move 95 g4
uh which requires basically
study-like responses from white after
all this king is still in a kind of a
tactical
landmine
yeah and apparently you can go knight to
xf7 here
how easy how easy is that to assess
in particular on 34 seconds wow knight
takes f7 here that's just that's really
throwing down the conway right yeah i
mean you play knight f7 because every
other move i think you resign wow pretty
much yeah but you have to really trust
yourself here because it looks like if
something goes wrong you do get mated
but our counter play on the king side
here is very very serious very serious
yeah and uh
if mvl width it's a three player round
robin of i believe 15 plus 10 or just
the ten plus five plus five ten plus
five plus five and
that'll be
and if it's still tied we just go to
armageddon that actually doesn't make
much sense but
we will figure that out when we get
there i guess yeah well the nice part is
that we've been telling the playoff
rules in case of two player or three
player tie thank goodness there was
never an opportunity for a four player
that was an opportunity today but it
wasn't going to happen yeah but he's we
didn't have the rules uh he played the
move rook d3 z3 yeah
the question is
is
that a winning move or is that just
engine suggests it is winning pretty
much pretty much winning yeah wow i'm
actually surprised that they don't give
a bigger advantage okay rook takes d3
although and we've got to take on f7
yeah and actually rook f7 rook d7 i
think is a better chance it's a much
better chance rigorous iron these recap
7 is a much better chance of knight f7
another 7 specifically king f8 knight g5
and a very precise move rook b6 which
shows but right besides them pawns
behind yeah
works behind white white is never in
time to set up any of those perpetual
types of
ideas with knight h7 knight f6 and the
b-bone just basically wins i think so
you have to take with the rook you have
to play rook d7 you have to hope that
this is
not as bad but it's uh it's pretty bad
i'm seeing a kind of a hand movement and
yes you're like
oh dear what have i done i've been an
idiot uh from perugia and how much time
four three three
two
wow
wow 32 seconds yeah and uh wow
two seconds for that game for that move
and all right king jade comes quickly
because during those two seconds mvl's
heart was beating yeah and you can see
paused g8 rook h7 rook d7 quickly sorry
yeah back to a minute yeah i just wanted
to say that yeah some of those moves
which were made on like two seconds were
you know he was back to his clock
banging best but
uh now that he's come down and chose
what to take on f7 with rook d7 was
already played in a very very artistic
manner with like a one finger push on
the button
ah
yeah and the pawn does need to go
immediately it's much stronger than
knight c5 just going b3 here and
starting to
starting to push
no question about it pass pawns push
them baby
yeah
and
you get the feeling that it will
actually cost white a piece
but you will get a number of pawns for
it potentially including the a5 pawn and
then it's not that easy to win
uh but he also he still needs to make
two more moves here they will not be
you can do a quick check check
yeah you can include but that actually
brings the king closer like i don't know
if where do you put your kingdom do you
seven f8 i think
okay but that actually also makes sense
for white right it's because h7 will be
hanging yes so you not only get to move
forward this way you'll probably
actually improve your position by
forcing the king away from g8 towards f8
and as you say at some moment you
probably reckon on having to give up a
piece
for that uh passer
you know
but first of all emblee has to play v3
wow
knight c5 throws away
much of his age
yeah but b3 is very logical here i think
i think it's very understandable that
you don't want to spend any tempo on any
extraneous things yeah sometimes the
attempt to play for a win
overwhelms your
sensibilities here and i think that uh
uh farouja
really really went way overboard in this
attempt and
well now it's it's clear that only
um
black
is playing for the win in the other game
got to h4
somehow
i'm kind of shocked i'm kind of shocked
i didn't think it would happen in this
game the evaluation doesn't change but
the pawn did get to h4 somehow yeah
but everything's stuck
everything is starting yeah everything
is stuck and king c5 king before will
start
becoming a topic of conversation so yeah
no fabi is still completely fine it's
not yeah it's not as if anything changed
significantly yeah rook c8 played by le
reza king g7 only legal move in the
position
is going to
be made on the board yeah i guess you go
you give a check from d7 here uh because
you do want your half an hour it's a
complicated end game and uh you
you know you probably recognize here
with white that you can't afford any
more mistakes
exactly so so getting the half an hour
and thinking in a more relaxed setting
than rather than 31 seconds is
a sensible choice here and the problem
for white is that if you go 98 check
here rook takes e8 uh
kind of wins on on the spot
because after rookie beats b8 before the
pawn actually costs you a full
uh we don't even get to uh sack the rook
for the 40 made on three seconds but it
wasn't a difficult move
and here we are
wow um
for mvl this is just like a dream come
true absolutely as he's made
as
he uh
with his next move will have made the
time control
and you can see that he's really
he's like
completely focused uh we we we spoke
about the very solid play of levon and
versus the very risky play of wesley and
their type of first if we start talking
about mvl as being uh
potentially where did he come from uh
peter
well i think he had a kind of a
willing co-conspirator today because uh
alireza had a number of options during
the game
to make it into a much drier much uh
safer position to yes to limit the risk
to uh to
just be
almost entirely safe or just entirely
safe but he wanted to as full blood of
the game as possible and this is what we
got
but envia was never really in the mix
alejandro until the last like three
rounds i mean like we hadn't been
talking about
uh maxine's uh results especially when
he fell apart against levon right we had
that game that he had widened the vienna
against lavon neroni and just completely
got destroyed but he's bounced back here
in the second half especially a victory
here against alaresa with the black
pieces puts him in a position tied for
first didn't see him coming but we did
say at the beginning of the of the round
if somebody has an outside chance to
join the leaders that is going to be
maxine we know that already likes fights
we know that a a player that would have
given up on the tournament would have
played some way to just kill the end
game into a rook
r draw earlier he had a lot of reza had
the chance others had many chances to
kill that game and just say let's go
into a draw and don't worry about it but
he's a fighter and sometimes those
fights cost you and this in this case
mvl is the one that's very close to
getting that full point joining wesley
and levon on five and a half points and
that way we would have a three-way tie
for first and a round robin ten plus
five tournament coming up wow so some
hundred thousand dollars for the first
place sixty-five thousand uh you gotta
throw in i think was it forty-eight was
what 48 for third but
then is the money shared i think well
that was my question it's a pool of
money
and then is it broken
by first second and third or is it
there's a number of ways to deal with
the of dealing with this and organizers
choose
whichever way they prefer there is the
the hoard system yes
now the the most arcane of all the
systems i think is what is called the
horse system where basically
uh the money is pulled and then half the
money it's it's split down the middle
and half the money is allocated
according to equally and then the other
yeah and the other the other hard uh
half is actually like the playoff is
being played and the other half is
redistributed
according to the percentages of of the
first second and third prize so you get
a kind of a
slightly balanced approach
so
coming back to the position on the board
in the mvl game i i briefly looked at
some lines because
uh knight c4 seems logical trying to
absolutely control the b3b2 idea and i
was
kind of shocked to see that the engines
really like going knight c5 here and
i i just wanted to see like i thought am
i blundering something is b2 not winning
a piece
and instead of knight c5 of course
and to my kind of horror
uh
b7 rook between b7 we win a piece in
like four different ways here
but
i understand it's a it's a sort of an
on-boarded engine which perhaps isn't as
deep as
uh as uh as all that but some kind of a
position specifically
this is actually slightly more
understandable but if we look at the
position after rook c6
uh after rugby seven we can play rook c6
here exactly and the difference is we
will be giving a check from c2 not e2
allowing us to take on pizza with the
knight
uh so we go knight takes b2 roxy to
check king of three we go knight takes
bit so
and the machine here goes rook h7 knight
a4 okay seven
rock h7 knight a4 rook a6 yeah and
instead of resigning it says 0.9
which is basically a draw for an end
game right
which is just stunning to me the a5 pawn
is alive i will play roxy five here it's
alive it's about to start running you
will go knight c3 you will go a4 you
will move your rook so i'm wondering if
if this is a sort of a function of the
depth not being no no i don't think so i
think this is probably closer to a draw
yeah but
it's it's a little bit interesting no
it's shocking one one
one pawn for the piece here
and i guess it just goes like g4 or h4 i
don't know f5 gff
g5 and then i don't know
some kind of counter play on the king
side but like this is just so
non-obvious to me that this is not
completely winning for black right
it definitely looks horrible yeah i
guess i actually do go like a 5g fg5
here
and start pushing i don't know
this is a dangerous bond
i
[Laughter]
yes you're right
you have a that would be that would be
my counterpoint like wow i think i've
resigned in better positions than this
so that's remarkable but we know that
that's what ali reza is hoping that he's
going to be able to sacrifice his knight
for the past b pawn
that he'll reduce the pawn structure as
much as he can to try to scramble a draw
out of this uh position but it it is a
bit of a surprise you you were
mentioning that there are three or four
ways i mean
why did you want to keep the rooks why
did you want to no i wanted to attack on
the pawn only for as quickly as possible
if you play with that knight
or sorry
uh yeah if you do it your way you go
rookie one night takes pizza yeah
you go rookie to check i assume right
i'm talking of three yes player takes b2
i take on h7 you haven't picked up the
pawn on a4 yet so i have to spend tempe
attacking it giving me more time to do
like i don't know clicking g [ __ ] g5
for instance right and there i could see
why there's a lot of counter play but
the line i gave with the rook on c5
controlling the white king not allowing
the white king to become activated and
also we're winning the pawn on e4
straight away by taking on b2 with the
knight and then taking on a4 this one i
thought has to be lost but apparently
not apparently i mean maybe it's lost
long term but the evaluation like you
you you learn to gauge
uh sort of what various machine
evaluations mean in various positions
right and when you're when you have a
piece for a pawn in an end game and the
evaluation isn't minus two
that's shocking or not even minus one
perhaps it does imply that this is
probably holdable with precise play yeah
to my eyes i don't quite understand why
that is but
you learn to trust those things
good point oh boy
alejandro jump right in you're not
you're kind of confused as well
not in a jumping mode yeah yeah
uh well no i'm looking at the variations
as well knights before you play out on
necessity everything else just loses uh
immediately so you go night knight c4
and the end just they say all right go
b2
and yeah there's so many different ways
to win this night they think there's a
particular way they like more than
another check here check it actually
likes dragging the king to the queen
side and after king e3 we go another way
where you can win the piece knight
before this is another mechanism to win
this position uh sorry the knight the
king on e3 is a little bit further away
than on the king side and it allows
certain checks in variations this is
very specific this is very computer-like
chess now of course i'm promoting uh
because the knight is now blocking the
rook so knight takes b2 is kind of
forced rook takes rook takes h7 and now
he can go rook a2 and win this pawn and
because there are some knight checks and
because the king can't really join that
fast it doesn't say black is clearly
winning
it does still think f5 is a possibility
that even bringing the king to d4 and
trying to catch the pawn that way is a
possibility for white so tons of ideas
tons of counter plays and it's not clear
at all that white actually is losing in
this position it just says minus 1.5
which to me means absolutely nothing we
already know this is a two racehold game
it doesn't really tell us if black is
winning or if white is still has this
within a drawing range knight c4 clearly
is going to be played it's clearly the
only move another rest that will fight
and they'll just kind of stumble into
some ending game in which i don't
guarantee mvl is going to win
yeah
wow uh
remarkable i mean everything to play for
playoff certainly on the horizon will it
be a two player will it be a three
player stay tuned uh the other side of
this break as
we will answer all your questions
they will they will we'll just watch
this they will okay
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sink field
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the us and world chess halls
of fame
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
welcome to our show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys gotta see this
that's our show now go start yourself
this is model.com
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
solid pressure
uh welcome back to round nine of the
super bad chess classic in romania with
a couple of games still going and one of
them incredibly important
uh in regards to our final standings
with maximo shirograph actually
with very very serious winning chances
on the black side
uh against arizona and there's also the
game between bogdan dayek and fabiano
carona going on but that one is a lot
quieter and has much less bearing on the
final outcomes of the event
and when we left it just on our break we
just thought that knight c5 was
absolutely boxed there was no choice
about it and that after b2
our
b7 was yet expected yeah but
we were gonna we were gonna sacrifice a
piece peter later
but the question is did
alireza make the right decision by
sacrificing the piece right away
something that we rather
dismissed i think in some human ways you
understand it because you don't need a
plaque a past spawn right you eliminate
that's actually not true i can i can if
i won't play knight c4 here
okay but then but then you have to take
a2 the roundabout way right yeah i go
looking to check okay two rook takes a
four it's a honestly it's a very serious
choice here but uh at that time i am but
but you i do give you a chance to to to
get some serious counter utilize one of
those important avenues towards
counterplay that we were discussing
earlier
just to
showcase to everybody our discussion
uh something along these lines i will
get my
my rook behind the plan which is very
nice and g5 i go look before here and i
think i don't actually lose the pawn on
b6 necessarily because i think you can't
take i think if you take and allow me to
play rugby six check and rook a6
i could lose this one probably is losing
but 2k7 probably yeah that's very hard
for you to
trundle up the board absolutely yeah
this is very serious contemplate but
yeah the big sort of systemic question
here in the current position is i black
obviously can take on a4 yeah why it
absolutely telegraphed that they will
take on e5
h7 pawn is now completely safe and we
get this we get this strange end game
yeah first of all if i i thought it's
necessarily two against one
apologies
but it's not because there is rookie to
check so i don't know which square to
choose let's say c3
knight c3 fair if you play a five which
i've heard you definitely want to do i'm
not sure i think he is also not sure
he's losing three against two but if you
play a five i want to go rookie to check
okay
seemingly you have to play king h3 and i
want to play g6 g5
and
you can avoid uh well depends on how
strong king g4 is but right i'm just
trying to trade off a pair of pawns is
essentially all right let's go knight e4
here okay that case i have king f3
that's one
that's legit though because i i'll still
get my
my pawn trades one right will you
on which so when we square a little bit
like h4 ghgh i'm winning very good oh no
that's comfortable because the knight
gets to f6 so you start getting checks
right
so checking h
yeah um
yeah you have to decide yeah it's a
it's weird all of these are extremely
extremely small margins right the oh
yeah everything is is move on move no
question about it does feel like i
cannot really avoid trading h7 for a
five and whether this is a draw or not i
really don't have a clue the other thing
you were about to say though peter was
that do you have to play f5 you're
you're about to suggest that the three
versus two even three versus two is not
like just by playing same way
just say go ahead kill me uh
and uh
you you get the feeling this probably is
winning but
it definitely requires precision
technique because yeah let me sidestep
f5 i don't know exactly how i should be
sidestepping f5 maybe rook d d6 to bring
my if i can get my knight to f6 i'm
feeling
much much better about my winning
chances absolutely uh i think what i
want to say is i'm probably i have some
some weird memories of
not really playing but like discussing
and analyzing is a strong word i don't
really analyze any games very much
if this knight on c3 was actually a
bishop
this one is
tricky
and maybe not even
strictly speaking winning for black
three against two with a specifically a
dark square bishop
and the pawns on
the pawns as they are on the h2 g3 and
f4 wow but i guess the night actually in
this engine probably is just a much
stronger piece than the bishop because
you can create all kinds of like no
matter what pawn structure why chooses
you can actually with the knight attack
the base of the chain
uh provoking weaknesses provoking some
kind of pawn advances which create
further weaknesses and eventually you do
lose by the way we do have uh the trade
as nvl deciding where to put the knight
i got a question for the grand masters
if you play knight b2 here instead of uh
knight c3
uh drive knight g4 yeah f5 knight c4
there's a tactical sequence that begins
like this the knight goes to c4 it
attacks the rook on a5
f5 f5 yeah
so you cannot take on e6 that trade it
just loses 93 check picks up the pawn so
you kind of have to go to k8 and take on
e8 yeah and take on e8 and then take on
g6 and how would you evaluate
i think very much depends on how active
the king gets straight away i think
like my default setting here that is
this is winning for black but i also
am fully expecting it to be somewhat
study-like
i'm not expecting this to be easy i'm
not expecting this to be easy but i'm
expecting this to be enough somehow yeah
oh i would think does the engine say
zero zero zero or because we're very
we're nearing to yeah king of three only
move drawing but it actually is a draw
of the king of three wow
that means that what i what i said in
the very early is that it's very
tempting very tempi oriented like if
king of three is the only move that
makes a draw here it means that you
can't you can't chill you you do have to
create immediate counter play but it
might be enough yeah you just get there
and let's say after king of seven i
suspect there will once again be the one
move no here actually everything draws
now
h3 is a draw wow instead of king of four
and there goes that speech
yeah the whole speech the whole species
so this is this is just a draw
wow i would have guessed it at least i'm
slightly heartened by the fact that
yasser is also wowing next to me because
i i would have thought that it would
have been somehow rather easy to uh
wrong step
y okay now we're back to being only two
moves being a draw here like passing
here no longer no longer makes a draw
but g4 does make a draw i was running a
g4 g6
and uh this is kind of what i was hoping
to be able to do even g5 is a draw
shockingly because you're in time to
play
yeah it has to be g5 right what else
also dropper
shockingly yeah knocking e4 and knocking
e4
we're
every time i go to g4 you have to give
me a check
yeah you can't allow h5 so and your
night's not getting i mean if your
knight gets to h5 you win we understand
that but it's just not getting there
wow if my knight were on h5 it'd be a
win and to get there i need to go
through g7 which means you just need to
go to e8 you're never in time to to to
organize all of that because the king
gets to g4 faster than all of those
things yeah you're one time for short
right now
what's going on four holding f4 king of
f4 and i make a pass
please go king g yes
and i go check actually even with light
on g7 it's apparently still a troll no
king of four you can't go knight of
course you can't go another fight with
h5 right oh yeah yeah that's clever yeah
yeah okay it doesn't actually get to
just design finely that would have been
a bit mind-blowing if it wasn't true
yeah yeah okay this one is this one is
this one is clean zero oh good good good
good good i've
sometimes i question my my chest
knowledge i mean this one i would have
thought was a a win
but okay so this happened from your
night because he might be six instead
i wonder if he still wants to go five
nights at five knight c4 is certainly on
we're expecting alireza to play a five
because yeah three three versus two you
do feel like you're probably in a lot of
trouble like you don't really
i don't feel that's crazy can i
can i uh
pretend like i've got all the time in
the world that would be that would be
another idea that is very very critical
because if we get the trade h24 h7 i'm
happy yeah you you instantly feel a lot
safer about making a draw and h5
currently runs into f5 very very clearly
but the xc4 just looks so strong here
um
rook c5 or c5 but then i get a super
blockade right knight e3 and h5 oh yeah
i'm not in time yeah so this is a g7
check right correct
check king g7 check i know i think i go
king f7 right you're not king
f7
yeah so that and then i go rookie seven
next move if you if you continue yes i
was trying to get my pawn to h5 and they
should be at this point if three versus
two is
done
yeah i was wondering no i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna play that one out we do
have knight b6 on the board pardon me
knight b6 on the board we are expecting
f5 and it's it's kind of curious because
yeah we are expecting a five and if if
mvl goes knight c4 we now know this
actually forces a draw yeah it's a
mistake which leads to a forest draw but
how easy would it be for alireza to
actually just swap the rooks off and say
i i trust in my suspicion that this is
this is a draw because i don't think
anybody really knows this with a knight
in g versus g h i suspect very very few
end game books actually feature it due
to its rarity and similar you know
seeming you know irrelevant and i i saw
it i got it once in a game and so i went
to the informant then games the big
books that they used to have
i saw it somewhere i know that it's a
draw this is why i was asking because i
had seen it before but it was so many
years ago
that i don't remember why or when or
which specific scenarios but i do know
that in some variations yeah yeah two
versus one is just a draw
wow still obviously very much depends on
what things are because if white doesn't
get to
you know doesn't get extended enough
yeah generally i was
neutral kings
and the pawns not being blockaded or any
type of blockade and
it was cool just hold you just hold just
hold it okay
that's actually very useful yeah i
wasn't aware at all teen years old and
he's supposed to have all of this wealth
of
experience i think knowledge about these
esoteric no 12 minutes you kind of hope
for the best i think he will be over
right now
he'll be operating on punches yeah he's
operating on hunches here but his
hunches are very good like he is we've
we've talked about this before he is one
of those people whose
natural understanding of you know how
things are in the chess board is
extremely extremely solid
uh so yeah i wouldn't be like he sees
knight c4 he knows that f5 will have but
you've a bit you you're dreaming to take
all the pawns off the board once the
pawns come off the board rook and knight
versus rook easy draw
okay uh next question then with the
rooks on a five gf
rook takes no easy draw easy draw you
think is it wrong okay i don't think you
can make progress i'm gonna go with draw
but
i think it's an easy job because i think
that if you trade rooks with the h-bond
it's trivial
on h7 yeah
i was actually going to say i was
actually i
said i was like that is not obvious
hold on ali
there's a second takes takes uh we we're
going to construct something yeah that's
right g5 checkered g6 takes takes
you know we're the king of things yeah
yeah
don't trick me yeah yeah and we're gonna
give you you're gonna give me all this
yeah we're gonna give you all of this
and you think this is trivial this is
this is just lost it's just lost yeah
this is just dead lost incredible it's
too far away you can't challenge it
quickly enough yeah not enough yeah you
know no it needs to be it needs to be
within reach for your bonds to start
yeah what we know for sure peter is that
we have a playoff we just don't know if
it's two or three yeah absolutely but
what we really want to know is what
about the money peter i mean yeah
the graphic is coming up but it's it's a
bit tricky but uh
i
i actually quite like the solution in
terms of in terms of what they do with
the money in in tied
uh in thai tournaments i think it's
reasonably fair
um
it goes
uh
yeah but
okay so here we are yeah uh in case in
case of the three-way play-off
uh the spread will be uh yeah this is
this is the uh the players who will be
contesting it
uh and the money is
basically uh they separate an additional
10k for the winner of the tournament and
the rest gets split uh down the middle
okay which i think is a very solid way
of doing things the winner has to get
something like i think i think it's fair
that the winner gets an additional a
little play-off yeah but splitting most
of it down the middle like i very much
understand as opposed to the horde
system of 50-50
okay and in case of three players died
we i assume will uh you know
see similar numbers it will be obviously
right yeah no you reserve 10k winner
gets done yes but but the the the number
that is being split will be obviously
lower because you
uh
you introduced the third the third price
which is 48 grand
into the equation here i remember i was
once playing
in the very high
stakes new york open that was
in in the day the new york open had been
one of the most
well-paid
events i think it had maybe 20 000 first
15 and so on and so on and it was one of
those things where
you know like there were six
no pardon me there was 12 players tight
for first going into the last wrong game
i was one of them i have won my game
rather quickly in fact
so i was in the
dug house you know
making my map on the on the price fund
and every single player who could tie
with me i'm just dreaming of a draw
right someone all of them
yeah
i mean i went i went from like 20 000
to 18 to 40.
but it was actually a like an even split
right there yes yeah yeah yeah it
eventually comes down to like fifty
three hundred and thirty three dollars i
once died for a second in the new york
open which i think was won by pablo
blockney an eight out of nine that was a
kind of a big score yeah huge freak
result because it's so it's a lot of
points for new york those were very very
strong opens exactly it was 95 yeah and
i i got my
i think seven and a half maybe even i
was seven out of nine and there was a
huge pile up on seven out of nine and
bible just crashed yeah it was all he
got probably the best result of his of
his career yeah just destroyed
okay this uh what's on my analysis board
is not on the game
we should actually pay some attention to
the other game because it's uh some
things happen there which what
yeah which are
difficult
difficult to understand at first glance
uh okay we left it more or less around
these
bishop v8 is a very clever move here
stopping king before because the pawn on
six is uh vulnerable 5d ended up
taking on a4 somewhat breaking up the
pawn chain king d5 king d3
uh c5 bishop b5
king five king three and here after a
very very prolonged thought he went with
c4 check and i think i now understand
what's happening okay he won c4 bishop
c4 check on c5 and bishop two okay he
found a very clean weight so
for a second there i wasn't sure why
we're giving up one of our two remaining
pawns but bishop too
does make a very comfortable draw now i
guess yeah the pawn h2 h4 is about to
fall and you can't really attack the
pawn on a5 quickly enough it's time for
the professional knight f3 yeah well
bogdan is not going to play knight f3
though i think he is
professional
yeah he's going to go knight f7 check
and continue but yeah you're
at this point you're probably not
winning this game ever ever okay not
that you were let's get back to our
playoff game and whoa
yeah uh remarkable restraint a
remarkable restraint by ali reza not to
play the move f5 which i mean
every fiber of your being is like let's
get these pawns off the board yeah
could it be peter that he was also
no i think he decided that that game was
lost
i think he decided knight c4 wins that
knight c4 i think it's very likely that
he saw knight c4 and he just couldn't
bring himself to he analyzed something
that went along these lines
down this road and said come on
two versus one come on actually hang on
a second h6 winning
get out of here what
h6 winning here
says my screen get out
only move only move to win
h6 h6 you know i have this thing going
on in my head right now that ali rija
comes to studio and says yeah i almost
played this and then i spotted this age
seven
six and i didn't like my chances of
holding and so i had to go with g4 yeah
that would be remarkable oh my god
h6 wins yeah yeah wow things that are
not going to happen
for 500. yeah i mean c4 instead
yeah wow this feels like this
should be convertible right
well let's you'll start by giving
obviously yeah or give a couple of
checks there's also something that you i
don't know if i want to bring i want my
bring my knight into it okay seven i
guess is the point okay well we got
rookie seven well let's trade rooks
there yeah rook is seven that would suit
me
i mean this doesn't really feel like it
holds
g4 this doesn't really feel like it
holds at all i think you provoke some
weaknesses and then you you get to them
and you win
okay if i don't give checks where is the
night going exactly um i thought uh
d2
d2 yeah i want to go rookie through
check and then like another six or
something yeah
d2 i don't think i don't think we hold
this with white i feel feels very very
unlikely feels bad huh yeah
i won't argue with you there peter at
all i i that knight's
i mean e4 just seems
yeah yeah you still fail to win this
occasionally because it's it's still
it's still tricky there is still the
plan of h4h5 to consider if white you
know isn't time to play
h4h5hghg somewhere by the way with
apologies to our audience it's just that
we all had to wake up very very early
here in saint louis and so coming to
grips with the fact that like in
particular of gh6h4 like how is this
loss
i mean i just find
this
remarkable that this is
losing because to the move
to the move h7 h6 and we do have by the
way knight d7 on the board uh peter
i don't know about you but i i just feel
tasered after this uh h7h6 yeah i just
have no idea how to do it
to be honest yeah yeah
the words words fail
g4 knight d7 and this conversion just
feels so much easier this this feels
like a
warm bath compared to what we just
experienced there with uh with f5
so uh
we're
at this moment predicting a three-way
play-off everybody does seem like it
yeah
again uh in that playoffs it will be a
round robin
between the the three players will play
uh
against one another and the two so
that's three rounds yeah because
obviously one one player sits out every
round yeah and the two top finishers
from the round robin will then go on to
play a match or
if i just win the round rob and i'm the
winner
yeah if i win two games that's it we're
done yeah
it's actually unclear what happens like
if if two people die for first that's
the round robin that's clear we go to
armageddon okay okay two people thai for
first yeah we go to armageddon
if three people tie for first
then we don't know
[Laughter]
okay very nice okay
i i'm glad i didn't
i didn't get the excel spreadsheet yeah
what's this i remember john donaldson
doing that at an olympiad uh calculating
and he did it perfectly he knew exactly
that the u.s had won the gold medal yeah
but he did it with a notepad
not like the app notepad on your iphone
looking at the relevant games writing
down how they were doing exactly yeah he
calculated perfectly knew that u.s got
gold medal over ukraine i think yes i
think 2016. yeah but it was a very
hidden result yeah and i remember very
vividly this uh image of
eliana eli enough elianov uh winning
and then being you know like rapturous
uh
hugs from his teammates as they
celebrated their gold medal victory
[Laughter]
but okay they had a phenomenal result
and
it was quite the tie knight d7
kg3 3 check being played i don't know
why we're forcing the king to h4 there
must be some kind of a concrete reason
why this is good because
generally by this point i am all very
interested if i'm trying to hold this
with white yeah so since we have only
this game i'm gonna i'm gonna pass this
white i'm just gonna keep passing until
you make a threat i wanna know
how you win so let's just put the king
i'm going to put it on g2 just
just to be just yes
okay
knight f6 yeah
everything you attack i defend right you
go i go h3 or something
and i will put my knight towards
yeah you have to start giving checks at
some point because if you allow 95 on
the post i think your position starts
crumbling a lot faster than you suspect
all right i go
rook a4 or something look at 495 yeah
okay
oops sorry that was
that was a
a mouth slip king now we got king of
seven kings
i got king edge too
just to get out of any
well in this case actually somewhere
around here i want to play h4 yeah
you you you can't play king h2 i know
what you mean you just want to make a
pass and somehow get out of dodge yeah
that's the yeah that's a much better
pass rook a4 yeah i understand yeah and
then
i want to include h5 somewhere i
well then you want to do it with the
knight on f6 yeah i think so yeah
actually let's not play that put the
knight on f6 and then okay he's going to
just make passes yeah passes just lose
to h5 i think rook a7 check is what
annoys me just try it
then i'll get in the rook check okay if
you want this
and you want this that's okay and then i
put the rook on some yeah like a3 h5
king of three
okay
we're helping you out
it's a team effort
we're trying to get to the truth as well
we we we're not sure
uh now let's say we get to this position
it's not an unreasonable position no by
the way we do have in the game but he's
going
h4
it's so hard to defend these positions
passively i mean you want
to go ahead so let me just refresh the
board
yeah the other one is going to be over
in a second there and
we finally
did you just hit us with a commentator's
curse and say no he did play night upset
he didn't do the professional thing
okay much to learn much to learn
all right and that's a draw between
bogdan diak and fabi if i cannot be
happy with this tournament kind of a
lackluster fifty percent my the one and
the one game he won
i mean
i met played knight a6 and somehow
almost got back almost drew they almost
drew the game so definitely not
a memorable tournament here for favi an
improvement from last year but that's
pretty much all you can say about it but
meanwhile for the local hero
50 against this field that's absolute
that's
that was impressive
good yeah very very good he also played
fighting chess he uh
he hasn't tried like playing
solidly for a draw in with white he who
continued trying to ask questions yeah
very very uh creditable performance by
bogdan
and
now uh
once again uh
the one remaining game is the game
that's going to decide if we have a
three-way or a two-way play-off and the
king went to h4
and i don't like this i think that he's
uh
unfortunately put his king in a in a
pocket of
trouble i'll leave it at that but uh
what is yeah what is the way to explore
let's say i just got king g7 yeah that's
what i was coming to uh as well king j7
k7 rook g3 is a starting point exactly
and then yeah i i'm not quite sure well
let's say i go rook c7 rook a7 for the
foreseeable and i ask you the same
question alejandro was asking no i mean
obviously
if you pick out i give you a check on
the sixth
peak out okay uh
do i want the pawn on h6 or not no okay
that's fine i i i peak
you check i return yeah roxy 7
rook c7 i peak
yeah somewhere around here i need to
start considering king g5 but maybe it's
a bit too early let's go rook a7
just chill
after sex are going forward
i think i think we wanted to go to king
tv
but then we got king g5 actually yeah no
no that would be a tempo against the
rook king d5 hits the rook i understand
i go to rook e6 or somewhere and uh
sorry what are we talking about
and 94 king g5
and just
pretend we have counter play
wow
not such a ridiculous pretense
rook h3 i want to play
rookie six check rookie seven i think to
begin with and then i start pushing the
f pawn right
sorry i'm gonna just repeat my position
here
uh get to the current position
okay he did uh
again he put his king on h4 removed that
well
done i didn't like that move
at all
but
knight f6
yeah i guess you give a couple of checks
you force rookie seven so that your king
on each waitlist has some squares and
you drop the rook back somewhere i'm
thinking rook check king of seven rook
czech rook e7 i think so king six
doesn't seem to achieve very much and
now we go rook i don't know a6 or if two
or okay with square uh okay
now i was reluctant to play h6 in
previous lines
maybe i just
do it
h6
i'm not afraid of g5 i think that's
helpful to me
probably even though like in this
specific constellation of pieces i am
curious about g5
g5 and king takes and king takes
i'm curious about this because 90
[ __ ] h6 and uh you know if i lose i
now lose some kind of you know there's
going to be some weird tactical solution
because the g6 pawn is very weak
you have knight h7 knight f8 but then
like maybe i'm in time to play h4 h5
yeah i don't like my rook on e7 yeah the
roku 7 is not really okay you should
start by playing yeah some kind of rook
b7 rook d7 yeah okay let me get uh
out of dodge let's go h3
it feels like yeah useful it's useful to
have the g pawn protected i
think it's useful also to have my king
of g7 yeah 95 95 is a strong threat yeah
maybe on a good day knight d5 rook f7
yeah this doesn't feel like it's
holdable but it also feels like
the biggest reason you lose this with
white is you kind of at some point you
lose
patience and you make up an inaccurate
move and then suddenly everything
collapses
let's jump to bucharest as uh christian
is with fabiano christian
yes uh thank you yasser we are here
indeed with fabiano carolina fabiano
welcome back to the studio the final
round it felt like you were trying with
the black pieces was that the strategy
going into the this championship round
yeah i was hoping to get some chances of
course tournament victory was already
out of the question
after yesterday uh after i ruined my
the chances i had yesterday so
uh anyway i thought you know if i win
finish on a high note it's uh
it's not terrible um but like
the thing is i play the line which he
probably was he wasn't expecting but he
was probably ready for because ali reza
played in an earlier round against um
show us against levon
uh
so this g5 long line yes yeah and level
one played this
uh this queen c2 i think he played king
it and
um
yeah i think this was the line and it
was the king
being a mistake the wonder that he made
in the opening um and these are super
complex positions so i was hoping that
we would get something like this and
and a fight but he
he played in a much more direct way
um i i didn't know the move castle i
thought 93 is kind of the usual stuff
um
and castle
uh
but it seemed like planning bishop v6 is
so logical
um
yeah f4 was the main move i considered
it's quite nice that it's 94 i have this
knight take c4 i think it's important
and a queen of six queen e5
and i think the guys in the studio were
showing this beautiful line and this
stuff loses king absolutely whatever he
doesn't really he has a check but no
no no attack
but yeah i guess he was still prepared
um yeah i wasn't i didn't think 93 was
dangerous because i thought the queen b6
would be quite decent because he has to
start misplacing his stuff
um
although like
this was just very direct um
i don't know if i'm forced like i was
considering this briefly and when i
played bishop e6 i was counting on rook
d8 but then i started to wonder about
this stuff it's some
total mess um but i thought okay so you
decided to shy away from that yeah
any sort of uh i mean
like maybe if i didn't know that he
he was prepared for this line then i
would consider it more seriously but um
did you still feel that he was somehow
within his preparation or knowledge i
guess he knew a little bit about the
line but it's such a
equalized position it doesn't really
matter like he can't
cause me too many problems here and
we've got a position where i'm down upon
but i
the bishop pair is definitely
uh you know enough compensation but the
drought tendencies are so high there's
really no chances for either of us to
play for a win
and we played this on forever at some
point i played a bit strange but i was
um
basically tired of moving around and i
decided to provoke this h4
and then get my king active
and
yeah it can get sharp in some cases but
it's mainly
um if he decides to to go for it and
then we have a pawn race while he he
controls my pawns like this and
um
yeah now my king is
centralized it's clearly
um just to draw now obviously fabiano
every single tournament from now until
the candidates is going to be some sort
of preparation for that big event how
would you assess this tournament from uh
for uh from your perspective
oh i mean shaky not not very not very
good overall um
like i i missed some chances i
you know i played one quite uh
quite bad game against maxine i lost
that game i was also very disappointed
yesterday because i still thought i had
chances in the tournament and i got such
a dream position from the opening
against richie
and uh i mean i i think he mixed up his
preparation or something because he
the position he got was like the worst
the worst of all worlds
and uh and i just ruined that i played
like this b4 very quickly and said like
rook d1 or something i just have such
tremendous pressure that i think i would
have likely won the game if i
if i played a bit better and then today
might have been a different story i
might have still you know at least
had a chance to
to make like a four-way play-off um
instead of the three-way play-up like
we'll see
so yeah quality was not really there
but um
anyway i mean you know i was fighting i
was trying um hopefully i'll i'll be
more in shape for
uh for the next tournament i still have
one more yeah for warsaw and uh okay
it's totally different rap and blitz
um
you know it's it's not at all related to
the type of chess we saw here
and of course totally different from the
from the candidates but anyway it's some
good training fabi thank you for joining
us sharing your experience and we're
looking forward to seeing a few days
thank you guys back to you thank you
fabi thank you christian and once again
our standings with one game remaining
peter yeah only the uh ferocious is
still running uh and that means that uh
maxine with a victory will join our two
leaders on uh five and a half currently
he has tied with linear and uh five
point four and a half out of nine but he
will definitely not lose this game so he
is guaranteed clear third now that that
shouldn't like
even perform a part of his no that's not
it calculations here the question is
says um if you were to
is it a 75 winning
opportunity i'm actually very sad
christian decided not to ask fabi
because
i think this is this is a position
everybody everyone should opine on
because of just how rare this material
balance is and i'm i'm i mean probably
sort of stated he they stated what he
believes because he he'd say he's
expecting a three-way play-off and
coming coming soon but still
even this you you don't win every single
time even though
that's what i mean yeah yeah we think
there were probably better ways of
trying to hold this for followers but
even this one you definitely can and
will mess up every now and again with
black it's not a guaranteed
victory uh regardless of what the engine
says until you start creating threats
and white obviously is trying very hard
to to make
creating threats as difficult as
possible for uh for maxim
rookie seven blocking the check on the
board uh rook takes king takes that one
i'm going to say is certainly a win yeah
that one i will go out on the uh ledge
if you will and say that's a certainly
win i'm expecting that alireza will
probably
and then we try to chill uh
and as alejandro would say go ahead do
your worst for the next few moves and
[Music]
he perhaps hinting at some of four or
five somewhere but
mainly just choosing a square
at random because you don't really know
where it's supposed to be it's difficult
to judge whether you know stopping 95 is
important or
supporting f5 is important but like you
can't stop 95 forever rg7 will prepare
it in such a way that will be very
difficult for you to stop agreed yeah
it's and he's also down on time and he
will have to play uh
i mean
the half a minute increment here he's on
four minutes uh and no more uh yeah no
no more additions of time are
forthcoming uh only
the half a minute increment here is
incredibly relevant because many of you
moves will you know be pretty much the
only moves in the position so you do
accumulate
but also if mvl creates a position where
a precision will suddenly be required
it's very easy to burn all of your
remaining time trying to figure out
which which of your potential i know two
options
is the the the one that gives you the
most chances of survival the more i'm
thinking about the more i do like the
move rook a5 it just gives mvl that one
other thing that he has to think about
that there is this move f4 f5 in the
position and sure white can play h3 and
just say
do your worst but
the fact that f4 f5 can come at any any
time and and create these two versus one
and the reason we're talking about a
five only with the rook on a5 of course
is that you absolutely do not want a 5g
fgf you have to read no that is deadly
5gfg if you resign right whereas a 5gf
rook takes a 5 could very easily just be
a draw you just play h2h3 afterwards and
it becomes very very difficult to
convert from there completely agreed
knight e4
yeah just making sure that the 5g five
check is uh
what you don't
want to
achieve very strong but you can pass you
can pass but this is this is one of the
reasons why i kind of get a little
nervous about having my especially if my
pawn were on h3 then i'd be really
afraid that you know i'd get into
zooksvong uh because my king it's easy
to imagine actually getting mated if you
do that exactly exactly but knight e4 on
the board just again ready to meet f5
with g5 and
you just jump right in
every move looks the same to the engine
but i like knight e4 because after the
moves knight e4 i'm even considering
king g7 rook f7 sometimes yes just
asking the question of how you're gonna
defend the pawns and the moment you
block them
it's gonna be easy pickings okay so let
me just make a pass i was wondering if i
can go king juice out and pretend i have
a thread okay i i got something rick's
not on the fifth true uh
applause
[Laughter]
but i did stop rook f7 thunderous
applause thank you
i was but i was afraid by
of the move rook f7 because again
understandably so yeah this doesn't seem
to be winning instantly rather easily
right so it has to be has to be stopped
so uh
thunderous applause of course but uh you
did
you still have to win the game after
bringing my rook to the fourth rank
but uh i i
at this point i can't remember if i
finished that sentence or not
my point is uh occasionally you will
make enough progress
seems like i was i was wondering exactly
how that loses g5 king h5 luke's put it
on the
yeah it looks very very bad but also
yeah f5 g5 is a draw oh okay f5 g5 is a
draw yeah just you can't you can't play
that you got king h5 and that's it
and yeah that's what i thought that
we're not in time king g7 rook a6 and
we're not in time to actually
uh make checkmate or some wonderful
thing you said rook a6
and i just have to give up g5 if you're
gonna ever make progress
and you won't yeah
and we and we chill we don't really play
anything we just play rugby 66 or b6 or
k6 or whatever and
wow so just let me just see this because
i'm still not yeah but this creates no
threat right b6
so just a second so you're saying in the
position we have on the board you can
play f5 what if i just move my king and
say congratulations you want to take
this is probably the stronger option
yeah creating a threat of g5 check
because now the g5 king h5 h6
will win and rook a6 you cannot play of
course because gfgf brings us back to
that position this is the dream position
yeah this
plays he needs to do it is because he
has 55 seconds and counting yeah he's
gone
he's gone to five and yeah q7 looks
strong yeah i think g7 looks very strong
i i think it's uh
you you should be able to reason out
that you cannot play g5 check without
preparation because i was i was like
your firm statement of it's a draw
surprised me a little bit yeah but right
but the fact that i couldn't find a win
after g5 checking h5 was worrying me
quite a bit because yes you would assume
that with the king on h5 if there if
there is a win it's
kind of immediate right and yeah i was
struggling to come up with something
there
and let's jump to bucharest and a quick
comment from anastasia
once again hello everyone and here we
are still in bucharest the last game is
finishing right now i mean the last
classical game at least and uh just
wanted to tell you that uh they're
playing when you're really like full of
people i've never seen so many
spectators all these days and it's like
um i think everybody understood that
it's gonna be a tie break and all of
them came to have to see the last time
they're the top layers and enjoy chess
the last hours of chess here in
bucharest and um i just wanted to update
you with some information because i
heard alejandro was struggling to tell
to the public what will happen in case
of tie if all three players will be um
will be playing the tie break then it's
going to be the round robin event and
imagine if all the games will finish in
the draw so what happens in this case i
heard that it's going to be another
drawing of lots and then two players
will play their magidon game while the
third one will be resting at that moment
and the winner of their mughadon match
will play another armageddon game with
the third one who is still waiting yes
so this is how we will learn who is the
winner
of the bucharest
part of the grand chess tour so i'm
looking forward to see what will happen
still we are not sure if maxine will win
this game i can hear your great comments
about this game of course we will follow
it here in bucharest so and now we we're
back to you to the studio peter
alejandro and yasser
thank you uh anastasia i must say that
when i came in today
i didn't expect that we'd have more than
one armageddon game feeder but if you're
telling me we're gonna have three
uh coffee
oh my gosh we're going to be really here
uh
the thing that's
we very much appreciate the update but
the question which
was left somewhat unanswered so so
basically
the
hang on
am i
am i to understand correctly that
basically the person who plays one
armageddon instead of two
is just
drawn by by drawing of lots correct
i am
overjoyed
i'm sure bias are potential as a
potential players in that tie break i'm
sure
this is this is tremendous stuff i kind
of miss the fact that
he's not in this playoffs so that we
could have a few more armageddons in
case everything went
uh in the meanwhile by the way f5 uh ali
reza is down on the clock but uh it's
mvl
well he knows he is he is now very very
close he knows that this is probably now
a calculable position potentially and uh
he has time enough to burn so he's doing
the right thing he's on 14 minutes
against one and a half
by the way in the interview uh with
richie
i just couldn't help but feeling that
there was so much you know south of
loathing going on there that it was a
little bit getting too much right it was
like looking in the mirror
[Laughter]
come on
he's not a terrible player i mean
so why the
self-deprecation but like the
combination of the the result
coupled with how that result was
achieved in this tournament i think is
very uh easy uh
you know you can understand how it
triggers those fittings because not only
has he had a really really horrible
result but it was also
you know a number of very good positions
blown a number of like straight-up
one-move peace blunders achieved in in a
single tournament
and he is currently you know this is
once it feels very disrespectful to the
first first gct event to to you know
describe it as a preparation for
anything right this is like a category
21 exactly exactly it doesn't get any
stronger than this so you know it's not
it's not really a warm-up as such
but he is
nearing the moment where he will be
playing the most important tournament of
his career right
he understands that you you don't always
do well but the combination of not doing
well and also like clearly his brain
malfunctioning on him time and time
again
over the course of the tournament is
is not enjoyable and yeah i i could uh
you you feel the pain there you feel you
feel he is really really struggling with
uh
with how this tournament came out and um
definitely yeah and again i
it it's so rare to see you know like
such a super world-class grand master
just you know again picking on himself
and saying you know i know nothing
that's terrible this is uh
i can't believe i did what i did and so
forth and so on uh in the meanwhile we
do have an exchange a trade if you will
on the g6 square uh
takes takes and
peter
this is a kind of a dream
uh for mvl now i mean well so three
versus two versus one sorry yeah
generally speaking trading pawns is uh
is in white's favor you would say but
this is a kind of a trade and
particularly because the king is on h4
it can be it can be attacked right uh
and
you're very very far from achieving any
kind of account to play against the bono
g6 this really does look winnable now
yeah you don't have any h4 h5 concepts
with your keys you can play g5 check
here because king h5 king of 6
will
create immediate very serious tactical
issues for
uh
for foreign even that i think is
playable i don't know if it's the best
move but it's like it's definitely
something about this one because i do
have check and i guess i like king five
king of four i think i'm not that
bothered by
allowing king g6 because yeah you're
never playing h4 there
gotcha
fair enough
wow okay so
if that's the case that's even uh
more good news for mvl fans more good
news for armageddon fans
and just to remind everybody uh playoffs
will be
played
15 minutes
after this game uh ends and there will
be a drawing of lots
for the numbers one two three in the uh
round robin
that they will play at the start
the player who wins the round robin will
be our champion yay but if two players
tie by scoring for example one and a
half there will be one a single
armageddon game there will be a single
arm and if all games are drawn or if all
three games are decisive in a way that
everybody ends on one point
then there will be there will be there
will be some flipping yeah and uh
i have been involved in some high
profile flips in my life they are fun
fun fun
tense tense affairs okay uh rook a4 on
the board and are you advocating for g5
yes i am
yes it's because you can't play king h5
and if you drive the king all the way
down to the second rank with the pawn on
g5 and you started thinking that my
knight can hop
somewhere to f4 to h4 and you calculate
that white just never gets h4n
so we give a check here i don't know we
give a check from d3 i think it's useful
yeah yeah king g2 and maybe knight c596
for instance yeah 95.96 something like
that that's the dream i very much like
this idea just landing it on f4 and yeah
eventually you just will make enough
progress to start picking up weaknesses
the the really sad part is you're
actually attacking my rook because
otherwise i was seriously contemplating
the move h2h4 so that in case you were
to take my pawn on h4
yeah
yeah something something has been
achieved no i'm not i'm not sure if it's
a draw but knight xa4 definitely does
win here
also i saw the previous move yes i owned
the previous one alejandro explained to
me like one of his worst moments uh
sorry alejandra this is he's playing
and it's just rook versus knight and
some pawns on the board so he's
obviously winning with the rook and uh
so he made some move and
the knight took the rook
andre looked at his score she said yeah
and the knight attacked the rug
didn't bother me
[Laughter]
it's really really really true
um
all right well again uh from
ali reza's
fans point of view
he's just hoping for a mistake yeah he's
hoping something goes wrong for uh for
mvl here and can king shrife i think he
loses the cleanest way to win here would
be the player of g8 i suspect
yeah that would be the mistake that
we're talking about here rg8 doesn't
actually create
enough of a mating thread and then king
f6
oh
that is pretty and you can also you can
also do the whole thing right you can
play rook g8 and then do the oh
and then
snaps on e4 and you go
young man
let me show you the voice of experience
that is funny yeah and our next stop on
the grand chess tour is warsaw poland
may 19th through the 23rd super bet
bringing you rapid and blitz yep those
are the playing days may 19th 20th and
21st we'll have rapid chess three rounds
a day and then we'll of course follow it
up with the woods portions nine round
tournaments of blitz on the 22nd and the
23rd
yes indeed something to look forward to
which doesn't really spoil anything but
also doesn't make immediate progress but
i think he's by this point very
interested in also in the idea of giving
as much as wide of a choice to alireza
is possible because the position is bad
and
getting him to burn more time is also
not not nothing
but i love these incremental creepy
crawly progressive types of moves
such as king g king king f6 and rookie
six in these positions one the whole
idea being that when i do play g5
i'll be good i'm ready yeah
i mean i will be absolutely
for bear by the way there is the
okay let me just show it uh king f6
there is the uh
the simple threat of mate i think you go
g5 check i think you absolutely have to
play g5 check yeah because uh if you
play rook a6 check i think king e5 wins
on the spot
i think g5 is just strictly the only
move you can even make because uh yeah
this is bad i'm not saying this is a
good one no no no no i got king g4h4 and
i hope that
somehow i'm in time even though like the
expectation is we're going to never
never sure
unfortunately for y 96 rookie for check
95 something like this exactly i
actually very much like king of six i
was also looking at that because
uh the the the point specifically is
that i think alireza is planning to go
to k6 check in response
and this is a check in case of h5 sorry
you're about to say something yeah in
the current position if we go king of
six you would like to play rook a6 check
and not commit to g4 g5 because 4g5 is
clearly not the move you want to be
making but king e5 just wins here
king e5 yeah because we don't really
need the king for that matching threat
to work and getting it to f4 pretty much
ends the i mean rook h7 is pretty strong
here we don't really need to be
the last thing you said was getting it
to f4
they went with the flow
[Laughter]
but rook h7 yes that is the
goal of the
of the game yeah nicely and uh yeah it
feels like king of six is a piston nice
that is checkmate that is checkmate
and uh tom
tom needed some reassurance somehow
our
wanted to be make sure that checkmate
was the goal of the game yes tom
sometimes you forget especially so yeah
yeah yeah very much so king f6 is not
played yet and uh i'm pretty sure it's
difficult to actually spoil this by now
because white is so far away from like
moving the king from h4 exactly i'm sure
that's a great way to start a
commentator's curse it's very difficult
to spoil the chances of winning this
position yes it's not so easy actually
king of 60 engines they still think it's
winning
they don't think it's very clean because
of g5
yeah you do play g5 instantly and you
feel that
actually you get squares for the king on
h4 currently it has no squares and yes
you hate the fact that your pawns got uh
advanced uh advanced and potentially
blockaded but you know the position is
bad enough that maybe this is sort of
the improvement you actually want right
uh at least uh there is a clear-cut plan
after g5 king somewhere king g4 h4 h5 is
a dream it's not going to happen
probably but it's at least
something to to look forward to and king
of six in the meantime uh is played yeah
he has to play g5 check if he goes king
h3 back
yeah he will be choice he will be
doomed i think yeah now g5
i don't know if king of seven or king e6
is cleaner i'm guessing f7 but i'm
guessing f7 as well well king f7 looks
right to me after king g4
knight drops back h4 rook comes in with
a check yeah but actually that that line
that you were giving king actually not
to five
yeah yeah i want to give a check here
and continue giving checks
how do you win this yeah exactly like it
it looks completely winning but i am
going to give you tons of checks and i
check i want to i want it all the way on
b7
and then i will play rocket chain
and honestly this probably is a draw now
i didn't realize that you could defend
the ball
i thought you were going to g8 i didn't
understand what the problem was
is this actually a draw or maybe not
because i'm not actually threatening h5
anyway i mean i could probably play
knight eight you don't have a thread i
can just no no no
i don't know how you win it that's the
other thing
hold on
yeah you could win it you just
the king can't move yeah now i'm running
with the king towards f3 or somewhere
and then i will create a mating net
and by the way
come on
five yeah was there an alternative to
kg4 not really but
yeah he just likes to wait until he gets
he has three seconds on his clock living
on the edge yeah
yeah these thrill seekers you know
all right 96 is winning it seems like
the only winning move but that is not so
shocking yeah you you kind of imagine
that this needs to be needs to be done
because you i mean h4h5 is actually
coming very quickly yeah right 96
blitzed out the big question is if i
play i mean it's actually not even such
a big question i think the answer is is
it rook a4 can we trade rooks or not i
think we can my my initial reaction was
that we cannot
but i think we can really uh that would
be the one thing that i would be seeking
to avoid but you're saying okay for you
you'd like to play this move like is a
strong word but i think i can play this
move yeah he's played with k4 because
takes takes h4 knight have to check
i think this wins
does it
wow i have to check
king of three okay
knight d3 93 okay
all right this is actually a draw
against both movies king e4 actually
loses for some reason no kidding but
king g3 and king g4 are both a draw
okay 95 check yeah
still a draw king e4
this is a draw yeah we actually had this
but i thought i'm i'm getting a better
version but then vl avoids it
wisely
the one to trade rooks in that situation
uh knight f5 yeah
sorry another five plate
another five plate an h4n g7 and yeah
he's very safely prevented the h5 knight
h5 idea
but how do we win this is the the
question now
um thing is you can't create a meta you
cannot create major threats because of
stalemate because of still matrix yeah
we might want to show that so for
example if i pass and you go to knight
h5 when i pass and you go to key three
it looks like you're check threading
checkmate which is very nice and then if
you go to k7 you get out of the checks
by just going king e8 and
marching the king but you actually don't
you know this would be this is a mistake
but true k8 and then okay it is simply a
draw yeah okay seven rook g8 and we
continue those checks and those checks
you actually do not get out of yeah
i think i don't know
also rookie 64 g6 is quite strong but uh
if you go yeah if you go that direction
yeah and if i go the other way it's a
mad rook yeah yeah yeah i think so yeah
rook c7 or rook it would be a doesn't
matter yeah we just give give those
checks from
from those squares forever
you can run towards e2
but yeah once you cross the sixth i give
a check from the sixth right like yeah
king a6 b6 is a draw
because and then you have a choice of
you know
giving up the ball and six and maybe not
making a drum
which would be
terrible unnecessary yeah i would
suspect okay so that's the point there
is the stalemate theme in the position
and ali reza there was
actually played very quickly uh yeah he
decided not to entertain those ideas he
put the king on f3 so that rookie three
doesn't actually happen
um
all right
yeah but i think after okay seven or
rook c7 whatever yeah yeah yeah i like
rookie seven much better i think you're
actually supposed to go kg for yourself
here i would suggest because
if you play yeah to have to go back to
those ideas of
the desperado rook if you go to k3
because if you pass if you play rook c4
instead for instance
i give a check from a3
and now king g4 actually is checkmate
king e4 probably is the only move but i
suspect loses to something and if you go
back to the second
if you play king ji king or whatever i
think now
yeah
yeah now the king the king starts
running towards the g4 square and yeah
there's just no not gonna hopelessly
yeah the king needs to stay on g4
weirdly the king actually needs to
uh voluntarily
step into a step and step into the
mating net and and try to uh provoke the
rook to the third because yeah if you if
you try avoiding that
you're doing worse yeah i'm not actually
sure how you lose against keeping the
king on e4 yeah that's another question
yeah and rook d7 is a weird move to my
eyes honestly because i guess he wants
to have rook g6 he wants to play king e6
and have rook v6 as an option yeah very
cleverly king g4 played by alireza reza
recognized by this point that this is
not made
it's in fact probably just a draw if you
play g3 can i play king e4
he says to go to you
yeah you probably should i want to go
towards the e4 square if you give me a
check i will trade rooks in this case
uh firm in my belief that i will pick up
all the pawns i think this is what mvl
is trying to do he's very clearly
reaching for king e6 he wants king e5
rugby five from d5 precisely and that
will uh they will win exactly exactly
that's what i'm thinking he's ready for
kingy sex yeah
i i guess the way to prolong the uh he
even starts with rookie six in the car
the the very slow creep creepy crowley
as you described it exactly
um but it doesn't really change very
much he will still play king e6 next
move the threat will be
king e5 and if the rule goes to e4
if it goes to e4 and now can which it
has time
yeah rook d3 is still a draw the 7
i don't think anything changed there or
at least it's not like you can go king
g8 king h7 knight g7 but that doesn't
really improve your position so you know
what you wanted yeah you do something
else
um
i i'm impressed by the fact that this
king is so useful on the uh g4 square
i'm starting to think maybe i should
just chase it out yeah you won't flush
it out diwali in this current position
looks of like a very very sensible move
just sort of asking the question yeah go
go away from make a move yeah yeah maybe
just make a move go away from the king
side
and if the rook you want played yeah if
the rook was to go to the side well no
yeah we go king of six king they fire we
we've got the the setup that we want
maybe even
one is not bad but i i quite like just
starting with king six and proceeding
from there agreed yeah
and he has done it by the way rook d1
yeah
yeah i like this idea a lot
get the king away from the h4 pawn it's
remarkable that the king on g4
being in the mating net is actually uh
the one way to invite a mistake yeah
yeah but the nbl is you know too long in
the tooth yeah
and we can see farouza he is a very very
low time again
they're down to single single digits on
the clock hard to tell but his
fingertips are
it's the pan it's a pen i thought it
would i didn't know if it was a piece
that he was okay before yeah
check is not a mistake but i quite like
just going kini 16 d5 here and and
starting on the proactive plan of
winning winning the game with with the
king march towards good squares
don't see anything wrong with it
whatsoever
and again after
rook a4 uh king e6 yeah any checks along
the third rank uh pardon the six yeah we
will play ruby six quite happily here
and right and if rookie for king d5 you
have to put the rook on e8 or somewhere
and then rook d4 check will probably
just have it by the way so
yeah and very quickly rook d6
yeah this is no longer really even very
tricky i think no i think it's done yeah
you go king e5 yeah once you get the
rook to d4 it's just so comfortable to
defend the pawn on g6 with king f5 or
knight f4 yeah
yes correct yeah
yeah
and we do get we do get the very
exciting uh three-way tie there and
potential for more shenanigans
down the line
potentially six more games of chess
i think it's actually five from the five
from that description anastasia gave i
don't think they play three armageddons
i think they play two it's just that
it's just that one lucky guy plays one
and the other and the other less like a
guy plays plays too
and the least lucky guy also plays one
there's one but loses it again
nice
nice
rook a4 on the board we are expecting
king e5 to appear yeah i think that very
quickly pretty easy yeah
at this point i would agree
yeah so
not even clear how to create a single
problem yeah this is just a very
very routine conversion from here
nicely done by email i wonder if he
realized that five nights before was a
draw
i'm really hoping they will not
interview him right now with a with a
three-way tiebreak in front of him but
right
yeah yeah i think we're going to let him
just get as much rest and
recalibrate because i mean obviously he
came in today thinking oh
those guys all draw and i win with the
black pieces oh aren't i a happy guy
but now that it's actually happening now
he's got to re-calibrate and think okay
how do i win a playoff and we can start
sort of wrapping up the classical
portion a little bit here and i want to
start by saying that that that
dude on the left
who
potentially has not lost a single game
of classical chess in 2021 it probably
is incorrect but feels like it right uh
we'll have lost two with white in this
tournament and we'll finish on minus one
uh remarkable he will not be a happy
camper about that
it's uh i think there are some people
that leave the tournament clearly
i'm
upset about their event i think ferruja
is definitely up there yeah young yan
shaq richard yeah there's a number of
very very sad people with with how this
came out
and uh yeah
the important trick here is not to go
rook d4 rook g3 because that would once
again blunder into king g4 and h5 but
yeah black is winning we'll just i think
we'll leave you to watch the conclusion
because we don't really need to explain
to you why having more pieces in this
end game is better than having a few
fewer pieces
but yeah i think it's the first setback
he's had in a while earlier as i don't
remember bad tournaments from him in
quite some time
and it's coming you know very very close
to uh to the candidates
that's a curious move king f5 i was
thinking king f4 but okay yeah king of
five is still fine you know okay five
you you're playing for here
yeah it really shouldn't shouldn't
matter a great deal what you do as long
as you don't blunder into a stalemate or
don't trade rooks in a way that moves
your light away from the h5 square
yeah so
and he he did not seem out of form
honestly alireza played very very
interesting chess very exciting chess in
this tournament i think he the the
number of setbacks one in particular i
think he was just really thrown off in
in his game with daniel dayaka where he
was up a piece and he seemed to be
cruising and daniel had no time and
somehow outplayed him and uh
yeah
that was that was late in the tournament
though and uh
yeah
he's still sort of playing exactly the
same brand of chess that we enjoyed so
much let's say in the grand in the grand
swiss where right he very very obviously
plays pretty much every single game to
maximize the chance of of all three
results including i think pretty much
all of his games with the black pieces
were you know as chaotic as he could
make them
[Music]
he is still the same alireza who was
absolutely just kind of setting the
world on fire in in particular late last
year
but it's just it wasn't clicking for him
and you
you could go down the rabbit hole of you
know you should not
stop playing chess altogether for like
five months because
uh because it will lead to this these
types of uh perhaps
misfires
but this is the this is the one where he
can sort of afford to have some misfires
he will still be you know desperately
unhappy about how this came out
but it's you know if it has to happen
you better now than in
madrid yeah you can sort of afford for
it to to happen now madrid would be
disastrous exactly
and i do like everything there are some
amazing constructions here uh which are
quite cute uh like you can actually in
some lines give them give up the on six
to drive the king back to the uh to the
back rank and then mate it there i found
uh one or two lines like this starting
with let's say you play
uh how did that go uh
king of four
uh rook a3 rookie 4
at this point you have to allow the
rookie 3 check so you play rook a6 for
instance here
and you can play rookie 3 check
king h2k g4 if you wanted this is even
stronger actually here i'm i'm probably
actually playing rookie to check
oh there yeah with that and and now
after king g1 we actually win with
knight g3
because king h3 cannot be stopped and
and we do give mate here with uh
very very nice mating pattern indeed
peter i like that one a lot
not much to be done and i'm just going
to refresh my board everybody's forgive
me for that but
we're up to date with the play
yeah but i mean the the king marching
its way to f3 and setting up a mate with
the rook and knight
mvl is doing it the the sort of the slow
way but he is still going to win very
comfortably rookie four is played with
the intention of playing king of three
and then having rookie three as a reply
to k3 check yeah which is showing sort
of nice nice little understanding of
things you could and here you go king of
two i think yeah you just play king of
two provocate to check your cooking of
three
and then once again rook a3 rookie 3 can
be played somewhere around here you can
be excused to just kind of throw in the
towel because you like by this point you
really know how this movie ends yeah yes
you still haven't even attacked the pawn
on g6 and you are getting slowly driven
driven into a corner and yeah the way
you lose here is you actually get mated
you don't even lose all your pawns you
just get made exactly
like for example one uh very
oops why don't you also make a yes i did
but somehow i didn't want to
register
yeah something like this just ends ends
the game you know you want this a very
very clean way to
cur
yeah now
in the past uh they used to have uh
the player who who lost the most games
won
yeah because it also meant you won them
in those games and that would be that
would be unveiled yeah with his three
victories and one defeat yeah uh and the
uh would have won a lot of kind of tie
breakers of the past and kind of a
sleeper there although we did mention it
during the course of the uh the course
of the broadcast would be linear who's
on 50 but actually won two games yeah
and
time and last year yeah very very high
percentage of decisive games for
a tournament in which in general it's
not
it's not that that big
rook f uh approached me rook a2 check
king f3 as you said it's kind of nice to
get the king uh
to f3 when your rook is
not ready to give a check on the first
rank and you're now ready to play knight
f4
and rookie two everything knight f4
king h2 king g4 everything and you can
see it's in mbl's posture that by this
point he is no longer he is no longer
concentrated he knows that it's kind of
he's not missing from here exactly
and he also kind of try not to look at
your opponent because yeah you you let
your opponent suffer in peace you know
that uh also knows he's lost so you
you're trying not to kind of
annoy your opponent
by staring at him intently and maybe if
you don't know him
you never you didn't go to the victor
korchner school of chess like do you
speak english why don't you resign yeah
i i love that story it's my it's my
all-time favorite story
it's so good
it's it's so terrible it's good i mean
uh king f3 rook a3 check uh rookie three
played yeah uh
handshake yeah kind of handshake here
really like that's not four a
no handshakes no handshakes here yeah
i'm of the knight f4 school of chess
another four okay to check and then
yeah
yeah king g3 i guess i guess the the the
simplest way and the the way that kind
of and there is there it is
wow
wow
if we only get one victory per round
this was the victory uh that makes the
playoffs that much more fun guys and we
had at least one victory per round
thanks to this game exactly yeah yeah we
were in danger of having an actual five
draw rounds but no but no no well that
sets up the stage guys it's a three-way
play-off for the winner of book rs2022 a
super bad chess classic here in romania
to start the grand chest remember the
winner of the playoff takes home an
extra 10k but also those gct points that
are so important for the tour players as
they go off to the playoffs that's the
amount of money they get
67
667 plus i'll assume the ten plus ten
for the winner so they're going to be
playing a three-way tournament basically
for ten thousand dollars
and you got the breakdown there and of
course we know our players wesley saw
and ivana ronyande
was led from start to finish right levon
joined him a little bit there near the
middle
and maxime
near the end was like hey this is my
time to get on plus two and now we have
the three players had tip to veround for
getting one right but
shame on you
shame on you guys for not getting any of
the either the other two i was really i
was hoping that you'd do better
but
we will take a break and
get ourselves sorted for a very exciting
playoff don't miss it see you on the
other side
[Music]
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories offering
facts that may have been omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
and we're back with the three-way tie
break
there at the top with mvl winning the
dramatic game against his countrymen
elizabeth
and this is the first game yeah this is
the first one we will watch wesley has
the white pieces against the one iranian
after the drawing of lords which means
that he will be black against mbl
will be black against levon i would
assume
or that makes sense two games and here's
how the playoff scenario works yeah we
can three players yeah we can ignore the
the top line there because lg win his
game
they will play a a single round robin
with everybody playing each other once
which means that one player always sits
out and we get one game to watch uh all
of the games will be ten plus five and
if there is still a tie
there will be an armageddon game uh with
five minutes to wide for four minutes
for black and draughts for black and the
interesting one of course is every is
what happens if everybody finishes on
one point which is not unheard of in
such a small tournament exactly
there will be an additional drawing of
lots which will determine
uh who gets to kind of get seated in the
final right uh and the other two players
will play another the same armageddon
five against four game and whoever
progresses you don't actually have to
win to progress in the right hand uh
gets to play yet another magette in game
against the guy who was on the sidelines
yeah grinning greeting as he watches
them slug it out yeah
absolutely
i was thinking about this during a rape
year and no seriously the amongst these
three players i can imagine them playing
this play off and getting three times
and getting three different results i
mean i really think that all of these
players are that this
is matched as as it can get yeah
are tremendous tremendous players and
jump in on this uh thought allie hunter
i mean they know each other so well
right these are some of the more
consistent tour participants they will
play against each other in rapid time
controls for many many years they faced
each other their grand chess tours
maxime and aronian specifically have had
matches
clubs that have gone the distance really
the distance so they're very familiar
with each other especially familiar with
rapid time controls with everything to
play for
yeah and in these
in these uh playoffs i've always felt
that
nerves
nerves play such an important part i
mean it's like yeah all of these guys
know all the good moves but it's just
that keeping
calm at the board absolutely and once
again more and more crucial because
they're such great veterans of the game
they know how to do that
they keep their emotions in check yeah
and the men and the men on our screen uh
i think
very very uh uh
hard to tilt
one of the most solid performance
performers in the last
number of years uh
the very few things seem to you know
throw him off his game
um
very solid tournament from him the other
two had a bit of a topsy-turvy event mvl
actually lost the game in one three and
uh levon only had two decisive results
could have had five
and three of them
yeah
and wesley had a very typical wesley
event where he won the two games where
he got good positions with white and was
i think entirely untroubled
yeah i i i can't remember a single even
slightly suspect position of well for
wesley yeah no
he had some additional chances he was
definitely better against fabian round
three with the black pieces when he was
upon
yeah he was definitely better in the
final position today whether this
advantage was enough for a win he
clearly didn't think so and maybe he was
right but once again once again
definitely pressure on his side you know
draw from a position of strength so to
speak yeah very very smooth event and
not so far
and and playing very much against the
the the tournament joker here
i'm sure uh lavon would appreciate that
i mean he would uh he'd be very
sympathetic yeah i think
uh he will also have
an opinion on who who the best joker
ever is i'm pretty sure right um
but yeah they know each other inside and
out and uh
this is going to be very interesting to
watch and also i actually kind of like
it's ten plus five because i think
they're both kind of like it's a very
grueling event
uh every day is a difficult game and
it's i think sort of by this point it's
more enjoyable to play shorter time
controls and then plus five is
significantly shorter than 15 plus 10.
absolutely what's also extraordinary for
me is that
in this time control of 10 minutes and
increment
uh the quality of the game can be so
high i mean it's just it's it's
extraordinary to me how
well these players play whether it's
three plus two or
five plus three or ten plus five and
here we go we are
underway as wesley so yeah their
classical game was somewhat uneventful
right it was
something very very sorry like
i'm so sorry we forgot about it but this
was not going to be solid this has been
the i e5
but one sort of refuted it from the
white side a little bit right i think
his last few kind of reviews not not
refuted refuted but uh what was actually
instrumental in uh i think putting the
first serious dents in
this idea of b5 uh beating i think
hikaru and he maybe won one more
gasoline year as well i think right i
think so but the hikara one was the big
one in the grand prix
uh yeah and this is all theory uh e4 e5
knight of three bishop before check
and uh yeah queen takes d2 here these
positions are solid the opponency ford
never survives but in the time that
white needs to win it back black will
finish development and
generally not stand uh all that poorly
energy first you can go 97 knight bc6
and just more or less instantly uh turns
to get into some kind of
an endgame where yes white is ever so
slightly better but it's not much
i
actually had a bad experience in that
specific variation against anatoly
karpov bishop takes c4 knight c6
knight takes c6 and you might think yeah
it kind of it's impossible but it's a
bit worse yeah he definitely outplayed
me thoroughly i wanted to say
definitely towards the top of the list
of people i would not want that
much to my discomfort i certainly found
that to be the case bishop takes c4
knight c6
i mean it shouldn't be a bad position
for or shouldn't be that bad let's put
it like this no it should not you can
also start with knight c3 which gives
you an additional option of perhaps
meeting knight bc6 with long castles
uh getting similar end games with with
your king already on c1 i don't know if
that's an achievement or not or you
could still go knight takes e6 and get
pretty much the same position we were
just discussing yeah maybe the king and
e3 would actually be
not so bad
um
not playing like bc6 here i think very
much does invite long castles though
for sure
uh by the way for a lot of amateur
players they're told that they shouldn't
be playing moves like bishop before shaq
and capturing because they're developing
their opponent's pieces for them you
also you also got rid of the bishop on
the face so you can castle easier and uh
um and also these days you know the very
simple fact of life is that uh
in the opening you do what the engine
does
well there you are how can you argue
with that right peter schmidler
the petersburg
years before maybe not very many years
but some years before i started
doing courses for chesapeal myself i
remember i
came to hamburg to do some commentary
with uh with gusty and
as is often the case i was staying with
him
in his
very nice uh very nice house by this
point
and he was in the process of finishing i
think uh his uh
magnum opposite the e45 course he did
for chesapeake
yeah one of the things he told me is
that
i'm running out of ways of
not saying that i'm giving this move
because this is what leela tells me to
play in this position
because
obviously
you know you're you're faced with a
dilemma there of you know you're
considering the strength of amateurs
these days and the fact that every
single amateur out there who is
interested enough in chef theory
to to purchase a course like this will
have an engine yes you can't ignore what
the engine says because they will be
they will be able to point out the
things you've missed
and it will be kind of unhealthy
you didn't double check
but but also but also if you every time
a somewhat alien looking move appears if
every time this happens
you just say this is here because it's
the first line
of the engine yeah
at some point it will become repetitive
yeah so you start looking for synonyms
and ways of saying this without saying
this
and
his is a long course
and he was kind of 20 hours later kind
of running out of adjectives to use he
was
my silicon friend has recommended
uh by the way uh just being told and i
find that rather uh preposterous that
long castles was a novelty but i think
this just seems to be two choices really
just a function of how rare this
position is i'm pretty sure if there
were more than like three games here
somebody would have played long castles
it's a very logical move i'm more
surprised by the fact that after knight
c6 queen e3 hasn't been played yet i
think queen e3 is like
by far okay this explains it because you
definitely don't play the same end game
now that levon has given you additional
options that's what i was thinking as
well queen e3 sure had my attention
because you can recapture with the rook
and uh well at the moment black's queen
doesn't have a very good
square but uh
wesley spotted a another potential
weakness
uh
she said
she's just weak yeah seven is weak and
uh this is actually
trouble yeah you're not holding on to
that palm but there's tactics in the
position what's the tactic the engines
want to go a6 this is the best basis
and here we go let's see if you find the
knife
you know you have to take with the
knight and go request and you go rook a7
and this defends the c4 pawn and more
importantly than defending c4 is that b5
is coming and that is a good structure
yeah that is amazing that is quite quite
striking and it does seem to be sort of
far and away the best option black has
here um a7 a6
forcing white to
uh
go through go through with his threat
yeah and i'm wondering if let's say
after something like queen f4 we're
supposed to sacrifice that queen
which i would be interested in
particularly in a rapid game like if you
play queen f4 here i go a b rook g8
route g8
and
a that rook on a8 is smiling isn't it
yeah it's a very strange position i'm
not sure this is good because knight
takes b5 might be decent with the
intention of meeting rook a2 with either
the immediate bishop c4 and then some
tactics maybe king b1 and then bishop c4
works i mean this is a whole rook i'm
trying to give away here it's not mine
which is why i'm trying
ah this is so beautiful can we get to
the front position there please
i i said king b1 right i i yes king b1
rook check
oh
and you have to play king c2 because if
you take on a2
you get chased to a4 and mated there
sweet
sweet
this is this is very cute completely
irrelevant but very good
it's not mate ah
is it not made i don't know life is just
so unfair i thought bishop seven was
maybe half king a5
king b5 by the way uh
what will not happen
[Laughter]
i think black is actually i think black
is actually doing maybe okay here i go
king's if you play king c5 i go b6 check
king d5 rook d1 check
king take c5 f6 check i win the queen
and then and then with a slight pull in
the air game now yeah then there's some
kind of a really strange end game which
i can't access
yeah okay but yeah things uh things that
uh are definitely a lot more fun for us
than they are for the players nothing
relevant because bishop v6 was played
very quickly by levon
not asics no
challenging wesley to take that part on
c7 you have to trade queen's first oh
i've got queen f4 as a starter and the
four is also a move i'm a little worried
about knight i think g6 yeah that is
that is a clever inclusion yeah there is
no
no
g8 a87 correct yeah g88 c7 is
this but it feels like a pinball but i'm
guessing this position is not that clear
actually like we go rook i want to say
c8 yes knight d6 f e
f e yeah
do you think the pawn on the bishop c4
95 or g393 or maybe this is i don't
believe this right nice that's not great
but wesley chose uh
rather quickly
wow i thought queen f4 was definitely a
boss move
queen d8 and then and then rook takes
the eight as well just uh forcing uh
forcing the most straightforward way of
picking the policy seven up he took with
the a rook yeah he took away the aok and
then yeah knight takes d8 doesn't make
any sense to me i think we take with the
rook and after 97 we look for a good
option here and 95 being the most
obvious one but there might be something
smarter even though i'm not entirely
sure what
as we look for yeah
the policy four is very very definitely
hanging right now and we don't want to
be giving up for nothing well rook d for
my walk into some kind of no
f3 knight b5
uh rook d4 exists something about knight
e5 i just don't trust
it feels like you're on the edge
uh the entire position looks very very
risky to be honest like i just don't
like this for black i like none of this
for black effects
yeah these are these positions tend to
be quite dangerous
indeed they do even though here i
definitely take with the rook i don't
create this quote-unquote passer on d3
which will just get picked up it feels
like exactly i think with the rook and i
hope that i don't lose very much here
yeah but i think a symptom of the
position levon didn't go for any of this
play the move knight a5 instead of this
i really hate okay well the 95
i think we think would have got refuted
knight a5 we understand why
not a beauty no that is not a beautiful
move yeah and wesley's saying okay you
go ahead and enjoy the discomfort
of
discordant pieces while i finish my
development this is a better bad game
for black yeah oh boy you're not
guaranteed to win it with white but you
you you have much the better over three
reasons more active pieces monstrous
knight on c3 which cannot be challenged
by anything
uh horrible knight on a5 the opponent c4
continually uh weak
right so weak that i very much would
like to collect forest knight takes e6
and then play six and b5 and this feels
like maybe the one way black
stabilizes here but you need so many
things to go right for you ride a7 a6
on the board a6
but while the knight on c7 is alive
we're not playing b5 this is why i was
also connecting it with the idea of
getting those pieces off and yeah wesley
just never taking on e6 here and unless
he's completely forced and compelled the
knight on c7 is just very very strong
well now wesley actually does have a
thing because
truth be told knight takes d1 and knight
c3 uh
knight pardon me to e3 yes to e3 thank
you makes makes perfect sense yeah at
that point but i mean i i like the c3
square so much that
i i feel that it's interesting but
unnecessary you can do this and let's
say i mean b5 knight a6 is immediately
horrible
if you play bishop c8 here
in order to play in order to play b5 if
all else fails i can actually play a4 i
don't really with the rogue's gone and
the queen's gone
i got a feeling that uh knight d5 is
also nice
i might just start claiming uh some
very seriously important territory
ordered i lost i think it really feels
it and it just right out of the opening
in fact pardon me the bishop is still
uneasy interestingly it is wesley who is
down on time here despite you know
seemingly a dominant position by move
whatever it is 15 16 now
uh
lev
i think rushed the opening a little bit
a little bit it seemed that he didn't
equalize fully i'm not sure where he
went wrong exactly but the variation he
chose running straight into this endgame
very bad i mean this pawn on c4 is gonna
drop
yeah king on d2 knight somewhere even a4
yeah exactly i was going to say the a2a4
is not going to be a problem at all and
yeah you just there's no these pieces
don't work together very well and white
is just and i'm just not sure how you
get b5 in ever because i i also have
possibilities of going not a4 but knight
a4
and when oh dear yeah yeah i think
knight a4 is a threat like you
immediately have threat
very poor you're just getting into c5
76 yeah yeah now this is just bad and
yeah i think the start of levon's
problems was that he played castles
prior to playing knight c6 i understand
why he didn't want that end game the one
that we were describing the one you
struggled against anatoly
but i mean
probably you didn't have this position i
would assume you know no no no no no i
he he got a position where he got in f4
and f5 in a kind of alaska style
and i had i had just
i was cramped yeah but but not like this
looks like it might actually be lost
it's not cramped it's uh it's much worse
than we do have i believe king f8 on the
board yeah he has played king of faith
but getting that king into the game is
going to be very very difficult because
yeah fa king d2 feels much more usable
just just looking into the e3
f4 at some point i liked what alejandro
was saying that
a4
knight b6 and king c3 that just wow
once you see that visually you're going
to i'll sign up for that
yeah but king d2 is probably not
spoiling anything no no no i like king
d2 as well i'm just saying that
now
yeah and yeah now there's a bit of a
choice because uh
without 97 check threads i like 95 less
even though i suspect white is still
much better but you have a choice of
still playing a4 you have a choice of
i'm i'm liking a4 that just
puts the kibosh
forever on b5
we've been talking about a knight a4
there's no b5 you can't because
knight c5 picks up the pawn or nation
well you can but cause it costs you the
a6 pawn which you probably don't enjoy
very much yeah fair
um
and the
another point i wanted to make is that
yes the king is on the face but getting
it much closer with the knight on c7
it's not going to be easy yeah that's
right it probably costs you material
like eventually you have to start
shedding uh shedding pawns here and yeah
what's your compensation here
he's got to he's got to get his pieces
into the game and yeah not expecting
knight c5
excuse me
okay i apologize i think it's similar i
think if you go bishop b7 then we have
1977 yeah
that's so
ugly that's cruel that come on that's
pretty that is very pretty actually yeah
yeah it's it's just bad bad
and knight takes c8 knight takes a6 is a
very nice way of clipping upon yeah he
is now basically looking for the best
way to give up the pawn on a6 and maybe
bring some pieces back into the game
like knight ac6 here i guess yeah that's
what you play yeah and you hope actually
hope that white has nothing stronger
than knight c8 knight a6 because then
you play king 796 and you at least you
know get some pieces
uh
to to function you're still probably
completely lost it might be one of those
moments where kc3 you don't even have to
do anything with that qc3 a2 well knight
d4 actually is something that black
wants so king c3 i i very much start
with king c3 i don't think any human
plays the engine move here which is
knight b8
knight
b8 yeah you gotta defend your phone
true
true by the way that is that is a large
large roof and the problem is like if
you go on b8 a4 just collects you and
yeah inside yeah black is lost black has
just lost
yeah
and uh
it just
tom and i said zucchuang i'm telling you
it's working it's working i mean magic
is working i mean the production teams
you know asking for their master
certificates
[Laughter]
just mastery
you know you you watch enough of our
broadcasts
by this point they should be familiar
with some terms yeah
and tom says he's working on it
we're working on his german that's
germany fs7 f6 and now it's time
for the heart harvest the harvest
commences but just the question is how
right do you go a4 i very much like
such a pretty move it just makes sure
that the queen side is well and truly
shattered yep and there it is
recognizes
you know
gold when he sees it yeah
and the thing is you you
sometimes when you
finally get rid of some of your
weaknesses your position kind of starts
to breathe
this is not the case yeah yeah it yeah
it's like after it takes on a4 with
black you kind of want to trade your
three pawns for the one white combat and
you're not gonna get it
close you're not even
yeah the entire queen side is going to
disappear you will be you will be two
down and your position will remain more
power you can you can
lose in a very spectacular fashion by
going ba 4 bishop takes c4 bishop b7
where 97 actually is made oh that's
pretty i have to show that to our
audience because that's not that's not a
unique
pattern that we're used to seeing that
is not something that happens very often
yeah pretty
yeah and the next one is mvl on the
white side against wesley and then we
will conclude with uh lavon trying to we
assume come back
if necessary right if
if
wesley actually wins he wins the second
one yeah that's it the tournament is
just over the third one probably doesn't
get played knight day seven played yeah
you can even maybe
but i mean eventually you have to start
cashing in like take you can be [ __ ]
c5 is actually yeah if you want to
continue really like the uh
looks like a great move here wow king
before kings
on that subject um peter that you
mentioned if you know you lose a
weakness you get some play for it it
reminds me of dr john nunn he played the
tarash against
olf anderson
lost an isolated queen pond position
after a hundred moves the second time he
played the tara she blundered
the isolated queen upon him
he made him easily drawn because he
didn't have to defend him
clearly not very true here yeah yeah and
wesley is very much
aware he's gonna have to f2f3 is also uh
wow that's a lot of patience
a lot of patience i see you're also a
man of culture
wow f2 f3 just let's say you're a native
culture if you go bishop b6 it's always
met by 97 knight c5 doesn't really
improve anything although i think i do
it here just to
then bring it back to fa to c8 and hope
that drop the ac
but honestly whatever you're doing yeah
whatever you do but f2 f3
okay boss
f2 f3 is just such wow an annoying move
to face right like
wow there was one thing that could
potentially hang in the future so now
it's no longer not hanging now it's no
longer happening which variation was it
hanging none but now
by the way if wesley was behind on the
clock
uh guess what levon's got a bad position
in the
bad clock time too
45 seconds and g5
does not help your position yeah but it
avoids mates that's
yeah but as i said like eventually you
just go knight c8 knight c8 knight a6
and you win very comfortably agreed
just taking off the pawn
we we had previously also mentioned that
is an official overkill with
king c5
but it's certainly wesley uh just
enjoying the moment
with an extra minute my
extra minute extra minute extra position
he's good this should be smooth sailing
for wesley
yeah i i still remember there was a yeah
i don't know my take ca okay the harvest
yeah it was uh the return of gary
kasparov and wesley played a blitz game
with gary
where wesley absolutely absolutely
destroyed gary and gary came in and said
i felt like the amateur versus paul
morphy
i mean uh wesley can make you look bad i
mean he is really good and knight takes
a6 on the board
yeah this whole structure on the queen
side as alejandro mentioned you can take
that pawn on a4 but after bishop takes
c4 bishop even even king takes is not
bad just to get it to c5 as early as
possible take away some squares from
those knights exactly this pawn on a4 is
not being traded for this pawn on b2
king takes c4 looks like a very good
move
uh peter i like that a lot
yeah i think i think it actually is
slightly
cleaner than bishop takes well both are
completely fine well the the beautiful
part is you put a white king on the c5
square and it starts to dominate
these two nights the knights are just
black nights or just simply awful
yeah he has played king takes before uh
very good worms the cockles and so on
yeah
six we got king c5 i think here
king c5 yeah one one
not bad but i kind of king c5 is is is
simple i like that too
uh
no no no we're no no no no we're
we're we're the vultures just you know
picking
picking bones that's all we're doing
here at alejandro yeah
those are pretty clean these bones are
pretty clean yeah they've been
they've been
picked over
knight c7 to d5 97 is good but you could
also just go king before knight c5 take
on a4 and yeah you like everything is so
well protected on the king's side that
like there's just no counter play you
need to necessarily worry about
what about f2
but abandoning the the very very
beautiful post on
c5 feels like you know aesthetically
it's not as pleasing in some other as
some other solutions might be
but
yeah
i mean
this is this is the way you eventually
just need to remember he does play on
five second increment so he doesn't want
to leave himself
no time no you know five seconds is
generous i mean it's pretty good the the
these players are really um
i want to say
very well
uh trained in three versus two so
they're used just to having only a mere
two second increment
okay
finally uh lavon this got interesting
that he played king b3 there are not
king b5 but none of this should matter
really
i mean i would have i think you just
kind of
tuned out the fact that the b5 square
existed at all because i don't think you
ever not blaking b5 there
um let me catch up with the players how
would i do that how do i refresh
my
uh um
that's an interesting question i think
possibly
clicking there might work
or not
they're on a blitz mode there you are no
that's not good yep yeah really
this is a good enough shot at the moment
yeah the knight on e3 is going to come
to f5 where it controls the king
completely and he's going to have to go
back and uh at some point yeah it's it's
the sort of making of final progress is
the the question but yeah eventually
extra pawns yeah b3 king c3
you just can't post enough questions
with this material balance yeah just go
b3 knocking three is a threat with ideas
of before and making further and further
progress also you have zero weaknesses
and you are two healthy pawns up so
yeah linking before and now you just
need to create one thread here 73.
he's looking at h4 which i quite like
just push it to h5 so that h7 also
becomes
a future target gh is too horrible to
contemplate although yeah maybe
everything else is even worse yeah he
goes gh
knight takes i guess we're not spoiling
our structure for no particular reason
yeah i don't like giving up the f4
square either that the knight could
potentially go g64
but still of course completely winning
of course
yeah 97 knight c5 is you know arguably
counter play of swords but not really
i just have to give lavonne a lot of
credit because he just had such an awful
position he's doing his is his best yeah
he's lighting a level best trying some
to find some chances but yeah you just
the issue here is that your position
cannot really be improved you can just
sort of continue making moves but let's
say even if you bishop diwani and that's
why i think he just goes king due to
here
that night ending is completely lost for
instance if you go for that night ending
i think it's just completely and utterly
lost because
yeah because of your weaknesses on the
king side you never hold that exactly
but he's down to eight seconds you know
straight
too
yeah this is not like 93 check now and
you probably have to take take that move
back but he will gain some time you have
to yeah you have to keep playing
come on
king did he
yeah
well 93 also
still still fine yeah the yeah f6 f6 is
way too weak for black to actually
sustain this but you know 94 i guess you
go yeah king beethoven 93 check actually
was maybe
uh slightly suboptimal but
yeah this is the issue for one here is
that yeah he's won the bottom b3 with
check his position is still completely
lost like we go king d3 here or even
bishop takes b3 but there's no reason
not to start with king d3 because the
knights d3 the knights are not really
unstick
unstuck yeah
yeah actually except with the kbc
i wasn't even sure i was winning oh yeah
yeah that's a very good point
take on the
knight i would have actually gotten rid
of one of the knights yeah i'm very
worried about blundering some forks
somewhere exactly bishop takes b3 knight
takes p3 knight g4 really looked like
the way to go he played knight g4
immediately and as you said
he's leaving
lavon
knight a5 doesn't yes
that ain't it but maybe there wasn't an
eid to go for yeah just f6 and
f6 that's like
right right very conservative here in
ig3 i don't i mean it's still winning
why there's still two pawns out but yeah
game probably
could have been over by this point but i
i don't see how it still doesn't end
exactly as we've predicted
king e4 bishop b3
this is an improvement for for black for
sure levon is amazing at
finding these resources that you really
would imagine he has a look
look at the cheapo he's about to uh try
to execute
there's a fork
uh which is one reason why you and i
would have taken that
three year long
at some point right yeah i would have i
would have limited the number of nights
the first opportunity i got i would have
gotten rid of one of them yeah i totally
agree with that sentiment okay um
g4 and then i think we can reasonably
safely trade on
j5
okay
okay okay is it time for bishop g8 so
you take stakes h5
what weight up
how
those ones you sometimes don't win
what and he's not done it he's not done
he's improving on it he's gonna he's
gonna my gosh
has westley given no no no no you got
you got king f3 yeah king of three of
three you can still play but he will not
be able to play king g
three you'll have to play knight for
king f2
and then you you go take six for h5 yeah
you have to you know you have to
those aren't always winning and he's
done it yeah and there he goes
you have to take right yeah i mean he
probably is winning after night at 593
specifically after 93. it might be the
last
last moment to do it but it's winning
but this game
was so close how does levon do this i
mean he he's always skating on thin ice
yeah this is kind of it's somehow some
kind of dark magic but yeah right
it just feels like
f yeah he will he will convert this
still i guess you know f5 king f4 knight
4924 yeah the light on h6 is way too
passive exactly for the one to hold
those and time a factor no not really no
no no no
not anymore because
the one
yeah he he almost got there he almost
got there wow
f6 king of five king of six yeah that
rather plays itself doesn't yeah f6
king to f5
and he's done it and the king is
marching through
whoo
wow
yeah okay
what cheapo
can
as long as you can possibly slide out
yeah as long as you don't play h5h6 you
like if as long as you keep this
construction black cannot just challenge
it at all like king e6 king e7 just wins
the game
you're you're done yeah yes even even
for levon this will be too much to
overcome yeah okay just look at yourself
e7 and now it's a kind of yeah as tom
would like to tell us this one
knight g5 not h6 and f7 is not bad
you've also got knight t5 if you want to
be a purist of some sort yeah it's like
purist of some sort
i'll play i got this one
anyone he'll take i'll just play h6 and
just say okay
well a purist of some sort
of some sort and i'll just play h6 f7
king g7 knight g4 and this is where they
won resigned right
two seconds he does so casually he did
it no almost seven sorry seven seven
seven no it wouldn't there's no reason
to go down
finally
finally wesley takes down levon that was
a marathon game considering the position
of the opening which is
terrible i mean the entities survived uh
this long that was just yeah yeah that
seemed uh that seemed like it should
have been it should have been over and
done with but also wesley never really
let go he did not win it as quickly as
he could have or is clearly yeah but he
controlled all the forks he uh when he
got flustered by this
1992-94 idea he refocused realized he
can't step into the threefold
and
the night ending was one very very
cleanly in the end
and our first result of this playoffs uh
picks up a full point and
he will play against mdl i'll be able
this game he'll be the blackfish you'll
be black against mvl yeah okay for
wesley just ends the tie break there and
there exactly any other result makes the
third game a necessity exactly uh here i
just want to say at this exact moment i
mean after the mooking how you don't
take it just just just
snap
you you trade off the bishop you never
get forked anymore bishop takes me and
look what happened because down the road
you you guessed it
suddenly right here in this moment
you could lose your bishop there was a
night check
and then it happened again there was
another opportunity
right here pardon me where
again if you're not paying attention
there's a fork you get rid of these
tricky nights peter yeah that's the
moral of the story i think
the conversion would have been much
calmer if you had it done that but um
good enough yeah the result is in the
book it worked exactly
well for wesley yes it took a little
longer than you would expect but
computers say he was always in charge he
was always plus four from the moment
that he got that end game yeah i never
like oh yeah a little dodgy here and
there considering the amount of
resources that levon was able to find
but everything under control wow very
impressive victory uh
very impressive victory uh for wesley
absolutely and he has a bit of a
breather uh they will play in about
three minutes from now
so i'm guessing it's like a five minute
break uh yeah and vl uh
white has white against especially
um now i'm guessing in the case of mvl
and wesley where rapid and blitz chess
are concerned these guys probably played
a hundred games with one another uh
including friendlies of some sorts and
like buckhouse and things and probably
more but you're right
it's actually difficult to get to a
hundred i'm not sure they played uh
that's a good point a hundred but they
played like i think sort of uh
six and there's
60 easy but uh yeah uh yeah it's also
googlable so yeah alejandra is already
doing it so i'm curious okay what's the
over and under on 60
i'm thinking over 16. over 18.
okay
and alejandro will deliver the verdict
i'll go with 73 all together classical
and rapid and bliss combined oh i'll go
over i'm back
you go
he's just texting
he's just texting his friends
he's not looking you know i mean
somebody said so i was like i don't have
to look it up anymore
no no he's guessing oh he was guessing
fine okay
so you know i'm already there yes so
there's actually higher than way higher
i said over
yeah you were absolutely right it is
actually over a hundred
oh
how many do i get a t-shirt no hello
hello you can buy one
20 off today by the way yeah so on the
whole catalog hello the whole thing yeah
and buy the whole the chest piece
but you got to use the code
so it's a like 25 classical games and
then
their scores are level 1919 with 57
draws in in rapid and blitz time
controls
now i thought wesley had to begin
[Laughter]
1919 57 draw no that actually is
including the classical so wesley is
ahead in rapid then blitz by three
because he's down three in classical and
that's what i said yeah and the total is
105. yeah i really underestimated how
much they played against each other in
the last couple of years and here's one
more english from mvl
doesn't want to test wesley in this e45
lines
c4
c4
american passing a win wraps up the
tournament yes that's all he needs but a
draw is not it's not bad nah draws not
bad draws not bad
that would force him to be able to win
with black against lebon
yeah draw works really really well you
think about it
yeah so this is like a
soft match point here for wesley yeah
yes soft match point interesting
now
um
when you're up against an mvo and i mean
i know he's got in his repertoire you're
never playing the grunfeld right
um sometimes sometimes so but move like
d5 here
against mvo
think about it i don't know if it's part
of wesley's reputation d5 immediately
but
well there you have your answer e5
instead right
uh yeah i'm curious what unveil will do
here i think you will just play some
kind of a reverse sicilian e3 or
something
to work for g3 channels
yeah
there's a lot of choices of course
including also d4 which has more or less
been
refuted no i think this could this has
been shelved here i think yeah the dakes
and bishop before lines have been
analyzed enough to to convince most
people that it doesn't work yeah yeah
she does play g3 i think i played this
in one of the sync cups here with wesley
and one of the uh singfield cups that i
got invited to
wildcard yeah this is like the main move
uh these days
um well uh sasha grisha thanks to your
bud has made bishop c5 almost
single-handedly made it proved it to be
uh
playable possibly boris of the like
really really high profile players
possibly boris played it slightly
earlier than sasha but yeah sasha played
the tone of that and then it became
absolute
absolute mainstream was played in world
championship matches
since then
which is extraordinary because at the
time that i was playing my englishes
with bishop g2 i mean knight b6 was such
played yeah like
nobody even thought about anything else
right yeah but what we see on our
screens is exactly why they play bishop
c5 they they keep the knight on d5
because tactically it works out you
don't have to move it after bishop g2
when the bishop is on c5 specifically
and not on e7 because the bond f2 will
hang in some variations
and then they prepare for and play 95 f6
if allowed white of course could take on
d5 but black is not that unhappy about
those positions either
numerically yeah and uh i think it's
quite clear why you would prefer the
knight on f6 to the knight on the b6
it's just much more help me out here i
think it was at the american cup where
ray robson allowed ray robson played
rook takes c6 yeah and knight takes e5
and we were looking at each other saying
how do you allow yeah that was a weird
one but it was a completely different
line yeah how do you so the idea here uh
uh peter is that you imagine that you
played knight day four and you're
thinking to yourself my threat
is rook takes c6
and i was i was also very very surprised
by it but it was it wasn't here because
the bishop was developed the b2 which
makes the whole thing even more puzzling
right since it also gave up the pawn on
e5 yeah that was the point yeah the
entire the entire uh
game just uh there was no beast b6 by
the way yeah he played with g8 instead
rookie 8
which is kind of extraordinary if he
puts his bishop back on f8 yeah and you
were telling me about the joko piano
where the bishop on a7 went to c5 and
back to f8 wouldn't surprise me in the
slightest and what you get here like if
you compare this position with the your
typical knight b6 positions is
uh black managed to develop very very
naturally
black definitely did not have to and
will not have to commit to f7 f6 which
is a move that you often feel
semi-obliged to play in those uh knight
b6 lines because the pawn on e5 is
constantly ever so slightly vulnerable
and you're not in time to play rookie
but fate often
and here yeah black has just a very very
healthy uh setup where
um no particular weaknesses i think the
bishop does go back
all the way back to it i don't know i
don't think you play space seven here by
the way i think we do have a three a
five knight a4 and the board started to
interrupt you yeah then you go home yeah
i think
bishop d6 would be the other choice yeah
i don't think the space seven is very
much on the agenda but bishop six looks
normal
uh
[Music]
since uh it yeah it connects your your
pieces a little bit better you allows
you perhaps to meet knight c5 with queen
e7 which is not
uh not insignificant yeah
and generally you want to play 1964 here
which more or less instantly equalizes
at least equalizes for black the one
kind of a poor minor piece here that you
have as a knight on c6 which is sort of
slightly in the way
if you get to put it on d4 and perhaps
trade it off and play c76 blunting
bishop on g2 you're instantly instantly
completely fine yeah pretty much in
every single case uh something to be
said for maybe bishop e3
right possibly he chose he chose the
immediate knight c5 and here my question
is
can i maybe
take the bull by the horns snap it off
and go e4
b7s and we're going straight into it not
next time c4 and what is the problem
here i go rookie 90 rookie
i go knight e1
yeah but then of the bishop g4 you
i don't like this yeah this doesn't look
i mean you do have a three oh no you
don't have a three because queen before
check we'll pick up some heavy pieces
yeah and i don't i'm not a big fan of
this either uh sorry
uh knight c5 by the way i've been told
is a novelty up to this moment
everything was theory but now with this
move e4 i
i guess whether i like it or not i'm
going to be forced to take it and we're
we're actually following a game uh in
which kiril giorgi of beat anos geary uh
with them of bishop g2 e3 i think that
you were advocating for instead of uh
knight c5
bishop e d
to the e3 seemed like a decent yeah i
just had a perfectly reasonable position
in that game but then uh got
some without playing and we do have by
the way uh after e4 takes
knight takes e4 and the rook actually
dropped back to c2 do i throw in the
bishop f5 here
right i don't see anything i mean wrong
knight h4 bishop h7 yeah we're still not
unhappy about that right and i think
knight
with all of us bishop f5 and the point
is that if the bishop moves then you
take on d1 take on d1 and all these
discovery attacks on c2 i'm not a happy
camper
maybe it wasn't playable though can we
take one no let's say this b3
really
yeah queen g1 d1 and if you take let's
say on g3 i want to go rook c6 and i
want to claim that this comes out okay
for what
i could also start with knight g3 which
might be yeah what about knight after
six anyway i'm playing rook six oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah knight is
hanging out another two i want to go
ah yeah okay this one this one works and
that's what works this one works yeah
okay sorry so he's gone quincy one and
now you do have to consider whether you
want to leave white with that bishop
alive or not
um i don't think you do
uh i would be surprised this bishop is
oh where's my pawn grover
can i grab a pond how do you play knight
d6
sweet
ka-ching
that's a fun you could sacrifice the
exchange but this is like the worst
version yeah this is
awesome star wars maybe it's not like
well i still got a pawn with a tempo
right hello
look look look look look look nah 27
you're worse
larson man and he was pretty bad
wesley is gonna get a gold uh
certificate to the pawn grubbers
uh you know
as we're being told by tom brilliantly
if he wins he wins but what he means of
course he wins the entire tournament
of course not actually he wouldn't even
play against mexico there would be no no
reason yeah roxy firefighter
before i kind of expected that but uh
rookie two pawn grubber i'm telling you
you know gold membership to wesley so
in uh the pond grouper society
society grew from association
association bishop e3 chosen by all
trying to pretend that the rook is in
some kind of trouble but with a
premeditated sacrifice yeah but the
queen of six attacks i like bishop
a lot yeah
i mean queen of sixes
no
not no i mean 92 actually
i thought it was just kind of forcing
the the rook uh to be allowed out
because you the b two pawn is hanging
and there's no comfortable way of
protecting it but 92 is a reasonably
comfortable way to protect it queen f6
knight
so yeah i'm very much on board with
bishop before there's a little tactic
here of rook c6 and knight d4 right
because then rook
it's hitting a lot of uh
units is this rook takes c6 knight d4
which means
vision before
b4 is getting
getting my knot as well not only do you
get out of rook f5 but you also defend
c6 you neutralize the bishop on g2 my
goodness you add it all up and
it's a really good move
yeah once you spot it it's hard to play
anything else
you just need to make sure that there's
no way to attack the rook on into here
because it is currently slightly yeah
that is the most important but but there
isn't yeah as soon as you realize yeah
that white lacks the pieces to attack it
effectively yeah you like bush before
here
wesley wesley very much on point
uh in in the second game in the room
well i mean uh he he came he came for
this playoff and let's face it wesley is
finding all the right
all right so hugs how does this go
do you want he has to play rook d1 right
yeah what other ideas do i have here
none and uh try to meet queen f6 with
knight
d4 d4 i guess yeah but it doesn't seem
like it's much of a winning attempt
frankly
well i gotta do something yeah it's
still the best play yeah you you have to
otherwise your position just kind of
collapses at least in this case and here
we can even start by taking on g2
because the knight takes you to is not
the winning attempt either
it's just not i'm sad to say i do
remember
napo committing suicide in the dubai
sacrificing and
forcing
magnus to sacrifice an exchange which
was completely winning that that game
was just like the the
tell us you want out without telling us
you want out yes exactly exactly
okay uh we don't have queen on f6 on the
board but we are suspect we are
suspecting that
that will be wesley's choice there's
also not that many choices because i
think if one is a threat if i'm not
missing anything yeah that is
actually a very yeah but i mean 256 just
plays itself you you know
you don't know
all right here's the question do i take
on d4 because bishop knight takes d4
bishop takes d4 it's a bit annoying
actually is it i think so all right and
then which performance and then bishop
f1 because the queen doesn't stay
anywhere where it hits f3
oh yeah that is a good yeah i thought
just queen e6 and why is that a problem
but yeah one yeah he does stay
constricted
wesley wesley is just very very on point
he's pretty good pretty good
yeah and he's just saying look if you
want my rook at the cost of your light
square bishop that's okay with me and i
i will set up all kinds of
uh nasty nasty uh attacks on the light
squares
yeah i think and poor mvl is saying well
maybe
winning with black against levon
is a better chance by this point i think
yeah he needs to make sure he has a game
to come back to exactly exactly and you
can use to make sure there's still
something to play for because yeah i
think the the only way he doesn't make a
draw here is that he loses yeah exactly
yeah so
g2 now we take on d4 bishop d4 we put a
queen on some good square i'm guessing
e6 is the most natural i think e6 is
absolutely yes and after rook takes c7
the question is whether black is winning
somehow but if you want to make a draw
knight b5 makes an immediate draw
well spotted actually like white still
has to make a draw there because oh no
question about it
check is a very large threat but i think
maybe four holds
maybe i don't know
it's a big maybe yeah i started seeing
knight e4 knight g5
right right yeah there's uh actually
yeah you you can oh he's gone queen g6
which is
a similar idea i don't think it makes
too much of a difference
okay because we still have access to
queenie fortunately we wanted rook c7 is
more or less box
uh yeah because otherwise otherwise what
is your what is your play for the pawn
here exactly and clear now here the
question
the difference here though is if you
play knight b5 here roxy check now
becomes available which wasn't available
without queen on easter with the 36
which maybe makes white's you know
equality chances much higher anything to
be said said for knight f5 to the five
knight h4 yeah but i guess we go queen
f4 we stop it right he's gone 95 i'm
expecting queen of four
stopping that h4 check has to be a very
very high priority here you don't want
to get
mated i'm sorry but
the the choice between g6 and e6
is very peculiar he's gonna look ca
check also understandable he wants to
limit maybe he wants to take on b7 there
and pretend he's playing for a win well
there is rookie eight nope what am i
saying that
that's a one that's that's not a white
rook on e2 i was going to go rook takes
queen takes and play i thought you meant
rookie 28 in response to ruxia which was
i was hoping it was like a white
it's supposed to be a white rook going
to the eighth rank it's been a lot of
hours it really has
good morning st louis yeah queen takes
me seven years ago vintage b7 seems very
risky but i guess he feels right because
you need to cover the diagonal it's not
so much about the pattern which is nice
yeah but how do you reply to queen g4
though queen g4 in this position i eng4
with the ideas of knight h with all
kinds of knight h4 knight takes d4 i'm
also just simply attacking the bishop on
d4 so you have to somehow address that
as well i'll move the bishop to c5 yeah
let's go you know
65 rook c2 rook takes b2 maybe wins or
something yeah like
knight h4 is made
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you still have queen d5 you don't have
to actually resign but it's a cute mate
threat but after two i think you do
resign though yeah ruxin does
g3 though
he hasn't blundered it but like is it
what
you three king of flaws g3 king f1 and
the rook only two is hanging but like
queen e5 i mean i don't think it's great
which one's on d4 yeah i mean uh yasser
had kind of a
yeah yeah yeah yeah at the wrong
position you actually can't defend both
things that's hilarious
he made mdl
mvl my man yeah mvl with such an mvl
move what a resource
h63
quincy yeah i i mean i stopped at queen
g3 i thought okay h3 is clever but yeah
i thought okay blunders the pawn on g3
cannot possibly be good but queen jesus
christ
played yeah this is a huge improvement
obviously
uh i was about to say that but still
what do we play huge improvement or no
what do we play
bishop c5 now i can take a little queen
e5
you've given me a square that is
brilliant
giving me a square bishop c5 allows
queen takes g3 check and against king f1
queen e5 will defend the rook that is
marvelous that is really funny that it's
actually a and time makes the position
yeah king of one maybe
he sidesteps single queen g3 check but
now afterwards
yeah eventually some threats will start
yeah
knight takes still like fantastic play
by mvl sports it's ridiculous that's
right
that's watching that h3 is possible is
like remarkably remarkably good
but knight takes d4 rook takes d4 queen
b one check queen takes king takes a e2
though is quite strong right
a lot of hours of comments
[Applause]
why not just move the record c2 exactly
yeah that's what i was suggesting yeah i
keeping ideas and yeah
and you can lose the game immediately by
playing bishop c3 and allowing knight t3
check for instance yeah there's there's
a way to lose on the spot
um yeah i think ruxin is completely fine
i like rixie too it makes a lot of sense
rook e4
wow that's fantastic we're not guessing
any of these movies yeah that's very
fancy the question is can i not play i
mean i think what he isn't
no that can't be right i wanted to say
bishop c3 he wants to take on g3 but i
don't think that works
i'm not sure maybe it does win the f5
checking g1 i think we don't have enough
checks there i don't think why you would
have enough checks yeah the queen b7 is
just such an important defender even
though
yeah and the old wants to play with
that defender and he has played taking
away some squares from the the queen on
g6 yeah it is now it is not better for
white i would assume right it's extra
pawn yeah because we we somehow
weathered the storm it's it's the same
position but the pieces got all pushed
back right
h3 h3 is just yeah yeah
what a resource what a great resource
such such cool
pressure rook is maybe having to back up
the e6 right now i'm not going to have
to ever reply to bishop c3 i think it's
actually it's very important to have a
reply to bishop c3 here exactly because
white is very close to completely
stabilized and by the way i should have
queen of three there i can still play
bishop c3
rookie 6 on the board and if
since this has been such a great
turnaround by
mvl i mean wow yeah we could play off
you know we can still we can still go
bishop c3 here because rooney 16 f3
keeps everything together by the way how
ridic
ridiculous is it for us to imagine that
nbl wins this game
loses against lavon
and there we go yeah we have two
armageddons let's go but we thought only
one could
win the maximum
yeah
yeah and mvl if he were to win this game
he'd only need a draw to win he would
need to draw with the black pieces again
and again i mean we're talking about mvl
just
winning i mean how did he tie for first
to begin with and
now how could he win this playoff he was
absolutely
fine
he's still walking very much on the edge
here yeah and now oh dear what is knight
g3 yeah queen h5 is apparently very
strong here with uh
pieces starting to hang i guess the
point is after king juto you have rookie
five oh dear oh oh oh god oh dear oh
dear queen h5 great move
sets up this one
why why is it on c5 yeah why is it
looking why is it
he's done it if you go king h2 to defend
the pawn on h3 there's a rookie five
queen e5 knight h4 yeah and rookie five
spears the bishop
one of the one of the weirdest skiers
yeah you you'll see along the fifth
round
like drago queen d3 but there is 26
there in there you don't actually win it
back yeah you don't win it back you
don't win the knight we should probably
put that on the board what's what is
that
king g2 rookie five
what was the line queen d3 takes on g4
but you don't actually win the piece
back because queen g6 actually
solves the tactical issues
that is an issue he is going to play
king somewhere no i think he's going for
the rook but i'm not sure what that
could be
yeah rookie yeah you can't play you
can't play any rook moves here rook
moves all loses almost immediately yeah
that's okay yeah but what else is it
cause i king king
but allowing takes h3 is completely
insane like i don't know if you can play
like that what even can you play now
well i mean you know you don't want to
know the best movie yeah i have i have
back to i have good eyesight but yeah
the move the move that you're supposed
to play here not to be worse is kind of
unplayable yes and the second g1 and the
second one the second best is king g4
king g1 actually jifo makes an immediate
draw by force g focus
between b3 we go queen d5 and there's a
repetition repetition got it um yeah
bishop c5 was just such a strange move
like if you if you realize and he's
reaching for his age
[Music]
oh wait what happens after rookie five
here
rookie five queen takes rookie five
queen takes now but you can start with
kenny two and then rookie five and that
wins a full piece apparently
mm-hmm um
is
[Music]
yeah black clearly has enough
compensation though because yeah enough
yeah h3h4 definitely remember that
winning here ends the tournament so yeah
it's a big miss but uh we went from
white being much better to white being
lost jb
white being now perhaps equal but
yeah i don't think black risks anything
anymore with the uh the setup with the
queen on g4 and the knight on the 5.
and and
you're doing e2 and rook e5 that was
that basically ended the game at the end
of the game on the spot yeah time is a
factor peter absolutely yeah it's a it's
a minute and a half against a minute and
20 and
with only a five second increment this
will become obviously a very uh
significant factor the mvl is continuing
to be e4 protecting
it's not hanging anymore that's a big
yeah
yeah but you can go
a b a
any knight g3 sacrifices
steel doesn't feel enough because the
bishop on c5 and the queen on d5
controls so many squares that it doesn't
really feel like yeah also queen d3 is
always a charge yeah just trade
something nice that's important yeah
weirdly i don't see anything forcing but
you can throw in maybe g7 g6 so that b3
is never a check rook f6 yeah right
there is a very solid move as well yeah
i guess we got to move
because
he didn't want to go on h-file because
we're definitely running here you didn't
want to go to the g file because of h4
sorry and then we're
better again
i mean do you really run here of course
the f2 is defended by the bishop oh you
run
yeah
and remember the tournament situation
he has to play for a win i think it's
the only way yeah he realizes the draw i
mean
he still has chances but if he feels
playable
i think he has to i feel that this is a
game with your four acts and uh
what a drama is going on in this uh
play-off
this is this is so impressive this is
crazy and i i kind of thought he will
play it but still you know seeing him
actually do it on the board is very very
queen g6 is a kind of indication that
wesley didn't
didn't see
any way of pursuing the attack yeah we
can go king c3 king b3 here i think it's
reasonably safe on b3
i quite like it
i like the uh the king walk right across
the in person
rookie one is the best move on the
position rook ac i couldn't see a reply
to rook a6 which is why i wasn't
suggesting it
a2 is
a2 is covered rookie 5 or something and
well i mean something to be said
seriously like rookie rookie 5 and maybe
like where does the knight even go
oh my word what a strange position the
king on d2 is the light goes to d6 that
really is the only square and what no
but no but
then you go h5 and where's the queen go
yeah and then we go queen d3 check and
we win that end game right just h5 yeah
yeah yeah yeah
h5 no checks h5 is the way and then we
think that's the winning move for mvl
and the queen's come on and yeah once
the queens come off like we are you're
just completely and utterly winning in
that end game
precisely your king is so close on the
queen side and he's reaching four no
he's going for h5 this is so
unbelievably impressive this is such a
game i mean
i mean it's three it's crazy yeah it
included some blunders but like still
this is so unbelievably impressive yeah
queen of six queen d3 uh he doesn't look
queen f6
threatened by the way queen takes e5 if
you weren't watching there was a knight
c4 check but queen d3 we thought was
curtains he didn't do it he played f4
not bad
f5 so exactly
start yeah and then there's something
and they might end soon series of checks
and not good for white hold on but we
could play queenie four here before
keeping everything through all of those
things should be winning yeah uh
sorry let me get rid of some arrows we
can put that knight in in a in a pin i
like queen e4 slightly better because i
want to be able to meet rookie to check
with king c3 but i suspect both moves
should should win here i just go to g4
just so so cool on the fire here you
know
that can not be the reason you play
knight f5 queen d3 check but now he goes
g6 and he has knight takes g6 or queen
e4 g6 here and uh yeah this
i mean i assume white is winning still
fun
bishop e7 bishop b7 the game kind of
continues because rookie two queen a6
you don't have time to pick up the night
ten seconds remember it's just such
tricky nights yeah he could have
probably put this to bed by now but yeah
b5 wow
yeah i'm i'm no longer i'm no longer
sure he will win at some point i was
really like i was so impressed by some
of his decisions i thought you know mvls
yeah he just he just wins but yeah now
it's back to being a horrible horrible
mess because uh rook check and nike
potentially jump to g2 i'm not sure
about that by the way but rook check and
no the knight has to the light kind of
has to stay on h4 because hg you have to
have knight h6 as a reply i really like
rook a5 by the way
just introducing an additional kind of
point of uncertainty there like with the
pawn with the pawn hanging and now with
the bishop hanging now even rook c5
queen b6 how easy is that to win on 10
seconds on 10 seconds but he goes 24
yeah on 10 seconds you never win it i
think yeah well queen v1 queen he played
that like serious all game
three soldiers this is back to being a
three years old game yeah
yeah he played queen d1 with some oh one
second
one second he played queen c2 yeah queen
takes g4 maybe but yeah queen a1
king c4
become
two seconds one second less than a
second queen a3 wins no doesn't mean no
c5 is protected i thought it was winning
that's real i don't think hg though like
it's made it you get me
no hg what's going on the blinders of
what's what just happened he just
blundered a rook he blundered he
blundered
all of them pieces quincy one check yeah
wesley wins
i guess yeah queenie two is even cleaner
no it wasn't quincy
oh and now he's saying i don't even give
you a draw no it's a favorite game back
to me and wesley is like why did i give
that check one of my questions quincy
one was was yeah can we go kingdom
success and now we got a queen e6 check
on the board this is why you go king to
six yes and then i got to stop the check
from e6 oh very good very good attack
the pawn on f7 and just b7 at some point
will become a topic you know it's a and
he's dying it is better
no
f5 is no he's not seven and he loses on
time he loses on time
all the pawns on the king's side with
check and queen takes f7
what a turnaround wesley was claiming
tournament victory
and
lavon is saying
ani
the best thing that can happen
just happened
pretty much
it is his only hope now wow right
what what a finish there there we see
lavon with his wife annie and he's
sitting there going oh come on mvl uh
give me a chance uh to climb back into
this playoff what did we just witness
this year i mean it was just like yeah
that was a hot potato kind of game what
did i just watch yeah
what did i just watch and
how did you where's the end of some time
okay okay let's see he's got 10 seconds
so here he's
he kind of blundered with this queen
each queen was a bad move and three two
one just finished and queen takes a king
kingdom
best move yeah it's brilliant
and uh
he wanted to play queen five which would
have actually i think kept the game
alive potentially but i guess he got
scared about b7 understandably because
b7 is not something you want to allow
and he chose to attack the bishop on c5
kind of i guess for getting in
when the seven was hanging
right but at this time his clock is
ticking there you see it down to two
and now
he reaches and it's too late he wanted
to go to and he missed the clock as well
the the the thing there's another step
there with queen of five
cost him the game uh
because who knows what will happen
like there's there's no telling like
absolutely no telling what happened
after queen of five where's shaq yeah
that was that was a game come on
yeah
wow that was a game and a half oh my
goodness what a playoff this is
ridiculous alejandro final thoughts
we have one more game left these two
guys are playing we're gonna have two
more armageddon
[Laughter]
ahead of us we still have one more game
coming up in a couple minutes
at least one more game level two
armageddon and lavon is going to be
why why why isn't it
why does he win
and should he win then we will have two
mark two armageddon armageddon not one
but sure
so you know
yeah but but in a way this is also
i mean i understand i'm stretching the
point a little bit but in a way this is
also an armageddon game because it's
because it's because it's so yes must
win game for one right yeah that's right
basically yeah this is not a martial
compensation
so i mean uh everybody when we came into
studio this morning very very early
morning here in st louis we understood
that that the longest broadcast we could
possibly have is a broadcast that went
through a playoff with an a
armageddon we had no real
no idea that there could be two yeah
but honestly
uh
yeah i mean i wanted to say something
boring i don't wanna i don't wanna
but here's what's next
playoff game number three lebanon with
the white pieces against mvl and
remember for mvl since he just beat
wesley a draw is enough to clinch first
place yes it is in the super bad chess
classic romania 2022 so he just needs a
solid game he just needs to defend
against levon but levon is looking and
saying hey guys if i win we start the
whole thing again
everybody starts from zero we start
drawing for the armageddons and things
start on you so levon's looking at his
second life
yes exactly so a place where he's been
here before
double elimination i will mention the
america's cup
and vl's giving him a rather fresh life
here at this position and the one needs
to take it
yeah wow and somehow if we feel very
appropriate right if yes if it actually
went somehow i feel after this chaotic
game that we just saw to a bite
i have to say this moment where
we reach this moment where
after queen h5h4 wesley uh posted up
no it was the h3 moment that was the
moment though h3 was fantastic
that was fabulous we just saw this
incredible move queen g4
and
you know there's all kinds of threats
this bishop is hanging on d4 to the
night this knight could potentially go
eight night h4 and crushes onto light
squares
and
uh mvl played this move h3 and then the
moment we saw that we said blunder alert
queen takes g
is the best move but after the next one
you're supposed to see rookie seven here
nobody saw
like hollywood how do you see rookie
rook e7 i didn't see it did you see it
at the time no no no it's just
impossible but it it's a it's a
marvelous concept this idea that the
queen is on pre the rook is on pre pawn
on f2 is defended by the bishop and it
just
holds
and this move h2h3 and i think that
really rocked wesley's world as well
because when he played the move queen g4
you know
like okay let me get in there buddy
ready to go
uh marvelous stuff peter yeah fan
fantastic fantastic game despite
potentially like 10 10. oh yeah we're
not gonna go through every single
weight of that game just that one moment
was that moment was wow
right great stuff but it featured like
some some absolutely fantastic decisions
finding h3 in that spot by mvl also yeah
you know stealing himself to play king
one d2 sort of yeah
was really cool
so i i think that was such a great
decision into the mouth of the lion
exactly walk right into the attack and
here it is this king he won and let's
get going and
and as we get ready for this third and
final playoff uh once again it's
the situation
yeah the jinx is coming but okay
all right simple scenario everyone needs
to do is win levon wins we go to two
armageddons i i
this exists
it will be touring against if levon wins
but if mvl manages to hold off levon
that will give him tournament victory
this is incredible
and we have some kind of random sicilian
as the choice of levon c4
they don't want to test mvl in the main
line of the poison pawn either
no
kind of understandably so
quite a fair here to begin things there
we go thank you
just had to get that uh
my bleach has
age six
[Laughter]
a4 played and
what what earth is the point of this
move h6
it can't be that bad
but
what is it preventing
i have no idea what this is about like
zero zero clue why six is funny actually
zero clue why we spend the tempo on this
like no idea whatsoever
wow i understand h3 h6 is yeah i think
it's aimed against stage three because
he is he's winting he's waiting to
pounce right he he h3g5 h3 g5 yeah way
and you've got to go the way you played
3g5 in this tournament situation and
honestly i think no way
i think i think if i were left here i
would very seriously considering playing
h3 which i think is a bad move just
because it promotes g5
and look at what he did for by the way
he did provoke bishop to g4 h3
and if you thought you didn't understand
why he played h6 now you know it's
bishop
correct it's just to save the [ __ ]
that's right knight h4 i mean the
maximum actually spent the time to
analyze the bishop c4 sicilian because
nothing nothing would shock me anymore
like we're we're done with the shocks
yeah yeah yeah knight f2 let's go
yeah
but this is like the the perfect
position for the one considering the
tournament situation i'm i'm very much
doubting he's doing well
but who cares but no he's got the kind
of chaotic position that he knows it's
absolutely relevant what the evaluation
here is because you know 32 pieces of
the board and like a huge big mess
there's only one also a result that
counts for him also i'm not sure he's
doing so poorly because like i really
really just like but maybe that's fine
i am honestly i am honestly surprised at
how poorly the engine thinks of this
position for the one
really yeah
but you you can't stop the 65 and then
things start kind of spreading spreading
out well how bad is it so i take yeah
i'll develop wi-fi
bishop has to go
we just castle into it i have no
problems casting into it here yeah i'll
keep developing yeah bishop d6 or what
happened i certainly see
castling into it being fine you could
start with queen d6 too right yeah yeah
but even even this like i don't i don't
really see why we're doing so poorly i'm
not saying poorly i wouldn't wait for
white or black
i mean i was being you know polite to
by
has already been played onto the board
yeah mvl castles without a moment's
hesitation 26 was playable but yeah
could you actually maybe with the idea
of castling queen sign right yeah
exactly question queen said g6 wow so
was actually maybe a much more critical
choice i don't know if critical because
this is also about muscles yeah wow okay
hasn't been played yet excuse me
that was our analysis yeah uh queen f3
94 between g2
yeah but i don't think g5 ever really
hangs in those types of locations
knight f3 uh
bringing in
myself
hello
well okay i got it i gotta cover g3 what
can i say and then rook again and yeah
the bishop h7 looks silly but the white
setup in general just like okay
how about knight e2 and no 92 you're
going to play bishop f4 i get that
there's also something to be said about
knight b4 at some point yeah
right
okay yeah it's just very comfortable for
black and uh
[Music]
i keep on trying trying to find a way to
revive the bishop on h7 immediately but
we don't we just don't need to we don't
have to yeah we can play without for a
while
well the big the big issue right now is
we've got to stop queen g3 which he does
yeah king g2 uh rook d8
defending the pawn on d5 such a logical
move rook did c4 is so much stronger and
bishop you played once again kind of in
in full expectation of having to deal
with the potential opening of the g-file
eventually so you play bishop g2 but
yeah what your next move is
yeah so it's all it's all been played
it's all been played the bishop is not
before
tonight i guess we watch with much
regret if you want to keep the bishop
you put it on b1 and there's no choice
he doesn't immediately because he knows
there's no choice yeah at what point
how much do i have to prepare bishop
takes that five knight h5 quite a bit
right yeah 92 exists
quite a bit uh i'm thinking that from
white's perspective he's got to play
knight e2 and c3 as soon as possible to
liberate himself by uh by mbl yeah to
liberate his position this is just very
very comfortable for black
h6 eh h6 is the new way to play the
sicilian have you heard
who knew
because
the strong bishop on h7 yes yes yes
uh again i'm thinking 92
you play it quickly you know your
positions yeah i don't even have to
react i think the bishop takes before
ideas i'm pretty sure i'm
i don't think i was ever really
intending
no no then i drop it back to c6 and yeah
i'm just really really not sure what
white ever wants in this position
[Music]
knows those principles no tactics
involved here goes rook fe-8
exactly
okay well even so i got to do something
c3
knight c6 knight e2 to g1
trying to get some
some
squares and
play for my pieces the rook on a1 the
queen on d1 particularly pathetic at the
moment
yeah you have to somehow crawl out of
this corner and uh
that's if you play c3 if you play c3 in
bishop c2 i'm wondering if c5 c4 is also
an idea but i'm not sure i need to give
the d4 square to okay so the white
pieces i wanted to secure the e4 square
for the knight on f6 i understood i
understood but i'm not 100 convinced
that that it's necessary to even give
yeah i mean we can play slower
the problem that i'm seeing also is that
if i play c3 knight c6 and
i'm you might even have h5 eventually
eventually h5 will become playable yeah
yeah i'm seeing a lot of opportunity
what did he do he took him before but i
think that was that's amazing
yeah but he's eyeballing like you know
in a kind of a perfect world you just
get mated on the dark squares here this
is where h5
terrifies me g5 and and
[Music]
maybe even something like knight e4
might work in some positions but
why yeah
why why bother yeah why bother
there has to be actually like g7 g6 is
now i think very very playable yeah g6
is what the razer has told us but bishop
c5 i like bishop z5 rookie 3 you don't
really want to play d4 ever g6 played g6
by mvl on point on target opening the
position for his bishop finally yeah
maybe queen g2 but i guess we can have
like your bishop c5 and three right i
mean that's
that's that's a very uninvited guest on
the e3 square but g7 g6 yeah starts
liberating yeah starting to dig out that
bishop on h7 that makes perfect sense
and white's position like this king on
g2 without the dark square bishop to
cover it it's just yeah the moment the
moment one bad thing happens to the
right position probably is the first and
the last it's missing the dark bishop
it's also missing the light squared
bishop it's not gonna get back to the
defense can i uh suggest queen d2 yeah
but my point was even if the best move i
have is king g7 i'm still kind of fine
making it
i was hoping that i was going to
scare you i'm not very scared about that
so that's right you work
rookie before is interesting knight h5
is kind of a move that i would like to
make maybe
repulsive
that is repulsive
rookie two bishop f4
oh my gosh talk about being on the back
foot there oh
was played and the bishop is digging
itself out of a
honestly like i already started thinking
that maybe 94 kind of wins in some of
these positions but there's absolutely
no reason to hurry with it exactly you
just play king g7 you don't have to do
anything spectacular you're just better
i'm kind of you know
i'm a little partial to king h7 only
because you're king white's king is on
the g file and maybe on a good day
something could happen on the g file
partner stop defending h5 let's go yeah
h5 g594 right something something along
those lines
yeah and this is better than my original
suggestion simply because oh there it is
knight e4 on the board yeah yeah he is
enjoying himself
now
oh boy and then e3 bishop before check
and like white is just oh that's
destroyed completely getting completely
destroyed yeah
well he's playing pieces down yeah a
number of pieces down if you don't take
on e4 you're kind of completely lost so
you you kind of close your eyes and go
you take c4 like
and for envia what a turn of fortune
when you think about uh
what he was suffering a moment ago
against wesley and wesley had it all
under control
now he's a man in control of his own
destiny and winning with the black
pieces it just looks completely winning
i think it's just done yeah yeah wow you
don't even particularly need to
calculate it just looks like look at the
neverending time
he goes yeah i mean
four
and he just dropped back with his queen
one you go once you go quinty one you
kind of know the game is up
i assume there is some kind of i mean
bishop g3 probably wins on the sport or
something yeah
there's no immediate immediate wins but
pretty much every move keeps
all the advantage all the advantages
maybe bishop f4 queen is seven i quite
like guys guys any movements
it's okay we just need to let maxine
choose one the position plays itself out
every move that black makes that creates
a threat is difficult to answer even a
move like queen c5 is difficult to
answer hmm
yeah it's it it looks horrendous and
you know the shocking part about this
position is that this is actually cool
material we haven't sacrificed anything
yeah anything to get here yeah we're
doing this for free uh yeah exactly we
sure are we're doing this for free with
black yeah he's gone bishop g3 i'm
guessing
is the only move
dropping in
uh threatening potentially knight f2
yeah that was my initial impression but
i i struggled to find any kind of a
killing blow after rook f1 so i went
back on it
but i guess white still has no threat so
we can go i don't know h5 h4 here
like just i like cemented there at some
point you just take on e4 you hope for
the best and we do
i like h5 h4 a lot i like bishop f4 a
lot
yeah
maybe not the cleanest but it should
still be just to be very strong right
yeah
uh as uh yeah played you yeah alejandra
says
he's got his choice of wins uh
unfortunately for the boss
i think you have to close your eyes
take on e4 right pray that you don't get
mad absolutely because what what move do
you have in this position well you
shouldn't do b3
if you're going to suffer you might as
well uh suffer on a full tummy take the
night
take the night close your eyes
uh
yes i'm lost yes i know
but yeah it's it's exactly it's exactly
that kind of a situation yeah
even without the tournament situation to
take into take into account you just
can't make yeah exactly like you just
you just do it and by the way the good
news about it
you know what that bishop on a2 is now
finally finally alive yeah unfortunately
for you you probably get mater thank you
somehow give me one turn all i need is
rook f6 and queen f1 and i'm i'm back in
with a shout yeah a strong shot how is
how is the like queen e5 takes g5 looks
kind of good but i don't want to give
you time to play i don't know king h1
and then maybe rg1 queen f1 or something
actually rookie five is the only move
the engines think is completely winning
everything else is still playable for
both sides rook e5 95 g5 also is very
very good it's very logical but yeah i
also feel that this isn't as clean
optically
as the lines without
h4 and bishop gt bishop g3 felt a bit
like you were getting a bit sidetracked
right yeah come on he was cementing his
bishop over there next to white's king i
you can't begrudge him
that
rookie five
is uh it's a nice follow-up to the whole
um
adventure again with
with
with bishop g3 it's a it's a reasonable
move i think he's clock times uh four
minutes against five and a half four
minutes for 11.
four minutes against five and a half
well
do i dare i say it it's crunch time
i think we're gonna have to put a
maximum on the amount of hours per
product yeah exactly exactly it's done
it's like
it's like like like the uh the pilots it
was the pilots you know it can only be
aboard ship for so long yeah it was the
the very cheerful yak
that did it for me like i i thought i
lost you on that one
boom rookie five by maxime takes his
time but finds the move
i don't know why it's like so crushing
but you can kind of understand yeah
but i thought i thought king h1 c3
couldn't queen g7 i think ends the game
there right because you can't protect
the palm h3 no i was thinking about
queen d7 but 96 and i don't know ah okay
you make pretends
yeah okay
i understand yeah
look bad but yeah i'm surviving king
sort of surviving sort of surviving
no i've seen rookie fight for g5 yeah
rookie five let's say we go c3 or g5
king h1 here
and uh i thought q7 just ended the game
but there is knight e6
after which
black is obviously much better but the
game is somehow still a float right yeah
still flair is new as they say yeah and
as we saw from the previous game
yeah you know it's not over anything can
happen yeah yeah
i mean c8 may be stronger but yeah it
might be
a slight issue yeah that might be a bit
of an issue yeah
knight g1 when you put it that way yeah
i understand how does that hey guys you
know like
we're all a little ropey over here uh
we're all a little bit
loopy
over here yeah
yeah oh boy oh boy um
on the other hand other suggestions do
not come easy i don't know
indeed can i actually kind of do want to
play queen g2 just to make it kind of
make the make it the end please make it
that quick
misery
g5 king h1
and i still have knight of three as a
response to bishop before check so i'm
not there to the most to the most
obvious move in the position i assume
i'm dead to something there
i assume so too yeah
i think i know them i thought i found
something very beautiful there to show
but what's wrong with rick g5 here we're
[ __ ] h1 and yeah this is the position
i was talking about like how do we put
the
yeah this is this unfortunately loses
the b6 check or it would have been a
better move oh
nasty nobody can go like you put my
queen on b4 i didn't put my clean up you
even took a pawn dude yeah okay
then it's okay
knight three
is good honestly ah you're attacking my
bishop i'm attacking this bishop yes i
don't know this is if this is great
again the the clock times guys uh one
and a half minute four for lev uh
sitting solidly on five minutes oh he's
doing great on his clock as
lavonz is ticking down
um anything to be said for queen c1
queens he's going to rook f6 rook f6
yeah you have to wonder what the replies
are of the hg5 is though against rick g6
i don't know why you won my bishop that
doesn't improve anything he just goes
king h1 here well the difference now is
that any queen d7 moves he does at least
[Laughter]
the idea of taking on g4
none of this taking on f6
business
being a boring person yeah
okay one two one one more look bishop e5
queen here yeah take on g4 take on d4
and then you drop with the queen no i
mean here i just take on default twice
honestly even that yeah sorry sorry i
just think you fought the white so
somehow in my mind i had a pawn on c3 i
don't know exactly how it got nothing
yet
but rook f6 is going to be walking into
this
incredibly powerful bishop to d4 retreat
and that's johnny ball game yeah it's
johnny ball game indeed yeah sir seems
to be maybe the only clean solution here
but it should be should be very logical
yeah there's there are some pieces we
can attack here with tempe so why not
attack them with templates well the
engine thinks that b3 is also winning so
you can follow
so yeah
b three
at least supporting the knight on d4
yeah yeah giving him queen f1 in case of
queen d7 but yeah there has to be a way
to win this by force and at least he's
not forced to resign right you keep the
game going keep the game going you hope
you're understood that's what it's all
that's about what the fight is about
here for lavon he's doing a good job
he's done a good job throughout the
tournament not having to resign so many
positions where you're like okay dude
that's it resign yeah just yeah goodbye
could you please yeah could you please
yeah
apparently apparently rook d6 rook of
six is the way to actually put it to bed
i'm going to be teasing lavon for ages i
mean it's going to be like you know
lavonna rooney and teaches you chassis
and we're going to have all of his games
forever from bucharest where he was on
the back foot and time and time again he
saved lost positions
yeah yeah mvl is so on point
by the way so on point
along with because you kind of do want
to stop queen f1 when the fun would
allow white a semblance of stabilization
there but now it always gets hit by rook
df6 and has no squares again has to go
backwards exactly i actually love that
that is such a such a nice move and then
when you put the rook on f6 and you take
on d4 and now can you do something
right yeah and at some point here that
one remembers he's playing for a win
along with the 10 000
bonus for the winner
uh
the winner
will get 12 gct points um yeah yeah for
this first competition
not 13 yeah the one the one slight
dampener on on the proceedings 22 plate
but yeah you just go queen d7 i guess
right oracle dc like 27 forcing
something or not really forcing nigeria
i thought it was forcing 91 but there is
queen e3 which i assume loses to g3 but
why bother
rogue gf6 is also of course completely
completely okay
absolutely the one finding a way to
continue though once again yeah right
three maybe the the one way not to give
up straight away bishop takes d4 you're
going to recapture i assume with the
pawn
in order to keep the rook out of g3
don't make me make moves i know i mean
yeah exactly exactly don't don't make me
make it
and he friends don't let friends please
friends don't let friends drive right
yes very nice yeah rook df6 rook g1
played by the one so he's actually
yeah we look at him he's like okay
i've got to do something and i've got to
do it fast
well
move good move by lavon
i mean rook takes knight takes and we're
still kicking up a fuss
very much so actually after
rookie 191 it's not even that easy is it
yeah
right yeah
apparently apparently rogue g3 is -8 but
only
your your vision finally
yeah yeah it's bishop jesus bishop okay
yeah okay yeah that would make that
makes more sense
it's a movement
[Laughter]
in the best way possible yeah
yeah 27 27 chosen by uh by mvl that's
it's pretty clean yeah queen
you got it they can go knight g1 that's
the only literally the only thing here
fifteen seconds for levon aronian and he
has captured there it goes yeah and
knight won but the position remains
horrible uh kind of horrible yeah all
the end games are lost as well like if i
take on c3 and take on d4 here like all
all of those positions are also
completely lost exactly because yeah
having to defend the pawn on h3 has
played the move knight g1
yeah roger iii looks natural but
i'm just kind of like reeling from b4 p3
i was like what
now you
come on
[Laughter]
oh
we have had
i want to just say a big shout out to
the players we had a great deal of fun
um
analyzing your games and sharing our
views with our audience
i thought this was a great fighting
event
absolutely the number of decisive games
may not have been that high but boy they
were full of content and it was really a
great joy
uh to follow these games
and working with yourselves and
the good folks in romania bucharest that
was really fun too
so uh
thanks to everybody yeah down to 30
seconds and the game is still somehow
slow going yeah i know the reason we're
still here is because this could still
turn around guys lavon somehow has
gotten and it's 20.
he'll soon be 15 and at that point you
start getting nervous exactly and
why he hasn't played rook g3
yet and it's ten seconds nine take on
defense do it just take on d4 and what
yeah that
takes a4 and accordingly
he's barely better
but he only needs a draw though so yeah
at some point
[Laughter]
he's doing it from a position of
strength
yeah he's clearly kind of
let go of much of his advantage but yeah
yeah but it's still yeah you're not
losing it doesn't mean f4 i'm telling
you guys queen f4 yeah 4392 or something
yeah yeah okay
don't go e3 look at this
don't do it level oh
[Music]
wow
and again three results possible bishop
takes b7 put it back on g2 and play yeah
yeah why not i don't even know why he
didn't take on b7 yeah if you're playing
bishop g2 anyway why not just you know
snack snack on the b7 pawn as well yeah
wow
guys guys the game is flared and new
guys yeah this is a new game this is a
whole new game yeah white has queens e4
two armageddons like
knight h4
and it could be two armageddons coming
up uh look at this 95 yeah
95 certainly it doesn't do much here and
the b the b pawn will start being a
destruction yeah oh deep deep is rolling
yeah
okay the deep one is rolling guys i'm
telling you d6 is the big threat i think
we in d6 right yeah
now i can reposition my knight knight 94
is the move
as a move on 934
no rook f6 knight g3 threatening d6 yeah
rook f2 but he goes 93 anyway yeah
knight three it's a whole whole new
thing yeah it's a whole new world it's a
whole new thing yeah laundry iii
wow
guys this is
[Laughter]
today
it's not friday the 13th but it could
have been i mean it feels like it was
my goodness
how to play
chess king h2 yeah quincy two we can go
quick queen e4 if we need to and we kind
of need to we don't we can't trade
queens here
no
no we cannot but we have to defend g2
and we do have to keep
yeah this is a king of f8 is a very very
very good yeah because like the five and
allows queen to fortune as we mentioned
yeah you can kind of push the h pawn
king h i just played f4 there but okay
yeah
get the key out of john dodge or some
thread right finally there's a threat in
every single something like d6 perhaps
but queen thanks to six unfortunately
okay threatening knight e7
alert alert rookie two cookie seven is a
thread
rookie two rookie two
four feelings quincy four let's go
queen see oh still a game threatening
mate is it threat of mate where's the
mate quincy it is kind of i mean with
nothing kind of a made but it's not made
so you can go b2 here but i don't know
if he can go b2 he's done it
i don't know if he could do it either
but what is chad runs yeah then it runs
i think he's still again again we're
running
no yeah oh my god but there are no more
checks and black will have checks
gets there
quinty three will will win right quinn
yeah and he flagged he flagged oh i
wow
that is quite something yeah that that
whole that whole tie break from start to
finish was
was quite something
[Laughter]
guys
guys that was uh
that was an adventure and a half i mean
uh
wow maxine
our winner and our great congratulations
and the suffering peter
that was there well
yeah uh
yeah
you know technically he won both games
on time but he was winning in both final
positions right
yeah that's that's not really how how it
ended but yeah we alejandra is standing
there with this kind of a glaze
trying to process what we just watched
what did we just watch
what happened what happened today i
remember wesley i remember
i remember calling
a live on draw against shaq
like
yeah like like two or three days ago
yeah exactly the symmetrical position
and suddenly we had all of these rapid
games and i don't even remember the
lavon wesley game anymore i have so many
things on my mind
i'm i'm going crazy guys i'm going
absolutely crazy let's see how this
finished up because it is mvl that
crowns himself winner of the 2022 super
bet chess classic in romania obtains 12
gct points and goes home with 77 000
not bad at all an extra 10 over wesleyan
levon who split the gct points
in that one
wow let's just
wow and of course
down the list fabian linear get six each
that's quite valuable for them uh bogdan
was the world car wild card for this
event farouja nepo three and a half each
and a disappointed mamedyarov and
rapport there with one and a half points
rounding out the table
so many stories about this event and
again a big shout out to bogdan i mean
to score 50 percent of this field is
really uh most
admirable and absolutely well
definitely you know
after today
the the talk of the town will be of
course that that tie break but if we if
we you know
take the classical portion into account
i'm pretty sure the romanian organizers
who uh definitely wanted a romanian wild
card in the tournament right
they would be delighted with this result
they should be delighted with this
result
um a little stunned about ali riza uh
pushing uh mvl into the playoffs it
seems like uh
at a certain moment their farouza just
kind of lost
rude touch with the reality he was
pushing an advantage that was no longer
there yeah i think i think he
kind of
as you described he
all his even though we criticized some
of the decisions uh let's say the
decision to keep the knights on the
board
he mathematically made his advantage
smaller
but the way unveil reacted to it
actually gave him an additional shot in
the game and and then he left himself
too little time and perhaps overstepped
the mark like he made one
one aggressive move too many yeah and uh
ended up paying the full price for it
wow and for wesley so who had played
such a marvelous tournament undefeated
cruising in the playoffs he just looked
at uh regal and then suddenly it was
like for the first for the first game in
the half of the playoffs it seemed like
there will not be a game three exactly
and one precise move in that game
against mvl and game two of the playoffs
would have actually stopped playing stop
the playoffs rookie five i think or
rookie five a little bit earlier right
near the end of the game right uh but
yeah mvl capitalized
fabulously uh in that game and i mean
none you know the swings later in the
game
and there were some swings yeah there
were some swings you know what the
surprising part is he white was never
better
white i know there were some draws in
that game but at no point did levon like
fully make it all the way back where he
was winning remember he needed a win yes
but raw was no good right he found a
perpetual he had to say no that's not
good enough and here's the final look as
he flagged as he was making us move
knight g3
but there you go it's uh
on time yeah he is potentially lost in
that position
in the final position before the move
knight g3 he's already lost but before
he plays queen c8 it's still a draw so
i'm crazy actually i'll put it here
because we have time to kill sure kj
this was the position that they had and
queen ca check was a losing mistake
according to the engine of course on
five second increment right difficult
this absolutely
this v4
so you can hunt this king not this way
but that way where it has no defense
would have been a good move on three
seconds and in three seconds you're
starting to wonder
lavon is a hard man to kill
look at that move that's funny we're
looking for us also rookie four is a
draw yeah
you're not gonna mate with justice
yeah that is funny oh come on and beat
her i mean you just gotta appreciate the
beauty behind that move
is it unquirk's queen she won yeah if he
actually goes before there is like
arbiter
i want this guy wandered
wow wow
wow
great fun guys it really really really
was
and we have more coming up not a joke
seriously warsaw the grand chess tour
will continue in just a few days it's
the 18th isn't it it starts
everybody's opening ceremony on the 18th
and that will be uh three days of rapid
two two days of blitz
and i understand
um
we have a different romanian uh player
uh originally we'll wait we'll wait for
final confirmation
and let's jump to bucharest for our
closing ceremonies
after nine days of intense and emotional
chess action we are finally ready to
crown a king i am joined today by
augusta druggish the super bad
foundation president michael kodakowski
representing the grand chester as well
as our victor maxim vasher lagrave
michael i'm going to give you the first
words uh thank you christian we just
concluded probably the most exciting
start of the season for the grand chess
tour with three-way tie for first place
uh with the clear winner right now uh
maxima alligraph from france
i would like
uh to congratulate our winner as well as
all
uh
players who played here an exciting
first leg of the grand chess tour i also
would like to thank our sponsors
superbad foundation
one uh
united properties first bank and
many many fans who actually uh
crowded
not only
this
whole
but also
where online and tens of thousands of
viewers
today
look and watch this exciting round and
exciting tie break
and i would like to pass the microphone
to the president of superbad foundation
augusta draggage
thank you
it's a great pleasure and a great honor
to have again gran chester and thank you
michael thank you all of you to have it
here for the third time in bucharest and
to see how many people so many kids they
are around this is the big
the the big pleasure of us to have as
many kids around the chest
so i'm thank you for the players and
especially for maxim and i'm happy to be
now
the second time in the position to offer
you a prize i remember last year on
zagreb and i wish you to happen on this
situation as many times so
congratulations thank you to everyone
and please
thank you
so here is the prize it's yours
congratulations
maxim first of all uh i would like uh to
give you the word tell us about your
initial thoughts and feelings right now
after this incredible tie breaks
of course i feel very good
but
i'm surprised i haven't
fainted or something it's been a very
long day
but yeah
[Music]
all in all a
very good day for me like i won three
games so that's definitely uh
very positive uh i want the tournament
um you know after uh
helping me come back from uh you know
tough uh
few months where i was trying to qualify
for candidates and didn't manage so of
course it's a boost of confidence and uh
in general of course i would like to
thank uh
first of all the organizers for putting
up a great a great event and absolutely
a stunning event uh including the
opening ceremony at the parliament
and uh of course i would like to thank
my my family my friends everyone who's
cheered me up in in the last
in the last few months and uh
helped me you know get
get back my energy
maxim you came into today's round with a
titanical task ahead of yourself you had
to beat ali reza ferruja one of the
hottest players on the circuit with the
black pieces how did you approach
today's game
i decided to play a very normal game
because i knew that ariza would not back
down from a fight
and actually tried very hard to win uh
as much as he could and
at some point he did uh backfire badly
you won that and then you had to wait
and see what wesley against aronian
and wesley won you were facing wesley
after that with the white pieces almost
in a must-win situation how did you
leave that moment in that game
yeah that's right i was in a muslim
situation and i added not any
preparation because i was just trying to
recover from uh
from the exhausting game i played with
alireza so
i just you know figured things out at
the board of course opening didn't go
well
and at some point um there were some
very scary moments but i did find some
uh
some tricks uh this h3 move for instance
uh where contact g3 doesn't work
and uh
yeah in the end i think it was a comedy
of blenders but it was such a
complicated position and five seconds
per move it was bound to happen that was
an incredible display of intense chess
exactly what we like to see here at the
granchester maxim you have so many fans
around the world here in bucharest as
well what do you have to say to them
yeah just uh thank you it's you know
always
great to feel the support to feel you
know people waiting for you and
you know
like
again what uh
during the event i was approached and
stopped
by all the
the romanian chess fans i
i probably have received tons of message
by by now but i will check that later
ladies and gentlemen the 2022 superbad
chess classic winner maxim bashir lagrav
thank you christian and we definitely uh
to all of the fans join in our applause
of what a just an outstanding effort i
mean it takes an effort like that peter
to win a tournament like this absolutely
first and forever
uh
very very nicely played by maxim
he actually is kind of rare in a
tournament like this to to be able to
win three games in one day and he did
win every single game today
not bad
not bad at all considering the level of
a position and uh yeah he should get
some some food into the system at some
point
yeah
and let's count down our uh top
competitors starting with number 10 and
going all the way to number one peter
yeah uh
richard did not have it
that was a tough event for ray
all of his courage all of his creativity
were not rewarded as he made some of the
great
great howlers of at this event ooh
blundering a rook blundering a piece is
not good
yeah and the similar things could be
said about uh shah he did
manage to win a game somewhere along the
way which makes it feel slightly better
you would say but as a defending
champion after a plus three effort last
year i mean no but the game that he won
thank you shaq continuing uh on the
topic of people who will be kind of
badly disappointed by their results
yandy pomnishi who left a lot of equity
on the table there he certainly did he
certainly did including a full point
swing against shock in the game we were
describing which is quite
rare and
next to him tied for seventh is alireza
fergie who actually lost two games with
white
uh wow uh yeah both of his losses came
with white one against nipomnishi early
in the tournament which was an absolute
brawl of a game yeah uh and and also
today where he clearly could have made
the draw like for the first half of the
game could have made a draw on every
single move of the game and continued
pressing and pressing and pressing and
eventually uh being very short on time
pushed it a bit too far and a local hero
bogdan with a fourth position at 50
percent are uh salutes to this young
player yeah very very nicely done could
have arguably scored even even higher
than 50 percent definitely a very very
credible credible performance
for fabi not a not a performance that
he's going to be proud about at all he
just didn't seem to get into his groove
not his proudest moment not his worst
moment certainly he's had disastrous
even in bucharest last year i would say
it was a disaster but this year
not great time for fourth yeah picks up
26 000 maybe one or two rating points as
well
and then yeah then we have one more
person on 50 there but how we got to
that 50 percent feeder come on yeah it
was not it was not a very linear type
first
decision
he he and the mvl tied for first in the
number of decisive games in the
tournament two wins but two losses for
lanier and also um
the man with uh the cat with nine lies
boy did he survive and he had somehow
gotta he tried to use one against
maximum but he just didn't have enough
he just ran out he ran out of them
but lavonne a hat uh a salute to you my
friend that was really a remarkable
performance very very strange
performance wesley what a tournament i
mean it was a very wesley event it was
very smooth he gets two points early
doesn't risk just gets very nice
positions pressures a bit when he's
given a chance doesn't take risk finds
himself in second and he was moments
away
moments away yeah
that he won the first game of the tie
break that game he won against uh
against le mans it's just a
positional masterpiece truly considering
it was a ten plus five games just a very
very clean game
uh and then yeah just one one more
correct decision against mdl and the
tournament is over in his favor but no
and look at who our winner is uh maxine
coming out of nowhere we thought
that his tournament was more or less
lost when he lost it in round seven
what was
which game did he lose which round did
he lose he got destroyed by levon yes in
the uh
vienna in the vienna he walked with his
kingdom
we thought that was goodbye
mvl but boy did he come back today he
came back with a fury right i mean he
came back two wins after that to be able
to catch up to the leaders yep i think
that was a great
a great fall back there for maxim i love
this tournament guys this was fun i ca
i've casted a lot of round robin
tournaments of this type some of them
are absolute snoot fest i remember so
many events where we look at the games
and we just have nothing to talk about
and this one man they just provided
entertainment five brawls every single
round so many of these rounds we thought
okay one decisive game but who cares the
content was there the fun was there a
lot of people tuned in to watch it and
remember we have more tournaments coming
up for you we're gonna take a three-day
break yay i don't know what you guys i
needed i had a three-day break and we're
gonna come back with warsaw rapid and
blitz coming up the grand chester
continues a full summer of chess coming
your way this is going to be a lot of
fun i had a ton of fun casting this one
with you guys can't wait to start all
over again in a few days i uh suck at
that completely a big shot
for his correct picking of uh lavon
to tie for first that was very very good
the prediction game was
convincingly crashingly crushingly won
by by varus yes yes it was the only the
only the only one of us who picked
somebody who is actually in plus by the
end of the tournament
yeah so so well done to yuvar and uh
thanks very much to to our production
team who made it all run smoothly
despite all of our attempts to you know
zap it derail sabotage and otherwise
otherwise otherwise destroy the
broadcast yeah yeah uh thanks to tom and
the the rest of the production team
we'll be back in i will continue
insisting it's four days time not three
excellent 15 16 17
more more rest time for me yes
thank you everyone for uh sharing your
days with us during these broadcasts i
hope you enjoyed them as much as we
enjoyed delivering them we'll see you
for warsaw bye for now see you then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited